Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie hast du die Woche verbracht?
Doch recht viel vor den Nachrichten. Du auch?
Bisschen.
Ja schon.
Ich bin jetzt nicht wach geblieben bis 2 Uhr nachts, aber ja.
Ich auch nicht. Das zeichnete sich ja dann doch am späten Abend ab, dass irgendwie miteinander geredet wird. Ich bin schockiert darüber, dass man von der Bundesregierung eigentlich nichts dazu gehört hat, dass Donald Trump dort verkündet, eine Zivilisation auszurotten. Und der einzige höherrangige Politiker, der aber ein Politiker AD ist, der sich dazu kritisch äußert, ist Peter Altmaier, der quasi aus dem Ruhestand heraus bei Twitter mal schreibt, dass das so nicht geht. Und sonst gibt es dazu eigentlich gar nichts. Es ist so skandalös, und dass überhaupt die Situation entstehen konnte, dass man also nicht vorher von Seiten der EU und von Seiten vor allem der Bundesrepublik sich vehement gegen Trumps Kurs und auch gegen Netanyaus Kurs gestellt hat. Und Netanyau ja immer noch gewehren lässt, der jetzt ja gerade dabei ist, den Libanon Stück für Stück dem Erdboden gleich zu machen, ist für mich skandalös. Also ich finde da kaum Worte für.
Also ich finde auch, ich war jetzt noch nie im Iran, will aber mal hin. Denn bei meinem Lieblings Afghanen hier in Banosviertel hängen Wandteppiche, an denen die persischen Städten, ich weiß, ich habe keine Ahnung, von damals wahrscheinlich gab es noch keinen Unterschied zwischen Afghanistan und Iran oder so. Deshalb da, oder übersetzt man diesen Text mit seiner Translator App und ist ja also ist ja eingestrickt, wird trotzdem erkannt. Buchstaben, von denen man denkt, gehört das schon zum Gemälde oder ist das inhaltlicher Text? Dann steht da so 4000 Jahre alt. Und das will man ja eigentlich mal sehen. Und wenn dann so eine Zivilisationszerstörung angekündigt wird, ist eigentlich ein angekündigter Zivilisationsbruch. Ja. So. Und wir wissen ja, im deutschen Strafrecht Mord, Mordversuche ist im Grunde das selbe. Ich war, weil du jetzt so sagst, es zeichnet sich ja ab, das und so. Man weiß ja immer nicht so genau, was im Fahrwasser der Geschichte so passiert. Es hätte ja auch sein können, dass man morgens aufwacht und dann heißt es, ja, die Chinesen sind jetzt auf Taiwan gelandet.
Ja.
Weit und breit kein amerikanisches Schiff, nicht mal Satelliten in der Nähe, die das beobachten oder so. Alle gebunden bei so einem Manöver. Und von daher würde ich das jetzt im Sinne von puh nochmal gut gegangen nicht geschehen, nicht durchgehen lassen.
Nein, das sowieso nicht.
Sondern es gibt große Erklärungsbedarfe, finde ich, von unserer Regierung. Anscheinend saßen einfach alle nur zu Hause und haben so gehofft, dass nichts passiert. Ja. Und es ist ja nichts passiert. Das Drehbuch für Beirut kennen wir aus Raffa.
Ja.
Also jedes Haus muss zerstört werden. Man sieht ja auf Instagram diese Videos, wie einfach ganze Dörfer gleichzeitig gesprengt werden. Wo man sich fast denkt, machen die sich einen Spaß daraus. Also wird das erst verkabelt, wie bei so einem Sprengunternehmer, der hier so ganz vorsichtig nach Haus springt. Es ist alles sehr betrüblich.
Zugleich wurde in Israel die Todesstrafe für Palästinense eingeführt.
Ja, und mit Champagner begossen.
Da gibt es auch ein Wort für, ich glaube, das heißt Apartheid, das dann fallen könnte. Es ist so dramatisch und es wird von Seiten der EU, also jetzt Spanien mal ausgenommen, viel zu wenig widersprochen. Und von Deutschland ist ja gar nichts mehr zu erwarten. Also alle gehen auf Tauchstation. Hier ist man ja beschäftigt, dass man nicht mal die eigenen Gesetze kennt, die man verabschiedet. Da muss dann jemand aus der Frankfurter Rundschau mal nachsehen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Das ist doch alles absurd.
Müssen wir jetzt wirklich alle Gesetze selber durch unsere eigene KI lesen lassen, weil es niemand mehr tut? Also das ist ja wirklich Redaktionsschluss, sonderesgleichen. Also wir reden über diese kleine Floskel bei der, oder Klausel, bei der im Nachhinein noch Rätselraten war, ob sie jetzt überhaupt gilt oder nicht. Ja. Dass wir beide uns jetzt melden müssten, falls wir keine Ahnung, ins Ausland gehen.
Drei Monate ins Ausland gehen, dass man sich dann meldet, dass man sich beim Karrierecenter oder wo auch immer bei der Bundeswehr abmeldet, wenn man männlich ist und im Alter von 18 bis 45 Jahren. Das ist so skandalös, dass ein Redakteur der Frankfurter Rundschau das mal nachliest und dann mal seine Konsequenzen daraus zieht und man dann ihm erst einmal bei der Bundeswehr gar nichts dazu sagen kann. Das Verteidigungsministerium dukt sich, stellt sich tot, erst einmal bis dann irgendwann Boris Pistorius sich auch nicht so recht erklären kann. Und ich frage mich auch, haben wir eigentlich im Parlament noch eine Opposition sitzen, die diese Gesetze liest? Also was macht eigentlich die Linkspartei außer TikTok-Tänze? Muss ich jetzt sie auch mal fragen, weil die auch immer nur so handzahm irgendwas gegen Aufrüstung und so weiter, aber auch wir brauchen Sicherheit. Dann muss man sich auch mal mit den Maßnahmen, die jetzt da gemacht werden, auseinandersetzen, damit man zum Beispiel auch seine eigenen Leute mobilisieren kann dagegen. Wenn man dann aber selbst davon überrascht ist und dann einfach nur beklagt, was wirklich von Teilen der Linkspartei kam, von den Grünen natürlich auch, aber da erwarten wir nichts mehr, dass das Gesetz sei schlecht gebaut. Nein, das hat nichts mit schlecht gebaut zu tun. Das heißt hier, dass Männer plötzlich an die Kandare genommen werden sollen und sich dem zu fügen haben, weil das dem Staatsinteresse dient. Und ich habe mich auch sehr aufgeregt, dass dabei so Leute, die über Ole und alle, die gegen Wehrpflicht sind, hergefallen sind, wie zum Beispiel Florian Schröder, plötzlich sich darüber lustig machen und das alles ganz skandalös finden, dass es jetzt dieses Gesetz gibt, dass man sich da melden sollte. Nee, das ist die reine Konsequenz dessen, was Ole und die anderen immer ausgeführt haben. Und ich finde es noch skandalöser, dass dann Boris Pistorius sich zu Wort meldet und Folgendes sagt, das wird dann überall zitiert und so getan wie, ist er nur halb so wild, also alles in Ordnung. Boris Pistorius sagt, derzeit ändert sich für die Männer nichts, ob 17 oder 45 Jahre oder dazwischen. Alle dürfen selbstverständlich verreisen und brauchen derzeit dafür auch keine Genehmigung. Zwei Mal derzeit in einem Satz bedeutet, naja, genau derzeit nicht, aber morgen kann es schon anders sein. Und dass man da nicht entsprechend mobilisiert dagegen, dass das einfach so durchgeht, wo alle sonst immer eine Freiheitsberaubung sehen, wo kleine Stellschrauben verändert werden sollen, finde ich wirklich absurd. Absurd sage ich heute schon viel zu häufig, aber anders weiß ich es nicht mehr zu beschreiben. Und finde es im höchsten Maße skandalös, dass es nicht skandalisiert wird. Ich finde auch erstaunlich, wo sind eigentlich die großen Demonstrationsaufrufe, das vor der amerikanischen Botschaft demonstriert wird oder irgendwas. Wir haben einen Manfred Weber, der bei Lanz sitzt und sagt, dieser Krieg ist im deutschen Interesse, also bezogen auf Iran. Wir haben CSU-Leute bei Lanz sitzen, die sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal abwarten mit diesem Energiegesetz, mit dem Kartellrechtsverschärfung und so weiter. Dann werden wir das mit den Energiepreisen und den Spritpreisen schon in den Griff bekommen. Nichts passiert. Wir haben eine Wirtschaftsministerin Reiche, die eine völlig bescheuerte Regelung eingeführt hat, dass die Tankstellen nur einmal am Tag den Preis erhöhen dürfen. Ja, was machen die natürlich? Sie nehmen erst mal den höchsten Preis, um sicherzugehen, dass sie auf keinen Fall Verluste machen. Also um 12 Uhr kracht es so richtig rauf. Wem ist damit geholfen? Also man hat jetzt auch noch darüber Gewinne produziert, von denen man aber die ganze Zeit sagt, es gibt sie gar nicht. Es ist nicht mehr zu fassen.
Ja, dann haben wir heute genau die richtige Literatur dazu. Zum einen das Absurde ist jetzt ein Grundbegriff im politischen Denken. Die Kritik an die Politiker, schön und gut, aber in der Demokratie wurde der Kunde zum König erklärt und er hat die Rolle nie ganz angenommen. Das wird uns heute auch erklärt. Und wir kriegen von Adrian Daub zum Thema Vibe und Vibe Shift Aufklärung, die ich hochinteressant finde. Lass mich das aber noch mal historisch zusammenbinden, denn es war Ostern, ich war auf Reisen. Meine Herkunft ist ja bekannt, ich komme aus Jena. Ja, dort fand eine sehr kräftezehrende und blutrünstige Schlacht statt. 1806, Jena-Auerstedt. Napoleon überrascht die Preußen mit der Idee, wir kommen aus allen Himmelsrichtungen. Die Preußen stehen nur gerade da wie befohlen. Und dann kommt Napoleon und Napoleon selbst ist überrascht, dass sein einer Kommandant noch vom Norden auskommen kann und so. Und es gibt eine herbe Niederlage. Die Franzosen rennen nach Berlin, laufen durchs Brandenburger Tor, bauen dann später sogar den Versailler Saal irgendwie nach Anmutung, Brandenburger Tor, wie auch immer. Und dann, wie gesagt, ich war auf Reisen, ich war im Saarland das erste Mal.
Wie du warst das erste Mal in diesem Bundesland.
Ja, es ist so klein, es führt keinen Weg. Man muss schon richtig hinfahren, damit man es nicht verpasst. Jedenfalls war ich im Saarland. Und dort gibt es einen Ort, der heißt nicht Auerstedt, sondern es ist der rote Berg von, jetzt muss ich hier nachschauen, wie das heißt, Schielen, warte einen Moment, Spicher, der Spicher. Auch dort eine Schlacht, 1870, also 64 Jahre nach Auerstedt. Diesmal herbe Niederlage für die Franzosen. Wie? Sie wurden überrascht, wie sie damals überrascht haben. Angriffe aus allen Himmelsrichtungen. Ich habe Claude gebeten, das zu visualisieren. Wir können uns das kurz angucken. Ich bin diesen Berg hoch auf ein Restaurant gegangen und dachte, wow, das ist echt steil. Und dann oben ein großes gegossenes Betonkreuz, zwölf Meter hoch oder so, das daran erinnert, dass damals gegen die Franzosen auf diesen Berg gerannt wurde und Bismarck dann den großen Sieg verkünden konnte. Ein Jahr später, der Stuhl, auf dem man die Unterschrift setzte, steht ja hier bei uns im historischen Museum. Und ich möchte gern vorlesen aus einer Infotafel, die dort rumstand, folgendes. Am 18. Januar 1871 wird Wilhelm I im glanzvollen Spiegelsaal des Schlosses von Versailles, der also auch gebaut wurde als Erinnerung, dass die Franzosen mal erfolgreich in Berlin gelandet sind, zum Kaiser ernannt. Der Kanzler hatte seinen Traum verwirklicht, Deutschland zu einen, Frankreich zu demütigen und sich für die Schlacht von Jena 1806 zu rächen. Ich kriege also im Saarland eine Aufklärung darüber, was 400 Kilometer weit weg, heute eh schon Jahrhunderte her, damals auch schon drei Generationen her passierte. Und ich denke mir so, wir beobachten diese Kriege gerade unter, ja mal gucken, was morgen ist. So und dann übermorgen ist schon, ah nee, ist jetzt doch wieder Epstins Fall dominante, was auch immer so. Nur wenn man so eine ganze Stadt wie Rafah oder jetzt Beirut und der ganze Kram, Androhung eines, wie nennt man das denn jetzt, Zivilisationsmord des iranischen Volkes und so. Glaubt man denn jetzt ernsthaft, das wird alles morgen vergessen, also bei den Beteiligten dort, es gibt ja auch Betroffene. Das ist irgendwie eine sehr schräge Lage dafür, dass wir in Europa überall, also im Saarland, man stolpert quasi von einem Kriegerdenkmal über das nächste. Man guckt dann immer, um was geht es hier? 1871, 1914, 1918, 1939, 1945, also es geht ja eine Reihe um, dass wir das gerade so in Friedenszeiten durch den deutsch-französischen Garten da gehen und sagen, da stehen die Rosen, da kümmern sich übrigens Franzosen und Deutsche im gleichen Maße drum und wie auch immer. Also kleinste Freundschaftsgesen, die da aber ganz ernst genommen werden. Und dann höre ich im Radio auf der Rückfahrt, dass Anke Rehlinger findet, Anke Rehlinger ist die mit mehr als 50 Prozent regierende saarländische Ministerpräsidentin.
SPD.
SPD, die also gefragt wird, ja sie können es ja offenbar, wollen sie nicht in Berlin und so. Und sie sagt, ja ein bisschen mithelfen geht schon, aber ich kann nicht SPD-Chefin werden, weil Berlin ist zu weit weg. Und ich denke mir, das ist doch das einzige Kriterium, das wir gerade brauchen.
Weit weg von Berlin.
Weit weg von Berlin, um die SPD zu führen.
Ich würde sogar vorschlagen, dass...
Dass Willi Brandhaus in Saarbrücken aufzukommen.
Ja ganz richtig. Ich würde vorschlagen, Anke Rehlinger darf in Saarbrücken bleiben, regiert von dort aus die Bundes-SPD. Und wer von Berlin kommen will, muss einen Antrag stellen, bei Boris Pistorius.
Der Auftrag, die SPD zu retten, erlischt, wenn man zu Fuß in Berlin aufkreuzt, wenn man denkt, die müssen jetzt alle nach... Also das wäre meine Idee. In so einem Ort, wo man noch so richtig... Also man sieht von überall Kriegerdenkmäler. Das sind da nicht einfach Stolpersteine, wo man so ach ja okay und so, sondern die stehen da einfach mannshoch, das sind die Kleinen, und turmhoch im ganzen Saarland verteilt. Vielleicht ist das einfach der richtige Mindset, um jetzt mal hier Opposition in der Regierung zu machen. Aber nur eine weitere Empfehlung aus der Podcastlandschaft.
Wir haben heute zwei Bücher, die unglaublich gut zu diesem Thema passen. Wir sprechen über Adrian Daub, was das Valley Herrschen nennt. Wir haben von ihm schon besprochen, was das Valley Denken nennt. Jetzt geht es also darum, dass sie Herrschen nach Macht ja gar nicht streben, sondern nach Dominanz vor allem. Und da muss man unterscheiden, was das eigentlich meint. Du hast schon gesagt, Adrian Daub beschreibt den Vibe-Shift, der stattgefunden hat. Er beschreibt diese männliche Herrschaft.
Das ist schon ganz wichtig, hier schon zu sagen. Er definiert überhaupt erst mal Vibe. Und damit die Unterscheidung zwischen, und das finde ich auch in unserem Podcast ganz wichtig, einem intuitiven und einem institutionellen Denkrahmen. Denn das kann sehr weit auseinanderfallen. Man hört, nach halbes Jahr lang, jetzt muss irgendwo hin, irgendwas muss geliefert werden, Panzer, Leoparden, was auch immer. Und man sieht alle Institutionen im Gleichschritt in diese Richtung laufen. Und dann macht man eine Demoskopie und stellt fest, zwei Drittel der Deutschen finden das gar nicht. Das ist, also Vibe-Shift auch wichtig, aber Vibe-Diskrepanz. Dass das so in der Definition drinsteckt, finde ich, das werden wir nachher herausstellen.
Bis hin zu exakten Analysen einzelner Tweets von Elon Musk, die man lange Zeit abgetan hat als, naja, ist das so ein bisschen verrückt wie jedes Genie, aber das da doch viel mehr dahinter steckt. Dann auch, fragen wir uns ja häufig, wenn wir diese Leute sehen, Peter Thiel, Jeff Bezos, wenn man sich ihre Lebensläufe ansieht, ihre Beziehungen ansieht, wie passt das eigentlich alles zusammen? Also wie kann man ganz rechts sein und dann zugleich aber wieder dort progressiv, wie kann das eigentlich zusammengehören, dass man einwandert in die USA und dann trotzdem eigentlich alle noch mal von rechts überholt? Wie ist es möglich, dass man von Demokratisierung spricht und eigentlich eine Diktatur am liebsten errichten würde? Wie passt das alles zusammen? Und Adrian Daubs sagt, na ja, es passt eigentlich alles ziemlich gut zusammen. Unsere Kategorien, unsere alten, die greifen nicht mehr. Und deswegen passt da etwas nicht mehr. Das können wir also lernen, welche neuen Kategorien es da gibt. Peter Sloterdijk schreibt ein Buch, das heißt Der Fürst und seine Erben über große Männer im Zeitalter der gewöhnlichen Leute. Das Interessante ist, dass hier als Klappentext noch etwas draufsteht, was man, glaube ich, wenn man das Buch jetzt gerade drucken würde, nicht mehr drauf schreiben würde, wie es steht. Als Madman ohne Plan für den nächsten Tag ist Trump fürs erste weit weniger gefährlich als sein Gegenspieler im Kreml. Würden wir jetzt nach den vergangenen Tagen nicht mehr so sehen. Das hat aber den Buch, hat aber jetzt den Buchinhalt nicht geschwächt, sondern es hat eine Aktualität, die noch zugenommen hat.
Ja, also ich finde schon, dass die Rückseite schon noch wichtig ist. Und zwar, dass das im Buch auch gut begründet wird. Denn das, was wir gerade in Amerika sehen, ist total wirkmächtig, obwohl der Typ so dumm ist. Und jetzt stelle dir mal vor, da säße ein Putin.
Ja, nur habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass Trump besonders rational vorgeht, während ich ja Putin bei aller Brutalität immer noch eine Rationalität unterstelle. So, und deswegen sehe ich jetzt gerade bei einem Trump wirklich die Gefahr, dass der sagt, die Verhandlungen mit dem Iran haben nichts gebracht, die Straße von Homs ist nicht auf. Wir drücken jetzt auf den roten Knopf. Da sehe ich jetzt bei Trump gerade akut eine größere Gefahr.
Wir lesen heute einen weiteren Text aus der New York Times. Ich lese heute nur Texte, die viel besprochen sind. Also, wo das so mitläuft, das viel zu besprochen ist. Nämlich diese Aufarbeitung von Maggie Haberman und Swann. Wie heißt der? Jeremy Swann? Jonathan Swann. Die beiden planen ein Buch. Und die Anbahnung von dem, was wir jetzt gesehen haben oder überhaupt des Iran-Kriegs, wird auch schon besprochen. Und es lauert doch nirgendwo ein Putin in dem Sinne, weil du jetzt die Rationalität, also diese Dummheit führt dann halt auch zu nichts. Also klar könnten die jetzt Atomwaffen einsetzen und so, allein weil sie es so potenziell können. Aber bislang schützt uns doch die Dummheit mehr davor als was?
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher. Also nach dieser Woche bin ich mir da nicht mehr sicher. Vor einer Woche, vor zwei Wochen.
Wir werden es auch nicht texten prüfen.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher. Was aber doch interessant ist bei Sloterdijk ist, dass er in diesem Buch Machiavelli noch einmal aufschlägt und schaut, welche Parallelen gibt es eigentlich zu unserer Gegenwart. Und er hat viele anzubieten. Darüber sprechen wir. Was wirst du also noch mitbringen? Du hast schon einen Text jetzt genannt.
Also Swan und Habermann Habermann lesen, How Trump Took the US to War with Iran. Dann Timothy Snyder, der publiziert auf eigene Faust bei Substack, aber der wohl jetzt Stand 4. April dann meist gelesene Text dort. Da zumindest man sieht ja so wie viele Kommentare und wie die das nennen, Restacks oder was auch immer. The Next Coup Attempt and How to Stop It ergeht in fünf Punkten durch wie die Midterms. Also vom Iran-Krieg bis zu den Midterms macht er die Planung. Und dann ein Text einfach nur wegen der Pointe, die wirklich sehr überraschend überzeugend ist, aber grundsätzlich uns alle betrifft, sag ich mal. Anna Holms hat in The Atlantic über warum sie sich dagegen sträubt, immer mit dem Trend zu gehen beim Fernsehserien schauen. The people who shun super popular pop culture. Also shun im Sinne von für sich. Umso größer die Empfehlung, umso mehr lehnen sie es ab.
Ja.
Dann gucken sie es lieber heimlich oder wie auch immer, aber geben es nicht zu. Oder gibt es, also klar, man kann das so intuitiv durchgehen. Was ist das für ein komisches Phänomen? Reaktanz spielt natürlich eine große Rolle. Aber sie hat am Ende eine ganz interessante Pointe, die auch nochmal an Redaktionsschluss anschließt und so.
Ich habe ein Buch, das gerade heiß diskutiert wird dabei, von Jörg Barbarowski Am Volk vorbei zur Krise der liberalen Demokratie. Auf dieses Buch bin ich nochmal besonders aufmerksam geworden, weil es in der Zeit von Christian Stahs eine lange Rezension gab, in der die ganze Zeit betont wurde, wie gefährlich das ist und dass der Autor doch da sehr rechte Ansichten hat. Und da ich dachte, dass es doch Zeit ist, mehr gefährliche Bücher zu lesen, wollte ich unbedingt zugreifen. Das habe ich dann gemacht und war sehr überrascht. Denn ich könnte mir jetzt auch gleich die Mühe machen und herauszuarbeiten, um herauszuarbeiten, dass Jörg Barbarowski nicht links ist. Das kann ich dann an Äußerungen zur Migrationspolitik zeigen oder an irgendeinem links-liberalen Bashing, das vielleicht da und dort über die Stränge schlägt. Manchmal aber würde ich auch sagen, nicht? Jedenfalls könnte ich das tun. Das wäre so eine Fleißarbeit, die ziemlich geistlos ist. Stattdessen würde ich eigentlich die, genau, die Clot machen kann. Und viel geistreicher ist eigentlich das, was Barbarowski selbst tut und das dann auch selbst weiterdenken, wenn man sein Buch gelesen hat. Nämlich, er bedankt sich anfangs bei verschiedenen Autoren, dass er als Historiker überhaupt so ein Buch schreiben kann. Da sind unter anderem genannt Philip Manow. Da sind aber also jemand, der jetzt auch gerade sehr heiß diskutiert wird, weil er sagt, naja, Demokratie und liberale Demokratie sind nicht identisch. Wir hatten dieses Buch unter Beobachtung oder ich hatte es hier mal vorgestellt. Er bedankt sich aber auch bei Leuten wie Wendy Brown und Chantal Mouffe, also linken Denkern. Und er bezieht sich durchgehend in diesem Buch auf Karl Schmitt, aber auch auf viele sehr linke, ich würde sagen, bis hin zu kommunistischen, französischen Theoretikern und sagt, naja, diese Demokratie und wie sie uns da die ganze Zeit beschrieben wird, ist eine große Ideologie. Das muss man erst mal erkennen. Man muss schon sich darüber im Klaren sein, wie sind die Herrschaftsverhältnisse. Und das bedeutet, dass man jetzt hier nicht einfach so eine friedliche Einheit und eine ungespaltene Gesellschaft oder sowas haben kann. Er geht soweit zu sagen, das, was an Populismus stattfindet, ist eine Belebung der Demokratie. Denn Demokratie bedeutete eigentlich immer auch, dass das sogenannte Staatsvolk gegen den Staat agiert. Und wir haben sehr viel Staatstragendes gerade. Wir haben Bücher hier gehabt oder darüber zumindest in Ansätzen geredet, die sagen, wir müssen mehr vertrauen und wir müssen mehr dies und das. Barbarowski geht da einen anderen Weg. Ist ein Autor, der ja da böse analytisch rangeht, aber damit zu einer enormen Klarheit kommt. Das also werde ich vorstellen und werde jetzt meine Kritik von links da gar nicht so groß machen, weil ich sage, das muss man produktiv von links lesen. Alexander Kluge, wir haben darüber gesprochen, ist verstorben. Dann kaufe ich mir ein Buch, das heißt Transkription von Ben Lerner, weil es darum geht, dass da ein junger Mann oder so jung ist er gar nicht 45, möchte ein allerletztes Interview mit seinem Mentor führen, ein Mann, der sich zwischen Kunst und zwischen Literatur, zwischen Wissenschaften und Film bewegt. Dann stellt sich heraus, dieser Mann, der da besucht wird, heißt zwar Thomas, aber porträtiert wird hier Alexander Kluge. Zumindest werden Einsprengse verwendet. Ben Lerner und Kluge waren nämlich miteinander befreundet. Und hier wird Alexander Kluge in Form dieses Thomas verewigt, wenn das dann auch weiter ins Fiktionale gedehnt wird. Alexander Kluge hat auch dieses Buch noch gelesen und hat das auch als eine Geste der Freundschaft gesehen. Ein sehr interessantes Werk. Wir werden uns mit einem Text beschäftigen, der in Merkur erschienen ist, von Roman Wider, einem Schriftsteller, der sehr auf der pro-ukrainischen Seite ist, der auch sein Dissertationsvorhaben schon früh geändert hat, weil er auf keinen Fall da gewisse russische Autoren mehr drin haben wollte. Er beschreibt das sehr gut. Er rechnet aber jetzt ab mit den Ukraine-Experten, die hier in Deutschland so sind, vor allem Carlo Massalla. Ein hoch interessanter Text. Dann aus Le Monde Diplomatique, Fanny Peugeot über Kongo und den Mineralienabbau und noch Musik aus Russland bzw. von russischen Komponisten im Exil.
Sehr gut. Ich habe eine Frage an die Hörer. Jetzt wo ich wieder physische Bücher kaufe, stapeln sie sich. Und ich möchte gern wissen, was zu lesen ist von mir im nächsten Salon. Zur Auswahl stehen vier Bücher. Zum einen Anna Verena Nosthoff, Kybernetik und Kritik. Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen. Als ja für heute fast in Planung, aber das wäre viel zu viel gewesen. Außerdem das knappe Gut Arbeit, was die KI übrig lässt.
Ich bin sehr dafür, dass wir das vielleicht sogar gemeinsam besprechen.
Dann, was ich auf jeden Fall lesen werde und die Frage, wie schnell. Fritz B. Simon, wie Diktaturen funktionieren. Es sind auf dem Cover alle drauf. Das ist ein Buch, das mich sowieso sehr interessiert, weil ja, wir finden alle Putin, Stalin, Trump usw., Gaddafi blöd, aber sie haben ja trotzdem ein Werk vollbracht. Also die, sagen wir mal so, Unterjochung eines Volkes muss ja auch irgendwie handwerklich gelingen. Dem könnte man nachgehen. Und Hartmut Rosa, Situation und Konstellation. Hartmut Rosa, manchmal ein bisschen verlacht von mir nicht, denn ich finde es immer sehr inspirierend im Sinne von, aber ich finde es immer sehr aufrüttelnd. Und ich finde es ja gut, wenn Soziologen die Orthodoxie ein bisschen verlassen und einfach sagen, es gibt schon eine Welt, in der das alles stattfindet und der widme ich mich jetzt auch mal.
Ja, ich habe diese Faszination nie so nachvollziehen können, aber gut, wir werden sehen.
Wir können ja einen Voting machen im Forum und dann wird eins davon auf jeden Fall. Also wenn du sagst, das Arbeitsbuch...
Wir schauen uns das zumindest mal an.
Okay, gut. Jemand hatte uns eine Mail geschrieben mit, man müsste ja im Archiv immer so viel klicken um die Folgen und überhaupt und so. Wenn man wissen will, was wir alles gelesen haben, und zwar jeder einzelne Text seit Mai 2020, die ersten drei muss ich noch nacharbeiten, händisch. Man geht auf neuezwanziger.de/salonoderneuezwanziger.deunddann gibt es oben einen Button oder einen Link mit Lektüre. Da findet man alle aufgelistet, da muss man nicht weiter klicken, sondern da sind alle schon ersichtlich und dann gibt es sogar eine Suchwelt, da kann man einfach Daub eingeben und dann sieht man immer, wenn wir über Daub gesprochen haben. Oder alle anderen Autoren. Das ist sehr viel einfacher als in den E-Mails, die wir bekommen immer, weil man nicht einfach mal in der Webseite oben die Menüleiste durchgeht.
Ja, wir haben eine Webseite. Sie ist sehr gut. Ich nutze sie nämlich auch, um wiederzufinden, was wir eigentlich so alle schon besprochen haben. neuezwanziger.de. Dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.
Hallo Stefan.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Kann es sein, dass du ein Bewohner postdemokratischer Zonen bist?
Darüber müsste ich zu lange nachdenken. Ein Bewohner postdemokratischer Zonen.
Ich zitiere Peter Sloterdijk. Die Staatsbürger früherer Jahrzehnte, auch wenn sie sich bekämpften, ließen sich von Zeitungen und Klassikern unterrichten. Bewohner postdemokratischer Zonen verbinden und isolieren sich untereinander aus guttenbergischer Sicht schon auf bis auf weiteres unbegreifliche Weise anders. Das Symbol ihrer Unbegreiflichkeit heißt bis zur Stunde Taylor Swift. Sie bezeugt den Sieg mittelmäßiger Jugendmusik über die Realität von erwachsenen alten Schlages.
Und das ist der Grund, warum du mir vorhin sagtest, du findest das Daubbuch besser, weil du diese Kritik von Sloterdijks an der einzigen jungen Frau, die die Leute noch zu Text und Lyrik-Lektüre treibt, nicht gut findest.
Ich muss sagen, das war eine Stelle, über die ich sehr gelacht habe. Deswegen habe ich es mir natürlich gleich angestrichen, damit ich dich damit konfrontieren kann. Als Taylor Swift-Fan musst du ja da aufgerüttelt werden.
Ja, es hat mich natürlich sehr aufgerüttelt, weil ich es ja auch nicht so gut finde.
Aber du bist ein größerer Fan des Buchs, glaube ich.
Ich sage mal so, ich bin größerer Fan des Buchs, denn er macht ja folgenden Bogenschlag, dass er uns die ganze Zeit, also im Grunde ein bisschen wie bei John Oliver, ich weiß nicht, ob du This Week Tonight häufig guckst, da wird ja die ganze Zeit, also 90 Prozent des Humors ist ja über Analogien. Also man versucht das was zu verdeutlichen, und dann kommt eine ganz absurde Vergleichsarbeit. Und so ist das ja hier auch. Und man muss anmerken, ja, sehr schmunzeln, Taylor Swift zu nennen, aber die Illustration passt nicht so ganz zu dem, was er uns eigentlich sagen wollte, denn er bettet das ja ein in die Unterscheidung von Grafosphäre und Sonosphäre. Das eine ist also noch das gedruckte Wort, die Zeitung, die Klassiker, die Bücher, also die in der Redaktionsarbeit sich befindlichen Gesellschaft, die sich über Lesen immer wieder selbst reflektiert und über die Zeitung eine gemeinsam geteilte Hintergrundrealität aufbaut, von der Dirk Becker in meinem Buch sagte, das ist wie das Morgengebet, das Hegel beschreibt, die morgendliche Zeitungslektüre. Im Vergleich dazu, Datenbilder, irgendwelche Informationen, Algorithmen und die ganze Zeit Sound und Video. Also jeder ist mit sich selbst beschäftigt, keine Timeline gleich der anderen. Nur Taylor Swift ist und genau deswegen ist sie ja so berühmt, diejenige, die alle wieder in so einen synchronisierenden Moment schickt, sei es als, wir sind hier wirklich alle zu 80.000 in dem Stadion gerade, oder wir zitieren aus ihren Liedern und die anderen wissen, ah ja, das ist aus Taylor Swifts Liedern und nicht aus einem, ich habe heute morgen was bei Instagram ersehen, das muss ich dir jetzt erstmal erklären, weil ich genau weiß, du weißt gar nicht, wovon ich rede. Von daher passt es einfach gar nicht.
Ich finde es passt gerade deshalb sehr gut, denn du beschreibst es ja richtig. Taylor Swift kann noch mal alle verbinden, global, jung und alt. Diversity wird groß geschrieben, aber nicht einfach nur so als Werbesignal, sondern es ist so. Es ist ein diversifiziertes Publikum, das sie vorfindet. Aber es ist eines, dass ich über diese Rhythmen noch verständigen kann, über diese Melodien. Ein Publikum, das die Easter Eggs noch erkennt. Aber würde man das Publikum zu etwas anderem befragen, nämlich das, was er meint, was die Erwachsenen alten Schlages umgetrieben hat, also man las noch die Zeitung, man las noch die Klassiker, würde dieses Publikum sich sofort granularisieren. Das heißt, wir hätten nur noch vereinzelte da. Nur Taylor Swift bindet sie noch zusammen. Deswegen ist eigentlich das Bild ganz gut gewählt, weil das schon ein Zeichen davon ist, dass wir völlig anders geworden sind. Dadurch eigentlich die gemeinsame Debattengrundlage ja fehlt, wodurch wir dann also nur noch effektiv zusammen gebunden werden können durch Taylor Swift. Hier war ich eigentlich überrascht, wie gut das Bild passt. Auch wenn er sich da ein bisschen über die mittelmäßige Jugendmusik mokiert, das will ich jetzt hier nicht nochmal beurteilen. Aber das an sich zusammenzubinden, scheint mir sehr logisch zu sein. Ich würde auch sagen, das ist ein Kennzeichen der Popkultur, die wir jetzt haben, dass man noch so ein paar, ich hätte fast gesagt überirdische, ein paar globale Phänomene hat, auf die sich alle nochmal so kurz verständigen können.
Also, so wie du es jetzt beschreibst, verstehe ich, dass Taylor Swift sozusagen als Ausnahme der sonospherischen Regel uns nochmal verdeutlicht, wie sehr wir im übrigen Alltag übrigens nicht Taylor Swift hören, alle gemeinsam, sondern jeder für sich. Ja, aber so habe ich es an der Stelle aus dem Buch nicht rausgelesen. Ich habe da mehr so ein alter Mann, sage ich nochmal.
Und das noch kennen, also uns darüber noch verständigen. Das heißt, wir können nicht, wo warst du jetzt zuletzt in Athen, irgendjemanden ansprechen und sagen, wie der alte Goethe schon schrieb. Oder bei Cervantes kann man das und das lesen. Jetzt kann man sagen, das galt eh immer nur für eine kleine Gruppe, die sich so ansprechen konnte. Aber man kann sich sicher sein, wenn man Marry Me, Juliet spielt, dann können alle mittanzen und mitsingen. Das ist also die letzte Verbindung, die hergestellt wird und deshalb ja auch postpolitische, postdemokratische Zonen, die da errichtet werden, weil es nur noch affektiv zusammengebunden ist.
So lasse ich es gelten?
Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, das ist kein Buch über Taylor Swift, sondern das ist eigentlich eine der wenigen Stellen, in denen es wirklich mal so ganz gegenwärtig, hier ist ein popkulturelles Phänomen. Ich sage mal, was dazu geht. Deswegen fällt es so auf. Denn was macht es Peters Sloterdijk hier eigentlich? Die Idee ist, wir müssen jetzt Machiavelli noch mal lesen. Und zwar Der Fürst. Das ist ja diese Schrift, die extrem wichtig ist für die Politikwissenschaft, aber auch für die Herrscher selbst. Nämlich, wie regiert man eigentlich ein Volk? Wie verhält sich der Regent? Dabei gibt es natürlich sehr viele verschiedene Interpretationen. Was gesagt werden kann, es ist also ein machtpolitisches Anliegen, das vertreten wird. Nämlich, es wird quasi eine Strategie ausgearbeitet, wie regiert werden kann. Dabei geht es zum Beispiel eher nicht um Moral, sondern es geht in erster Linie einmal darum, wie kann Regierung funktionieren. Es ist ein sehr funktionalistischer Blick auf die Herrscher und wie sie regieren können. Machiavelli hat auch ganz andere Ansätze, auch sehr demokratische Ansätze und all das. Das wird auch hier in dem Buch hin und wieder deutlich. Wichtig ist jetzt für Peter Sloterdijk zu sagen, also wir haben diese Phänomene, Putin, Trump, Elon Musk, Modi und so weiter. Was kann man eigentlich, wenn man Machiavelli liest und sich überhaupt mit der Geschichte der Alten und der sogenannten großen Männer beschäftigt, über die Gegenwart heute sagen? Und das macht er dann anhand von vielen Kapiteln, in denen er sagt, naja, es gibt da schon sehr viele Bezüge. Er spricht über die charismatische Macht, über Souveränität, über, das ist seine Diagnose, heute eine verwilderte Vertikalität und das Absurde spielt hier auch eine Rolle. Ein Kapitel heißt Das Große und das Absurde.
Genau, das Große und das Absurde. Was ja super interessant ist, ist, so wie du es jetzt beschrieben hast, warum jetzt nochmal der Fürst und es ist ja ein sehr wohlwollender Umgang, in dem einfach festgestellt wird, ja, weil grad Konjunktur ist. Ja, und er markiert das ja ganz interessant. Wir hatten das ja auch häufiger, dass immer wieder über Fukuyama gesprochen wird, der also 1992, drei Jahre nach oder zweieinhalb Jahre, zwei Jahre nach der globalen Wende der Westen ist besiegt. Also wird er nun ist untergegangen und jetzt wird das Ende der Geschichte ausgerufen. Die UN wächst also von ursprünglich 50 Nationen auf 192. Alleine in dieser Zeit, in der Fukuyama sagte, das ist das Ende der Geschichte, kommt der ganze Ostblock dazu, 30, 40 neue Länder. Und er sagt nun rückblickend, ja, das ist ganz interessant. Auf der einen Seite haben wir diese gigantische Konjunktur für Verfassungsrechtler. Also alle brauchen eine neue Verfassung, schreiben die auch, nur nach getaner Arbeit geht man nach Hause. Und das zweite große Buch, das Konjunktur hat, ist Der Fürst von Machiavelli, 500 Jahre alt. Und diese Gleichzeitigkeit, über die muss man sich jetzt nicht mehr wundern. Denn mit der Demokratisierung, mit der Verfassungsverrechtlichung, mit der Zurechtweisung des Bürgers, was er alles darf und nicht darf, entsteht der Wunsch nach einem neuen Fürsten. Und während wir immer heute, du hast es ja angesprochen, diese normativen Bücher lesen, in denen uns noch mal gesagt wird, ne ne, wir müssen jetzt den herrschenden Vertrauen, hier und da, uns wird alles noch mal schön dahin gebogen, sagt Sloterdijk einfach, nö, wir haben uns jetzt die letzten 500 Jahre angeguckt. Sehr viel Demokratie war nicht nach der Sturz in den Staat, also der Hierarchisierung von Gesellschaft. Und im Grunde schwingt das Pendel jetzt nicht einfach zurück, sondern da, wo es halt immer war. Wir sind zurück in einer Zeit, von der wir dachten, aber wir haben doch jetzt Wissenschaft, aber wir haben doch jetzt Technologie, brauchen wir noch den großen Befehl. Und da würde ich auch sagen, als Kritik ja, erwähnt Taylor Swift und Claude und KI erwähnt er nicht. Und da würde ich nämlich auch sagen, wer kriegt heute die Befehle? Muss es zwingend der Staatsbürger sein, der zurechtgewiesen werden muss? Oder ist das nicht längst diese Ermächtigung, dass wir die Befehle heute einfach weitergeben und dem Computer sagen, unter dem Roboter demnächst, der, was weiß ich, das selbstfahrende Auto, der humanoide Roboter, der uns die Waschmaschine macht, wie auch immer. Also da fehlt mir auch sozusagen die Gegenwart. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ein spektakuläres Buch. Das wir jetzt von oben nach unten durchgehen, denn schon der Titel ist sehr gut, finde ich.
Der Fürst und seine Erben.
Ja, es ist also nicht Der Fürst und seine Doubles, sondern es ist nicht die Nachahmung, sondern es ist das Reingestolper in. Die Rolle ist halt da. Also es ist ja auch so eine Flapsigkeit. Die macht er gar nicht. Vielleicht ist ihm das Argument zu einfach, aber das kann man ja mal machen. Demokratie, wir laden sie immer so auf, aber am Ende wird halt einfach nur durchgezählt. Jemand hat 51 Prozent der Stimmen, also es ist jetzt Der Fürst. Und derjenige dann, wie was? Und dann kommt noch die Ehefrau von ihm und sagt, wie was nochmal? Also wir wissen ja immer von den First Ladies, Michael Obama wollte eigentlich nicht nochmal. Melania wollte erstmal überrascht, beim zweiten Mal, wie nochmal? Sind die alle doof oder was? Und dann sieht man, wie sie in ihrem Film einfach nur die Privilegien nutzt und sagt, welche Kleider, welche Tische, welche was und so. Also völlig inhaltsbefreit eigentlich. Da haben wir so eine Fürstenrolle. Also der Fürst, der damalige Fürst und heute seine Erben. Und dann im Untertitel über große Männer, also nicht mächtige, nicht tolle, leistungsstarke, so einfach nur große Männer. Das wird dir dann gleich gut aufgeklärt. Im Zeitalter der gewöhnlichen Leute. Gewöhnliche Leute im Plural, das meint also nicht nur, könnte man jetzt denken, einfach das Publikum. Wir sind halt gewöhnliche Leute, sondern auch die Neuen Fürsten sind gewöhnliche Leute.
Denn sie haben nicht mehr den eigentlich direkten Bezug, den die alten Fürsten hatten zum Kaiser, zum lieben Gott. Ja, über den Papst dann vielleicht gespielt. Wie auch immer, er geht ja verschiedene Fälle da durch, wo auch die Nähe zu Gott gesucht wird oder man Gott gleich sich macht auf Erden. Man sich quasi als den verlängerten Arm sieht. Das wird heute mühsam wieder hergestellt.
Ja, also.
Aber in einer anderen Selbstverständlichkeit damals gelebt.
Muss es drastischer sagen. Hitler, die Führerrolle gab es nicht. Hitler hat sie gemacht.
Ja.
Das selbe gilt für Stalin. Ja. Das selbe gilt für Putin. Und es gilt erst recht für Napoleon. Das ist ja große Bewunderung für Napoleon hier. Und zwar auch genau dieser Faszination wie bei Fritz B. Es gibt Diktatoren. Okay, wir wissen, wie wir darüber denken müssen, aber es gibt sie ja trotzdem. So, ja. Also Napoleon erwächst aus dieser kurzen Phase, der wollen wir es nicht mal mit Demokratie nach englischem Vorbild versuchen. Jetzt haben wir dem König den Kopf abgehackt. Und die erste Idee von Napoleon ist Demokratie, König, könne ich nicht einfach ein Kaiser nach römischem Vorbild sein? Also eine völlig neue Rolle. Während Trump einfach nur, muss man jetzt wirklich sagen, einfach nur amerikanischer Präsident geworden ist. Ja. Und da sieht man die Demokratie.
Und auch Putin ist ja weiterhin Präsident. Also er orientiert sich natürlich an den Zaren, aber er geht nicht zu dem Schritt, dass er sagt, ich bin jetzt der Zar.
Genau. Was bedeutet, und das ist die große, finde ich, Aufklärung in diesem Buch, da ist dann die Frage, also ich könnte jetzt vier Stunden darüber reden, du magst es eher knapp, um dann zu Daub zu kommen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, wir können schon ausführlich jetzt darüber reden.
Aber die Demokratie selbst hat dafür gesorgt, dass Trump ohne Ambitionen, ohne Fähigkeiten und ohne Fertigkeiten überhaupt in diese Position kommen konnte.
Ja, die Demokratie selbst, das ist ganz wichtig zu erkennen. Es ist eben dann nicht die Erblinie im Sinne von, ja sein Großvater war ja auch schon, sondern es ist die Demokratie selbst, die ihn dahin bringt. Aber er steht damit in einer Tradition, wird damit zum Erben der Fürsten. Die Provokation, die Sloterdijk uns hier unterjubelt, ist ja erst einmal zu sagen, ja wir reden da zwar über einen 500 Jahre alten Text und er beschäftigt sich mit Fürsten. Und jetzt kann man sagen, ja die Medici Herrschaft, was hat das alles jetzt mit uns zu tun? Aber zu sagen, dass er wächst aus der Demokratie. Wo wir ja genau sagen würden, die Demokratie ist das Gegenteil davon, von dem was da Machiavelli meint mit dem Fürsten. Genau, dass er sagt, nein, nein wir stellen das jetzt mal in eine lange Reihe und vergleichen es miteinander, weil es miteinander zu vergleichen ist. Und der Fürst nicht verschwunden ist, sondern er hat Erben. Das ist eigentlich die interessante Provokation, die in diesem Buch steckt.
So, und noch bevor man jetzt einsteigt in den Text, der klappt ein Text, hat eine ganz wichtige Sache in diesem dritten Absatz. Ein Fürst, der sich behaupten wolle, also ins Amt ist er gekommen durch demokratische Maßnahmen, er musste einfach nur, heute Abend ist Duell, dein Duelland ist 91 und debil und alle sehens. Also im Grunde sehr viel musst du nicht machen, hau nicht zu voll drauf, sonst siehst du noch unmenschlich aus so. Er muss einfach nur absolvieren. So und dann steht hier ein Fürst, der sich behaupten wolle, also erst im Amt muss man sich überhaupt behaupten, in dieser amerikanischen Demokratie. Statuierte Machiavelli müsse lernen, nicht gut zu sein. Und ja, hat mir Klot geholfen, herauszufinden, in den vielen, vielen Übersetzungen von Machiavelli heißt es einfach, der Fürst muss auch mal böse sein oder sowas. Und hier geht es aber gezielt darum, erstens lernen, zweitens nicht gut zu sein. Denn das Gute steckt ja drin. Du sollst ja das Gemeinwohl, dann wird irgendwas gefaselt, also wie Wahlkämpfe also ablaufen. Aber dann im Amt muss man zeigen, ich bin in der Lage zu lernen, nicht gut zu sein. Wir haben ja beim letzten Mal schon diskutiert, wo eigentlich die Wirtschaftskompetenz der CDU herkommt, weil sie eben härten zumutet. Also diese Art von, ich weiß, ihr habt mich gewählt und ihr wollt das Beste, aber das Beste ist erst übermorgen, jetzt muss man durch den Drähen-Tal gehen, der Gürtel muss enger geschnallt werden. Das muss man lernen. Und das kann man auch gut nachvollziehen für normale Menschen. Also man muss dann einfach von Angesichts zu Angesichts, nach der Audienz, mit den Leidenden das absolvieren, um eine Sekunde später zu sagen, aber sorry, tut mir leid, wir müssen das Krankenhaus jetzt zumachen.
Ganz genau.
Das muss man lernen.
Und das gibt ja dann auch großen Respekt, wenn man das dann macht. Wir sehen das ja bei Lars Kling bei, wenn er dann so eine Rede hält bei Bertelsmann, dann wird gesagt von Seiten des Journalismus, er kann es, er ist derjenige, jetzt muss er nur weiterhin den Mut haben. Man könnte auch sagen, er muss weiterhin den Mut haben, nicht gut zu sein.
Genau. Und dann kommt der Konnemann, lobt ihn für die Rede und dann sagen die Journalisten, und das ist der Ausweis, dass das jetzt richtig ist.
Ja, jetzt hat er Kompetenz.
Genau, jetzt ist er Kompetent. So, und das muss Trump jetzt gerade lernen, nicht gut zu sein. Und ich würde sagen, das ist das Erste, was er übt, also das Einzige, die Demokratie hat ihm den Weg bereitet. Und bei der eigenen Maßnahme, lerne nicht gut zu sein, scheitert er ja fundamental. Denn dieses Eisding, also den Amerikanern die Arbeitskräfte wegzufischen und halt im Sekundären die Familienmitglieder. Oder halt das ganze Budget einfach im Iran zu verbraten durch totale Zerstörung, die 100 Jahre Rache bedeutet. Da fällt es gerade ganz schwer zu ersehen, warum das jetzt perspektivisch gut ist. Also warum das jetzt ein Gürtel enger schneien für irgendwas Gutes ist. Und Trump scheitert sozusagen an der einen Aufgabe, die ihm mitgegeben wurde, nachdem ihm das ganze Feld bereitet wurde.
Jetzt werden aber doch Leute sagen, naja, aber das ist ja gerade nicht gut, was er tut. Warum ist denn das jetzt anders zu verstehen, als das, was Sloterdijk meint? Bleiben wir bei Sloterdijk, um das deutlich zu machen und auch um mal eine kritische Note hier zu setzen. Es ist ja so, dass Peter Sloterdijk sehr gegen die Migrationspolitik von Angela Merkel sich gestellt hat und damals auch diesen Satz sagte, ich glaube, es war sogar in der Kulturzeit, dass man mit wohltemperierter Grausamkeit vorgehen muss angesichts der Migranten, die nach Deutschland kommen wollen. Das ist ja eine Formulierung, die Höcke aufgegriffen hat, dann auch in seinem Buch, das direkt zitiert hat, also diese wohltemperierte Grausamkeit. Ich will jetzt hier Sloterdijk nicht für diesen Satz verteidigen, weil ich das ja auch fundamental anders sehe als er. Was er aber damit angesprochen hat, ist tatsächlich nicht einfach einen Wunsch, den er hat, wie umgegangen werden soll. Es ist kein Imperativ, der da drin liegt, sondern er beschreibt etwas, was einer Regierung zu eigen ist. Nämlich diese wohltemperierte Grausamkeit, die jetzt gerade von der EU an den Tag gelegt wird. Wohltemperiert klingt immer noch so, als sei sie gar nicht so schlimm. Mit wohltemperiert ist ja in diesem Zusammenhang gemeint, also bitte nicht die Bilder produzieren, die Trump produziert.
Genau.
Das ist nämlich genau das, was dann die Bevölkerung möglicherweise in Rage bringt und auf die Straße treibt. Wir in der EU oder die EU, nicht wir, ich bin da nicht für zuständig, aber die EU sorgt dafür, dass Leute da still und heimlich im Mittelmeer saufen und ein paar Aktivisten schaffen es vielleicht, das noch mal groß zu machen bei Instagram für so eine halbe Stunde. Aber das ist genau die wohltemperierte Grausamkeit, von der Sloterdijk da gesprochen hat. Dass aus der Mitte heraus, aus so einem linksliberalen Spektrum heraus, so ein Hass dann auf Sloterdijk kam, ließ sich für mich nur so deuten, dass Sloterdijk hier in Wahrheit etwas angesprochen hatte, was die da, die sich aus der Mitte gerade empören, ja die ganze Zeit schon machen, nämlich sich nicht gut verhalten, weil sie gerade davon ausgehen, dass das aber das richtige Regierungshandeln ist. Und bei Trump ist es genau anders, dass wenn immer er was anfasst, dann eskaliert das, dann explodiert es rings herum und man sagt sich wieso, warum ist er so doof?
Genau, das ist eine sehr wichtige Unterscheidung, denn die Unterstellung ist, damals auch bei Merkels Flüchtlingspolitik, Merkel öffnet die Grenzen, in Anführungszeichen, wie auch immer, und dann weiß man nicht genau, wohin das führt, man sieht nur sehr viele Syrer auf der Autobahn, was auch immer. Und sehr viele Menschen, sehr heimlich, abends vorm Fernsehen. Na zum Glück hat Sebastian Kurz jetzt die Dingsroute geschlossen. Also ist man es eigentlich, und das ist eben auch beim Vibe ganz wichtig, dass man so zwischen institutionellen und intuitiven Realitäten ganz hart auch für sich unterscheidet und das dann auch aushält, dass es eine Diskrepanz ist, weil man muss ja niemandem offenbaren. Also man kann dann einfach auf die Straße gehen und sagen, das ist voll scheiße, wie du mit den Menschen umgegangen wirst, aber abends sich noch mal versichern, dass jetzt die Route wirklich geschlossen ist von Sebastian Kurz. Aber der ist ganz böse. Und diese Diskrepanz, die also eine spezifische Mitarbeit des Publikums am politischen System bedeutet, um die geht es hier ganz tiefschöpfend und das finde ich auch sehr gut. In der Ansicht klärt uns das Buch viel auf, denn das kann man ja jetzt zugestehen. Sloterdijks sitzt nicht nur in Fernsehshows und sagt dort, was hast du gerade gesagt, die wohltemperierte Klausamkeit ist da. Und er zeigt sich eben fasziniert davon als philosophische Herausforderung, das jetzt zu verstehen. Sondern er sagt hier halt auch ganz klar, naja, also dass man jetzt noch mal den Fürst liest von Machiavelli liegt ja auf der Hand, denn es gibt Putin und Trump sogar zeitgleich auf der Weltbühne. Das reicht völlig aus. Die Frage ist jetzt nur, wollen wir jetzt weiter sagen, das sind so Präsidenten oder sagen wir einfach, ach komm, scheiß auf die ganze Formalstruktur, die in Verfassungstexten drin steht. Wir lesen jetzt Machiavelli, das sind Tyrannen. Und er sagt halt einfach, das sind jetzt Tyrannen. So wie beschrieben. Und dann geht's los. Und da finde ich, das ist okay. Also das ist ja genau richtig. Das ist ja das, was wir uns wünschen. Ja. Dass man jetzt den Schleier mal hebt von diesen ganzen Verfassungsrechtsdiskursen und was man so sagen darf in den Tagesthemen und was nicht. Sondern wir sagen, es gibt doch Tyrannen. Also müssen wir uns auch den Fürsten lesen. Ja.
Ja, das würde ich also zum Beispiel mal den Leuten, die bei tageschau.de arbeiten, zur Lektüre empfehlen. Um das Wording, wie man heute so sagt, zu überdenken bei manchen Sachen, die zum Beispiel von Trump da so kommen.
Ja, oder man baut sich halt so einen Browserplugin, das einfach die Worte austauscht. Autokratie, immer ein Verlegenheitsbegriff für Tyrannie.
Ja.
Und dann ist man eigentlich schon, dann stimmen die Satzbauten wieder. Ja.
Sloterdijk gibt auch ziemlich zu Anfang Jürgen Habermas noch eins mit, ohne dass er ihn erwähnt natürlich. Er schreibt, man wird wohl zugeben, nie wurde ein noblerer Traum geträumt, als der von der Gleichvernünftigkeit aller und zumindest der vielen.
Ja.
Das heißt, Sloterdijk sagte ja, im Diskurs brauchen wir uns nicht irgendwo treffen, um miteinander zu diskutieren. Ich würde ja auch sagen, Habermas, aber das wäre jetzt wieder ein eigenes Fass, das wir öffnen, Habermas selbst hat diesen Traum in Akademie geträumt und auch realisiert. Aber man sieht ja gerade, wie sehr er in den letzten, sagen wir, 30 Jahren zum Verfechter eigentlich einer Technokratie wurde, dass er offenbar ja selbst genau diesen Traum nicht mehr weitertraumen konnte. Und deswegen wäre meine leise These hier bei diesem Buch des Sloterdijks in gewisser Weise auch in die Fußstapfen von Habermas tritt, nämlich dann, wenn er jetzt uns vor diesen großen Männern bei aller Faszination, die er hat, mahnt und warnt, sodass er doch eigentlich diesem technokratischen System mehr abgewinnen kann, als ich bislang dachte. Ich dachte, er sei da mit so einem nizianischen Nihilismus mehr ausgestattet. Aber möglicherweise merkt auch Sloterdijk gerade, das ist mal schön für eine Vöjetorn-Provokation, könnte aber gefährlich werden.
Ja, es gibt noch nicht nur Habermas, wird unerwähnt über Bande eins mitgegeben, sondern auch Münkler. Der wird nämlich auch gar nicht erwähnt, obwohl er ja diese, ich habe als Doktorand 20.000 Bücher verkauft und so. Nur wenn man das hier so liest, ne?
Als Doktorand? Ach so, ah, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Die große Machiavelli-Desertation von Münkler. Wurde ja hier, fand gar nicht statt, ja.
Ja, und der Autor der Imperien und all das, natürlich ja ein muster ja nachvorkommen.
Aber auch hier möchte sich Sloterdijk doch in diese Tradition stellen. Denn Münkler fällt ja jetzt gerade dadurch auf, dass er uns die ganze Zeit erklärt, nee, wir müssen jetzt wieder zu den Waffen greifen und die Stadtmauer muss abgesichert werden und so weiter. Und genau das schreibt er ja auch. Also, dass man so die, nichts könnte uns ferner liegen als, wie baut man die Stadtmauer fest. So, wir sind alle beschäftigt mit, wie schnell fährt mein Auto und so. Luxusfragen. Nur in Sachen Belizismus, also dem Ruf nach Kriegstüchtigkeit, würde ich sagen, ist das Buch hier, da hätte man auch ruhig mal eins zu eins Münkler erwähnen können.
Ja, also Sloterdijk ist hier absolut auf diesem Aufrüstungsdiskurs. Tut so, als seien wir in Deutschland eigentlich völlig verblendet durch einen Pazifismus, der überall kassiert, was ich jetzt nicht so wahrnehme, offenstanden. Aber ja, er ist da ganz dafür, was ja interessant ist, dass er zum einen ja diese neoliberale, individualistische Tendenz ja in seinem Werk mit auch geprägt hat. Also er ist jemand, der sich stark auf Stirner früher bezogen hat. Und er ist letztendlich mit Christian Lindner zusammen bei, ne, wie war das? Er hat die, ja genau, er hat die Rede gehalten bei der Trauung von Lindner und seiner Franka Leefeld.
Ich glaube, er hatte einfach Hoffnung in Lindner, die er auch zu spät aufgegeben hat.
Genau, also das, aber eigentlich ist das ja ein Widerspruch, denn dieses neoliberale Subjekt, das ja in gewisser Weise auch bei Sloterdijk mit angelegt ist, ist ja eines genau, das sich nicht mehr unterwirft und sagt, ich verzichte auf mein Auto, ich rüste jetzt lieber auf, baut keine BMWs, baut jetzt Panzer. Das ist ja gerade nicht die Haltung des neoliberalen Subjekts. Weshalb ich ja in so einer dialektischen Pirouette jetzt sagen würde, die Neoliberalen, also die richtigen Neoliberalen, sind vielleicht die, die man am ehesten als Partner gegen die Kriegstüchtigkeit für sich gewinnen kann.
Also schwierig. Zum einen, wenn man ihn jetzt eintaktet in die neoliberale Ecke. Er schreibt, der Hinweis, wonach der Fürst keine anderen Gedanken haben darf als solche, die der Kriegskunst gelten, verfehlen das breite Publikum, ebenso wie die Angehörigen der heutigen Intelligenzjahr in Hochschulen, Parteivorständen und Redaktionen. Unsere Kritik ist ja, die hier sogenannte Intelligenzjahr macht ja gerade nichts anderes, als uns nochmal zu sagen, Kriegskunst ist gerade das Allerwichtigste. Lieber 100 Milliarden hier in Panzer, die 50 Cent Rendite bringen, als auch nur ein Euro mehr in Bildung, der uns sieben Euro bringt. Und Neoliberalismus auf die Spitze getrieben heißt ja, und das schreiben die ja auch selber so in ihren großen amerikanischen Texten gerade, im Grunde lassen sich alle Probleme dadurch lösen, dass jeder für sich selbst Verantwortung übernimmt und niemand für jemand anderen. Außer eins, Verteidigung.
Ja, da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht. Diese Schilderung finden wir ja auch immer wieder, beziehungsweise die Geschichte zeigt es ja. Reagan ist ja so ein typischer Fall. Wir zerschlagen den Sozialstaat und erhöhen das Militärbudget ins Vermessliche. Jedoch bringt ja genau dieser Individualismus auch eine gewisse Subjektivität hervor, die sagt, ich bin mir selbst der Nächste und jeder, der jetzt von mir verlangt, dass ich mit meinem Auto langsamer fahren soll, beraubt mich meiner Freiheit. Jeder, der jetzt sagt, ich soll mich vorher abmelden, wenn ich verreise, beraubt mich meiner Freiheit. Jeder, der sagt, ich soll jetzt mal ein Jahr irgendwo an der Front sein, beraubt mich meiner Freiheit. Insofern bringt dieser Neoliberalismus auch Subjekte hervor, die in gewisser Weise widerständig werden, weil sie sagen, nicht mit mir, ich bin der Einzige und mein Eigentum ist das, was mich interessiert, um ein bisschen Stirner zu paraphrasieren.
Genau, bleibt aber die Heuristik, die Pointe hier. Machiavelli hat damals kein Handbuch geschrieben, sondern ein Habitus vorgestellt. Und der gilt heute. Und deswegen schaut man in diese Bücher nochmal rein.
Das Volk im Licht seiner besten Qualitäten betrachtet kann und darf nichts anderes sein als ein Ensemble von Mikrokurfürsten ausgestattet mit dem zu allgemeinem Recht ausgedehnten Vorrecht, die zu bestimmen, die an der Spitze stehen sollen. Die Parteiführer und ihr Anhang fungieren daraufhin als bürgerliche Elektoren, Wahlmänner, die über die Besetzung der Spitzenposition mit einfacher Mehrheit entscheiden. Das heißt, wir haben hier die gewöhnlichen Leute, die wählen. Wir haben aber auch die gewöhnlichen Wahlmänner, die in Spitzenpositionen kommen können. Dabei ist interessant, dass aber das alles wiederum so lächerlich ist, dass man es gar nicht mehr als lächerlich benennen muss. Es ist so erstaunlich, dass man hier von Sloterdijk gesagt bekommt, dieser demokratische Idealismus, der da ist. Dass der eigentlich bedeutete, Mut zur Lächerlichkeit zu haben. Also die Demokratie so hoch zu halten in einer Weise, dass das Volk sich da ausdrückt in seinem Willen und all das. Sondern eigentlich muss man verstehen, es genügt so ein minimalistischer Ansatz zu verstehen, das Volk will nicht unterdrückt werden. Das ist ja erstmal der entscheidende Punkt. Das, was dann so aufgeladen wurde von ich, der souveräne Wähler, der gleich vernünftig mit den anderen Wählern zusammensteht, um dann die Spitzen zu bestimmen, um so in Mehrheiten zu entscheiden, das sei von einem Idealismus geprägt, der mit der Realität doch selten oder gar nicht übereinstimmt. Weshalb er dann sagt, man kann diesen Idealismus nur dann hochhalten, wenn man Mut zur Lächerlichkeit hat.
Ja, also lassen uns das langsam entfalten. Also das mit den Kurfürsten, mit den Mikrokurfürsten ist ja interessant. Das war ja die aktuelle Realität der Zeit, als Machiavelli schrieb, also ist ja hier in Frankfurt, sieben Kurfürsten kommen zusammen, treffen sich in so einer kleinen Kammer und wählen dann halt den nächsten König. So, schon unter den sieben war ja klar, dass man so Tricks anwendet, also echte Intrigen, wie zum Beispiel, ach so, du kommst grad vom Klo, also wir haben uns schon gewählt.
Ja.
So. Und dann, wann ist die nächste Wahl? Ja, wenn der König tot ist. Wer weiß wann das ist, kann in fünf Jahren sein oder in 50. So. Also Leute werden einfach ausgedingst so, ja.
Wir kennen das, das war dann kein Trick, sondern so ein Deal damals als Orban nicht dagegen stimmen sollte, bei irgendeiner Abstimmung in Brüssel.
Genau, da geht dann jemand raus.
Dass man sagte, wollen sie, dürfen wir sie einladen, dass sie vielleicht jetzt schon mal in die Mittagspause gehen. Ja, diese Spielereien.
So. Was also bei sieben Kurfürsten oder bei 28 Staats- und Regierungschefs im EU-Rat oder im Europäischen Rat klappt natürlich bei 60 Millionen Mikrokurfürsten nicht. Weshalb man in der Demokratie sich auf das von dir erwähnte Mindestmaß einigt, wir wollen zumindest mal einfach nicht regiert werden. So im Sinne von nicht unterdrückt werden. Nicht unterdrückt werden. Genau. Also wir wollen regiert werden, aber nicht unterdrückt werden. Und da sieht man ja schon, okay, das wird irgendwie nicht so aufgehen, weil wir wissen ja, die Freiheit ist immer die Freiheit des Andersdenkenden. Und die beginnt halt zwei Schritte nach vorne und schon steht man im Gebiet des anderen.
Ja, aber man hat ja da tatsächlich graduelle Unterschiede. Also wir können ja sagen, ist es eine Frage, jetzt wird man tyrannisiert oder nicht? Oder wie stark wird man unterdrückt? Also etwas Zwang und Unterdrückung ist immer da in jedem Herrschaftssystem. Ja, das beginnt mit der Straßenverkehrsordnung, wenn man so möchte. Aber dann ist die Frage, wie definiert man dann eine unerträgliche Unterdrückung?
Also ich finde es auf jeden Fall gut, dass wir ein Demokratiebuch haben, in dem nicht noch mal erklärt wird, dass ja die Theorie dazu Versagte und die ganzen Überhöhungen, also im Sinne von was braucht die Demokratie? Naja, sie hat auf jeden Fall Voraussetzungen, die sie nicht selbst herstellen kann. Also muss so der gute Mensch eine Rolle spielen. Und er sagt jetzt einfach, nee, erstmal einigt man sich darauf, nicht unterdrückt, nicht ausgesaugt, nicht überwacht, nicht belogen, nicht willkürlich eingesperrt zu werden. Und man denkt sich so, naja, aber damit ist ja die Rezeptur vollständig. Also wir haben eine von allen Inhalten befreite Demokratie Definition, die sich gerade noch so darauf einigt, dass es halt so Unterlegene gibt im demokratischen Ablauf. Also 50 Prozent plus lassen halt 49 Prozent zurück. Und da fragt man sich ja schon, wenn man das liest, ja, was soll denn daraus erwachsen? Ja, also wer hat jemals eine Idee entwickeln können, dass das jetzt ausreichendes Fundament ist. Und ich finde schon, da kommt halt dieses ganze Böckenförde-Diktum. Und ja, wir müssen uns zu Staatsbürgern sozialisieren, was auch immer. Das läuft halt wirklich zügig leer, wenn man das ernst nimmt, was er hier schreibt. Und wir kommen ja nicht drum herum, das ernst zu nehmen, weil es ist ja genau, wie sie das beschreiben.
Er geht ja sogar noch weiter und sagt, ist ja nicht nur so, dass man dann, wenn man diese Mehrheit hat, nehmen wir die 51 Prozent, diese Mehrheit repräsentiert bekommt. Denn das gibt es natürlich, dass man sagt, jetzt hat man dort eine Mehrheit. Aber wie drückt sie sich dann beim Regieren aus? Da sagt er, kein Mensch ist noch naiv genug anzunehmen, dass das, was in den Hauptstädten geschieht, ein Output aus dem ist, was die konvigierenden inneren Königtümer des vorgeblichen Souveränz namens Volk, Kraft ihrer Besonnenheit und Wohlberatenheit wirklich möchten. Das ist ja, um das mal runterzubrechen, genau das, was wir jetzt zum Beispiel beim Elend der SPD gut ablesen können, wenn immer man auf der regionalen Ebene mit SPD-Politikern redet und sie auf die Bundes-SPD anspricht, also auf das Willy-Brandt-Haus und alle, die dort so unterwegs sind, dann gibt es da Zorn. Wenn man mit SPD-Wählern spricht, dann gibt es nur noch Unverständnis dafür. Das heißt, die haben die zwar gewählt, haben die ins Willy-Brandt-Haus gebracht, aber deren Wille wird ja nicht im Willy-Brandt-Haus umgesetzt bzw. wird nicht in der Regierung dann entsprechend umgesetzt. Sloterdijks schreibt, nichts geschieht dort auf den geraden Bahnen einer Volonté générale. Und wenn sie nur ein personifizierter kollektiver Wunsch wäre, geschweige denn denen eine Raison générale. Alles, was beschlossen wird, ist ermüdende Aushandlung, Stückwerk, Kompromissprodukt, auch im besten Fall ein geringeres Übel, das sich rühmt, die unter den gegebenen Umständen am wenigsten schlechte Lösung zu bieten. In den geringeren Übeln kommen weniger die Voten der Bürger zum Tragen als die Erpressungen der Regierungen durch Koalitionspartner, Interessenverbände, Lobbyisten und mediale Agitationen.
Ja, und so haben wir eine Demokratie im Verfall in fünf Schritten. Also wir erklären den Mikrokönig, den Bürger zum Mikrokönig, reduzieren den dann aber auf einen Konsum souverän. Also er darf zumindest angebotsgetrieben im Regal noch aussuchen, welchen Joghurt er jetzt kauft. Der Kunde ist König. Dann zitiert er hier selbst Friedrich August den dritten im November 1918. Ja macht euren Dreck doch alleine. Also selbst das kleine Angebot wird er nicht mehr akzeptiert. Wir haben eine Postdemokratie durch Abdankungen von oben und von unten. Also Lars Klingbeier kümmert sich nicht mehr darum, was die Leute eigentlich bräuchten, sondern lässt sich da halt rein lobbyieren, weil schon klar ist, naja, arme Leute gehen ja eh nicht wählen. Die haben ja schon abgedankt. Die haben ihren Mikrokönigsstatus schon verlassen. Und damit wird die Postdemokratie und ich würde jetzt sagen, die Demokratie an sich zum, wie er schreibt, Vorraum der Wiedermonarchie. Also es wird dann einfach die Lücke gefüllt, die halt da ist. Und es ist zum einen die Lücke unten, nicht Wähler, die die Lücke wieder füllen und sagen, ja, ich gehe jetzt Krupalla wählen. Der bringt, oder Weidel, die bringt die richtige Wut mit, meine Wut.
Ja.
Und da ist aber nichts Konstruktives mehr drin, weder von unten noch von oben.
Nein.
Sondern da sind dann einfach 30 Prozent Destruktive, so wie hier zitiert Sartre. Ja, man geht nicht einfach nur nicht wählen, sondern damit gibt man der Demokratie noch einen Tritt. Und dann hat man halt 40 Prozent Weidel und alle fragen sich, also wie machen wir jetzt eine Regierung? Ach so, es muss einfach die CDU mit der Linken zusammenarbeiten, obwohl das gegen alle Statuten, die man sich, also man muss das alles über Bord werfen. Und das wird dann aus den Mikrokönigen, aus den Mikrorojalen wieder stolze Könige machen. Und geht natürlich nicht auf. Also ist auch sozusagen sehr gut beschrieben hier, dass es einfach in der Grundbauweise nicht hinhaut.
Dabei ist ja manchmal bei ihm nicht klar, was ist deskriptiv und was ist tatsächlich seine Position.
Aber das ist doch so toll.
Ja, ja, das ist ja auch das, was häufig eben Skandale einbrachte, wenn er da über Regeln für den Menschenpark redet und man plötzlich denkt, ja, steckt er jetzt ein eugenisches Programm oder was vor? Und hier hat man auch so den Fall, wo er aber dann deutlich wird, ist dann, was mich irritiert hat mit seiner Kritik an Sachtre, der die Demokratie als Gimpelfalle beschreibt. Also der Wähler ist eigentlich Verreiter an seiner eigenen Gruppe, sobald er da in der Wahlkabine steht und wählt. Die Demokratie gemeindet quasi ihn dann ein und er kann dann zum Beispiel nicht mehr entsprechend politisch werden im Sinne von Klassenkampf oder sonst etwas. Das heißt für Sachtre, dass er eigentlich mit dieser These diesen Tritt, der da von rechts kommt, nämlich gegen das Ganze als Gemeinwesen, plötzlich, dass dieser Tritt von Sachtre schon mit dem linken Fuß vorweggenommen wurde. Wenn ich auch sagen würde, na ja bei Sachtre geht es ja dann schon um so eine radikal-demokratische Idee, die da drin liegt, also aus dieser bürgerlich repräsentativen Idee der Demokratie auszubrechen, während das bei den Rechten ja tatsächlich auf eine Etablierung von Tyrannei hinausläuft. Auch wenn ich weiß, dass Sachtre mitunter mit linken Autoritären oder Tyrannen durchaus liebäugelte. Aber ich glaube, dass man das nochmal so trennen könnte. Deswegen ist bei Sloterdijk mir gar nicht so klar, was ist denn sein Plädoyer? Kannst du mir das sagen? Also kann man ein Plädoyer daraus ablesen, jetzt außer was wir schon angesprochen haben mit Aufrüstung oder sowas, kann man ein Plädoyer ablesen, dass hier jemand versucht, eigentlich die repräsentative Politik stark zu machen, die repräsentative Demokratie, die liberalen Institutionen zu stärken. Geht es mehr um eine elektorale Demokratie, wo es nur also darum geht, was ist die Mehrheit und das ist dann das, was gemacht werden muss. Siehst du da eine klare Tendenz?
Sehr, denn wir hampeln immer an dieser Demokratie rum, weil wir glauben, das ist der Dreh-und-Angelpunkt. Nur er sagt ja, Demokratie ist ja nur eine Form, den Staat zu regieren und schon der Staat ist ja eine falsche Idee. Also ist die Demokratie dadurch, dass sie die Hierarchie nicht aufhebt von oben und unten und echte Freiheit gewährt und sei es, dass man die Unterdrückung durch den Staat gegen die Unterdrückung von der Natur, der man dann ungeschützt gegenübersteht, dass man ihr ausgeliefert ist. Also er ist ja hier sehr auf dem Ohletrip, zu sagen, Demokratie schön und gut. Jedes Mal, wenn mir irgendwer irgendwas sagt, kann ich das sofort widerlegen, weil wir ja hier auf einem Felder arbeiten. Eigentlich müssten wir in den Keller gehen und den Staat selbst kritisieren. Ja, das macht er hier sehr gut. Weshalb er auch diese ganze Faszination für, ja, da sind jetzt Dispoten zurück, Tyrannen nach. Und klar, das ist nicht tiefstes Mittelalter, aber 15. Jahrhundert ist ja schon so, da hat die Welt mal gesehen, was übel bedeutet und böse, dass er hier sagt, na ja, darüber kann man schon erschrocken, also erschrecken. Aber deswegen ist es nicht unbegreiflich. Und das finde ich sehr gut, wie er das am Anfang ganz deutlich macht, zu sagen, es ist begreiflich. Wir sind nur einfach innerlich erschrocken, aber wir können es uns nicht nicht erklären. Während jetzt ganz viele behaupten, wow, das ist für mich so unerklärlich, wie das mit Trump, wie sind die Amerikaner so dumm? Ich kann das nicht verstehen. Er sagt eher, das ist jetzt die leichteste Übung. Das sind nicht mal 400 Seiten so Standard, sondern da schreibt man einfach mal kurz einen Essay. Das finde ich schon ein guter Einstieg.
Nur jetzt meine Frage zielte ab auf irgendeinen Ratschlag zur Demokratie, denn diese Dekonstruktion kann ich ja sehr gut nachvollziehen. Ich bringe nachher Barbarowski, der geht dann nochmal mit mehr Schmackes rein. Aber kannst du etwas herauslesen, wo du sagen würdest, das ist das Richtige, weil er sagt zum Beispiel Folgendes. Er sagt, na ja, bei der Demokratie muss es, solange sie vital sind, doch darum gehen, gegen autoritäre Versuchungen eine hohe Immunität herzustellen. Nietzsche hat ja selbst auch die demokratischen Institutionen sogar gelobt, als Quarantäne-Einrichtungen. Allerdings gibt er dann zu bedenken, sie sind jedoch a priori zweideutig angelegt. Weil sie zum meisten, zumal in großen Nationalstaaten, pyramidal-zentralistisch aufgebaut sind, fungieren sie als dynamische Paradoxien. Zur Diktaturverhinderung errichtet, laden sie zugleich zur Diktaturerrichtung ein. Die Mittel hierzu finden sich im kleinen Einmaleins des Populismus. Die Lähmung der Parlamente, die Umwandlung der Richterschaft in eine Gefolgschaft, die Einschüchterung der freien Meinungssprache, die allmähliche Gleichhaltung der Medien und die Aufstachelung des pochistischen Mops. Es kann kein Zweifel bestehen, dass Trumps Amerika all diese Anzeichen der autoritären Transformation aufweist. Hier kommen ja zwei Dinge aber zusammen. Trump also versucht, Parlament, Verfassung, all das so auszuhebeln, beziehungsweise mit seinen Leuten zu besetzen. Also die liberalen Institutionen. Zugleich aber sind ja diese liberalen Institutionen auch eigentlich welche, die im hohen Maße die Souveränität des Volkes einschränken.
Ja.
Und da bleibt er sehr unentschieden, will ich feststellen. Was vielleicht an dem Dilemma an sich liegt.
Beantworte jetzt deine Frage, was ich gerne mache und was ich nicht so gern mache, ist jetzt schon auf Seite 170, nämlich die zentralen Pornen zu sprechen kommen. Ich sage es trotzdem, denn der Entfaltung widerspricht ist jetzt nur minimal.
Aber das hier war zitiert von den ersten 20 Seiten.
Ja, aber die Antwort auf die Frage steht halt ganz unten. Also ob, aber ob konzellär oder lokal, ohne die gewöhnlichen Leute wird nichts zu machen sein. Also wir kommen mit den gewöhnlichen Leute nicht herum. Sie sind, wie sie zur Freiheit verdammt sind, auch dazu verurteilt, auf ihre Weise etwas Größe zu zeigen. Was für mich bedeutet, also er baut ja hier dieses Sartre, schreibt also 1946, der Mensch ist zur Freiheit verurteilt, weil er aus der Verantwortung, die die Freiheit mitgibt, nicht herauskommt. Und jetzt sagt Sloterdijk, 2026, wir sind zur Freiheit verdammt. Oder wie sie zur Freiheit verdammt sind, sind sie auch dazu verurteilt, etwas Größe zu zeigen. Was ja bedeutet, die Rolle des, und wir kommen hinter das Königliche, die Kaiserliche, die Hierarchie, nicht zurück. Macht ist da. Aber es steckt auch eine gewisse Macht auch im Mikrokönig, der beispielsweise einfach sagen kann und es dann auch tun sollte, sorry Herr Klingbeil, aber ich bin nicht bereit. I prefer not to. Und ich finde auch bei so Sachen wie, also du hast jetzt gesagt, in Gaza findet ein Genozid statt, das kann man so nicht stehen lassen, weil das Wort und so weiter, blablabla. Da kann man einfach sagen, das ist Größe zeigen. Es ist mir eigentlich egal, was im Handbuch steht, die Realität ist. Und wie wir das jetzt nennen, ist egal, sondern ich bin dagegen. Und dieses Dagegen und das Stimmen, das sieht man halt nirgendwo. Also die Leute nehmen ja alles hin. Und werden halt über diesen Konsum wirklich ruhig gestellt.
Als seien wir Zuschauer, obwohl wir ja eigentlich Akteure sind.
Genau. Und da muss ich sagen, ja, das ist schon ein Ausweg aus der Misere. Denn auch Sloterdijk würde jetzt sagen, naja, wir interessieren uns schon dafür, warum jetzt Putin und Trump zurückkommen. Nur anstatt die ganze Zeit zuschauend zu sagen, wow, das ist wirklich so krass und die sind so böse und ich kann das nicht verstehen, muss man dann halt sagen, naja, komm, also wir sind selbst schuld. Und so schwer ist das nicht zu verstehen.
Das bedeutet, es geht Sloterdijk um eine Selbsteinmächtigung. Eigentlich würde ich sagen, eines jeden Einzelnen, womit er seinem Individualismus zwar die Treue hält, aber diesen nicht einfach im luftleeren Raum geschrien lässt, sondern sagt, genau das ist ja die Verantwortung in der Freiheit zu sein, heißt dafür, verdammt zu, dazu verdammt zu sein.
Aber es ist im Sloterdijkchen-Denken eben das richtige Leben im falschen.
Ja.
Also wir kommen nicht aus dem Staat heraus, aber im Staat doch bitte nicht die dümmsten als die Könige. Und deswegen ja das Absurde, das Große, was wir jetzt ausführlich entfalten müssen.
Ja, ja, unbedingt.
Weil da widerstrebt es ihm ja komplett, wie kann das mit meiner Menschheit passieren, sozusagen, dass die Leute hier so, naja. Sehr interessant ist jedenfalls seine Cliffhanger-Theorie. Wir haben also ein König, das Mittelalter, die Neuzeit, wie auch immer, bis Ludwig dem Sechzehnten und dann wird er einfach geköpft. Also die Grundlage war eigentlich da. Und dann kommt aber nicht die Demokratie, sondern ein Cliffhanger als Brückenzeit, bis der König zurückkommt, aber in neuer Semantik umkleidet. Plötzlich ringt man ihm ab, dass er gut zu seiner Ehefrau ist. Sonst kann man Präsident nicht wählen, weil in Amerika lange es muss familiär stimmen und so. Bis dann Trump gesagt hat, nö, man kann auch einfach mit Stormy Daniels am Tag, der Geburt des Sohnes durch die Nacht und so und solche Sachen. Demokratie ist Cliffhanger Reiben. Und wenn es schief geht und die Franzosen haben mehrere Versuche gebraucht, kommt halt erstmal ein römischer Kaiser aus Urzeiten zurück. Der kriegt dann auch noch mal Kinder und so. Und das sind immer noch Kaiser. Aber irgendwann dann beim fünften Versuch könnte es ja mal gelingen, bis dann wieder Le Pen oder ihr Zögling da kommt und so. Aber er würde sich natürlich keine normative Wertung hier zutrauen. Ich mir aber schon. Ich würde schon sagen, Macron ist ein besserer Präsident als eine Le Pen.
Ja.
Auch wenn es in politisch viele Verwerfungen gibt und die Rente da reformiert wurde. Aber das ist ein bisschen wie zwischen Merkel und Weidel sind jetzt voll verschiedene Personen. Ja.
In der Tat, in der Tat. Wie wollen wir weiter vorgehen? Was ist etwas, was du unbedingt ansprechen willst? Also, wir können jetzt über die verwilderte Vertikalität sprechen oder würdest du gerne?
Ja. Also, wir haben jetzt den Grundstein, finde ich, gut gelegt und haben eine Kerntese, nämlich, und es ist ja bei ihm, das Französische ist besonders interessant, weil erstens die französische Revolution. Die Leute haben wirklich einfach dem König den Kopf abgeschlagen. Zweitens, es folgte nicht die Demokratie, obwohl das alle wollten. Erst mal kam Rakobiner, wie sie auch immer heißen, Jakobiner Schreckensherrschaft. Und dann kam ein neuer Kaiser und was auch immer. So, und es hat fünf Versuche gebraucht. Aber, würde ich jetzt sagen, es kann gelingen. So wie man bei Auschwitz sagt, es ist geschehen, es kann wieder geschehen, würde ich sagen, es ist denkbar, dass auf den König eine Demokratie folgt. Und wir haben es ja schon gesehen, es ist geschehen, es kann wieder passieren. So, wie kann man das forcieren? Und bei dieser Frage, wie kann man das forcieren, würde ich sagen, wir müssen mehrere Dinge beobachten. Zum einen ganz wichtiges Thema bei ihm, die Entsakralisierung des Throns. Napoleon kam, aber er hat nie ausgeschlossen, dass er nicht auf Gottes Gnaden legitimiert ist, sondern durch Volkes Wille. Und so verrückt groß diese napoleonische Kaiser-Macht war, dahinter ist man halt nicht zurückgegangen. Auch Putin veranstaltet Wahlen. Auch Trump hat Angst vor, dass in Wisconsin bei einer Vorwahl irgendwas nicht zu seinen Gunsten ausgeht, weil sich das dann aufsummiert. So, und da würde ich sagen, das ist ein Fortschritt, den kann man mal verbuchen. Und den hat er auch gut beschrieben.
Was nicht bedeutet, dass sie sich zusätzlich noch vergöttlichen.
Ja, das können sie immer noch machen.
Weil sie ja dann auserwählt wurden vom Volk, ist das für sie ein Zeichen, dass sie an sich auserwählt sind.
Und da würde ich sagen, das ist gerade am größten zu beobachten. JD Vans gegen Papst Leo. Der eine sagt, aus göttlichen Gründen ziehen wir hier in den Krieg. Und der andere sagt, ne, aus göttlichen Gründen und ich spreche direkt viel und ich bin sein Stellvertreter, machen wir das nicht. Und einen Tag später heißt es ja doch Frieden und so. Zwei Wochen Frieden. So, dann muss man sagen, okay, das ist der größte Kampf, dass die Amerikaner versuchen, das jetzt wieder zu sakralisieren. Das wäre ein echtes Novum, das darf nicht geschehen. Ich finde, das wird auch das halbe Land nicht mitmachen, weil man nämlich eine echte kognitive Überzeugung braucht, ein Glauben und der ist einfach nicht vorhanden. Was bedeutet, als Alternative dafür hat man nur gewaltsame Unterdrückung, wie unter Putin. Der hat sich zwar auch die Kirche unterworfen mit seinem Dingssache, aber da läuft ja wohl selbe Gewalt. So, also die Endsakralisierung des Throns durch Napoleon, trotz Größe, trotz Absurdität, kann man schon mal verbuchen.
Putin ist das Stichwort, dazu schreibt er, in dem Machiavelli von der Macht der Fortuna handelt, deren Rad sich ständig dreht, eröffnet er ein Feld von Beobachtungen in Bezug auf die Aufwärts- und Abwärtsbeweglichkeit der als prekäre Vollmacht aufgefassten Herrscherposition. Nicht umsonst spricht man im Umkreis von putinahen Ideologen von der Staatsvertikale, die der neue Zar aufrechterhalten müsse, vor allem, indem er die Macht der Provinzgouverneure stark verringerte. Über dies kostete der neue Zentralismus den Kreml die zynische Allianz mit der strategisch reanimierten russisch-orthodoxen Kirche. Dass an deren Spitze eine zwielichtige Figur, wie der 2009 ins Amt gewählte Patriarch Kirill I geboren 1946 steht, ein ehemaliger KGB-Mann passt ins Bild. Unter ihm wandelte sich das östliche Christentum in die moralische Tapete einer neo-imperialen Aggressionsmacht.
Ja, genau. So, das kann man also verbuchen. Diese Sakralität ist jetzt gegeben, was bedeutet, man muss Herrschaft, Macht ein neues Fundament geben. Und das beschreibt er hier, das ist die Souveränität des Volkes in verschiedenen Ausführungen. Ich bin ihr alle. Ihr seid alle ich. Oder eben sie sind gegen ihn, weil er für euch ist. Also das war ja der eigentliche Erfolg von Trump, nicht dieses Sakrale. Da würde ich auch sagen, das wird wohl die etwas, und da muss man in Amerika sagen, die etwas aufgeklärteren Leute jetzt nicht unbedingt dazu bringen. Aber dass man, und das ist jetzt sehr clever über Bande gespielt, das hat ja Charlie Kirk, hat ja diesen Spruch, ich wusste gar nicht, also entweder hatte diesen Heider, also das Vorbild schon gekannt, oder die haben es jetzt wirklich neu erfunden, dass er einfach sagt, naja, wisst ihr Leute, er ist ihr und damit nicht die anderen, was in einem Land, in dem man nur in Washington erfolgreich sein kann, wenn man gegen das Establishment anargumentiert, also wenn man am besten in Alaska schon mal Gouverneur war oder irgendwo weit weg, dass man dann in Washington Erfolg hat. Es hat sich ja schon sehr abgenudelt eigentlich, dass man immer von außen kommen musste, nicht aus dem Betrieb, aber dass man es hier noch mal so explizit macht, er kommt nicht nur von außen, sondern er kommt noch für euch von außen. Und daran, wie sie ihn bekämpfen, erkennt ihr, von wie weit außen ihr kommt, nämlich genauso von so weit draußen, wie ihr seid, wie ihr euch fühlt und so. Das hat zwar auch, finde ich, das ist wirklich kurz vor, so religiöse Raffinesse, aber es ist halt ganz weltlich gebunden, dass Trump also jetzt diesen Shift macht. Und ich würde sagen, Trump ist so doof, der lässt sich halt zu allem verleiten. Da kommen halt einfach 30 Leute rein, die sagen, wir glauben an Gott und legen jetzt unsere Hand auf deine Schulter und plötzlich ist er so eine Woche lang so beseelt oder sowas. Aber nur aus der Zeremonie heraus. So er lässt sich da gefangen. Da würde ich halt sagen, das sollte er nicht machen, denn dieses Modell des, da ist ein Deep State, das Washington, die etablierten, ich komme von außen, das funktioniert ja erstaunlich eigentlich nach zehn Jahren immer noch. Obwohl er so, ne. Von daher würde ich sagen, jetzt keinen Tipp an Trump geben, aber diese Reaktualisierung des Gottes, Gnadentum, die JD. Vance jetzt da so versucht, die würde ich genau nicht machen. Was eben wieder bedeutet, ja, offensichtlich ist das Sakrale weiterhin ein Erfolgskriterium. Ja, also würde ich auf jeden Fall so sagen. Das können wir hier verbuchen. Und dann beginnt ja schon in den Vorüberlegungen sein Sturz in den Staat. Die 5000 Jahre oder das 5000-jährige Reich der politischen Vertikalität. Also, dass man es von oben nach unten denkt und jeder für sich einen Platz formuliert. Und diese 5000 stellt halt wirklich in Bezug zu 200 Jahre. Also, dass man dem Franzosen, dem König den Kopf nimmt. Das ist jetzt 200 Jahre her. Ist also eine kleine Variation von, wie man die Vertikalität des Staates organisieren kann. Da würde ich sagen, na ja, man kann schon nochmal Athen und so dazunehmen. Oder dass in Rom eben auch 500 und nicht nur sieben Kurfürsten da ein bisschen mitentschieden haben. Ja, also, dass Caesar eigentlich immer nur Konsul war und sich dann Kaiserrechte gab, die dann erst seinen erster Nachfolger, so richtig, als ich bin ein Kaiser wahrnehmen konnte. Das ist ja eigentlich diese Napoleon-Sache schon viel früher. Also eigentlich sind es gar nicht 5000 Jahre, sondern ich würde sagen, na ja, man hat ja so 3000 Jahre, aber ob man jetzt wirklich von Vertikalität sprechen kann.
Sloterdijks ist ja so besessen von der französischen Revolution. Er hat ja dieses Buch geschrieben, Die Schrecklichen Kinder der Neuzeit, in dem er auch so sehr deutlich macht, dass das die sind, die die Tradition kappen, die alles hinter sich lassen, die Köpfen, die Vater und Mutterlos in die Welt hinaus schreiten und dann Taten verrichten. Und das ist seine, sagen wir, kontrerevolutionäre Angst vor diesen Figuren. Deswegen ist da die Obsession mit der französischen Revolution, mit der dann diese moderne und Selbstsetzung beginnt, besonders groß. Wenngleich, das ist dann das beeindruckende, heißt Sloterdijks, diese Faszination für genau diesen Einzelnen, der sich selbst setzt, bis hin zum Napoleon, der sich selbst die Krone aufsetzt, dann doch wieder groß ist bei ihm. Dass die Faszination so immens dann wieder ist für gerade diese Figur, die sagt, ich gehe aus der Tradition hinaus.
Und da würde ich nämlich sagen, mit seinen eigenen Mitteln und ein bisschen die Faszination für Napoleon runtergeschraubt und ein bisschen für römische und altgriechische Versuche vorangestellt, da könnte man halt sagen, naja, es hat zweimal nicht geklappt, weil man einfach von dem Pantheon des Gottes Reichtum nicht lassen wollte. Also klar, stürzte man dann irgendwie zurück und dann haben die Christen auch noch so ein Angebot mit Jenseits und sowas gemacht, was ja nun für alle sehr verlockend war. Das sehe ich gerade eben, wie beschrieben, so nicht. Weshalb ich sagen würde, nee, Herr Sloterdijk, ist ja nicht einfach die letzten 200 von 5.000 Jahren, sondern es ist der dritte Versuch von immer wieder und diesmal ohne Gott. Ja, also wollen wir dir nicht nochmal eine andere Chance beiräumen als so, wie er das hier macht. So, aber das abgehandelt kommt ja dann auf seine Verhaltenslehre der Kälte zu sprechen. Ja, das ist also für uns ganz wichtig, weil hier geht's ans Eingemachte, nämlich die CDU Wirtschaftskompetenz Unterstellung.
Ja, er bezieht sich ja da auf das Buch von Helmut Leten, der sich mit der Literatur der 20er Jahre auseinandergesetzt hat und dann aber auch zu Grasjahn zurückgeht, um zu sagen, diese Verhaltenslehre der Kälte ist in den 20er Jahren ein literarischer Stil. Man findet das auch bei Ernst Jünger natürlich, der dann einer dieser Vertreter ist, meinte also, man setzt sich in eine Position, bei der man gerade nicht Empathie nach vorne stellt, sondern sich versucht, unempfindlich zu machen, um zu bestehen, für die 20er Jahre Literatur meint das auch, zu bestehen im urbanen Raum. Verhülle dich, zeige keine Gefühle. Auch bei Berthold Brecht findet man solche Anweisungen an die Großstädter. Aber das darüber hinaus gesehen und wie das ursprünglich in dem Handorakel von Graz ja mal angelegt war, bedeutet das natürlich, den politischen Führern zu sagen, werde unempfindlich, weine nicht, zeige nicht die Gefühle in der Öffentlichkeit, sondern zeige die Härte, die notwendig ist, um zu regieren.
Genau.
Und damit wird man also dann unterrichtet in dieser Verhaltenslehre der Kälte, die ein jeder an den Tag legen muss. Und wie es dann für Politiker dann so oft in der Floskel heißt, er musste unbequeme Entscheidungen treffen.
Genau. Und hier, finde ich, steckt eine große Lehre für Kritik daran drin, dass man nämlich nicht länger sagt, das Gegenwald hat eine Rede gehalten. Und ich finde, da sind so Defekte drin, sondern nein, das ist eine gewählte Praxisform.
Ja.
Die machen das mit Absicht. Die übersehen nicht einfach die Armen oder haben zu wenig Empathie oder was auch immer, sondern es ist ein Machtinstrument. So, und da kann man nämlich jetzt hier mit Handwerken sozusagen, also wirklich ein Kritikhandwerk neu begründen. Also, dass man es neu begründen muss, ist schon blöd.
Aber das muss man ja selbst hier ableiten, nur um das deutlich zu machen. Das muss man ja selbst da ableiten aus dem Text von Sloterdijk. Sloterdijk stellt das ja erst mal so hin und sagt, so geht Regieren. Ja. Wir, die wir ja die ganze Zeit darauf hinweisen, zum Beispiel bei der Klingenbeiräde, wie fatal eine solche Politik für so viele Menschen im Land ist. Wir sagen ja nicht, aber so ist es einfach gut, dass der Vizekanzler die Verhaltenslehren der Kelten an den Tag legt. Sondern wir würden ja schon genau dazu in Opposition gehen und sagen, ja, man muss mitunter unbequeme Entscheidungen treffen, aber bitte unbequeme Entscheidungen gegenüber den anderen.
Wir hatten es ja mal mit Rutger Brechmann.
Also du hast es ja deutlich gemacht, um dich nochmal zu unterbrechen. Klingen bei in seiner Rhetorik. Die Menschen müssen Opfer bringen, die Menschen sind dazu bereit. Wir müssen das kürzen und wir müssen da und dort und weiter. Also die Zwänge werden deutlich benannt. Als es dann um die Reichen geht, Vermögensteuer und so, sind die Formulierungen, wir werden mal darüber nachdenken, ob wir sie höflich bitten könnten.
Genau, so und da muss man aber die Rede eben genau studieren, wie wir es gemacht haben und die politische Praxis herausarbeiten, statt immer die irgendwelche Defekte aus der eigenen Beobachtung. So und jetzt schreibt ja Sloterdijks.
Du wolltest aber noch was zu Brichmann.
Ja genau, so Sloterdijks schreibt, In ihr wird die religiöse und humanitäre Moral durch diplomatisches Kalkül ersetzt. Also die Härte ist ein Kalkül. Es ist jetzt keine religiöse oder humanitär abgeleitete Moral, weil die würde ja Gegenteiliges sagen, sondern nein, diese Kälte ist diplomatisches Kalkül. Und jetzt kommt ein ganz wichtiger Satz. Gesetze der Ferne, der Fernethik, brechen in die Nähe welten gemeinsamen Lebens ein. Die Sphäre der Einfühlung muss eine, muss den Verhaltenslehren der Kälte Platz machen. So, und jetzt können wir jetzt, wir haben es an Rutger Brechmann beschrieben. Wir haben uns immer gefragt, was ist mit diesen Leuten los, die diese Kälte mitbringen? Und das beschriebene Szenario ist ja, wie vorhin schon kurz angedeutet, also du bist Finanzminister, hörst dir das Leiden an, gehst durch die Tür und verkündest, dass es sein muss. Kein normaler Mensch kann das aushalten, weil man hat ja gerade aus der Nahwelt, der Lebenswelt, eine echte Schicksalsschilderung vielleicht noch mit Tränen und so weiter dargeboten bekommen. Wie kriegt man das überhaupt hin, dann eine Sekunde später der Weltöffentlichkeit zu sagen und so weiter? So und hier kann man jetzt sagen im Rutger Brechmannsens Sinne, das schaffen nur Leute, die diese Nahwelt ausblenden und immer in der Lars Klingbeiligen Budgetrechnung bleiben.
Ja.
So und das wird hier beschrieben und zwar mit diesen Worten die Fernethik. Wir kommen ganz am Ende darauf zurück, was die Ferne so mit sich bringt, gerade wenn man sie mit Waffen, Technologie, also Magie überbrücken kann. Und die bricht in die Nahwelt herein. Nur Leute, die das können, können große absurde neurömische Kaiser innerhalb einer Demokratie werden. Und dann kommt die Aufklärung von Amlinger und Nachtweihe, wie diese Härte selbst im Publikum wieder verfängt. Und Leute sagen eben das eine. Ja. Also da kann man so Bogen schließen.
Das sind dann Leute, bei denen man Angst haben muss. Deswegen auch bei Pocher, der ja auch so eine Nahkälte hat im Sinne von, ja die will ja nur Geld. Also klar, man macht sich mit der Podcast und führt mit ihrem Gespräch von Angesicht zu Angesicht pro Publikum. Also muss man erst mal bewältigen. Deswegen mein Ratschlag zuletzt dazu, bitte nicht in die Politik wechseln.
Ja, eigentlich prädestiniert dafür.
Genau, da wird es dann gefährlich. Also das wird hier ganz wunderbar beschrieben, wie die Moral ausgetauscht wird gegen Kalkül. Und dieses Kalkül, abgeleitet aus Fernethik, also Budgetdenken, reinbricht in die Nahwelt, wo wir es eigentlich nicht aushalten. Wo wir sagen, nee, nach Feierabend geht man zu Hause, da ist Familie, da tankt man wieder auf und so. Da soll das eigentlich nicht stattfinden. Und dann kommt aber Klingbeil und sagt, übrigens ihr seid alle nicht mehr krankenversichert. Das muss man dann bewältigen, dann wird man ein großer absurder Fürst. Und Sloterdijk, finde ich, hat es wirklich hervorragend beschrieben. Er macht dann hier auch noch mal den expliziten Vergleich. Wir hatten ja ein Gegenangebot, Luther, fast zur selben Zeit. Luther hat aber nicht gerade Konjunktur. Die Leute rennen aus der Kirche in die Buchläden und lesen Machiavelli. Das im Grunde ist ein Bild. Also das Kalkül, ob siegt über die religiös unterfütterte Moral, ist wirklich sehr gut. An der Stelle sehr, sehr gut beschrieben.
Siehst du, dass Sloterdijk einen Ausweg daraus liefert, im Sinne von gibt es ein anderes als ein kalkuliertes Regieren, so wie es hier beschrieben wird?
Das nicht.
Das nämlich nicht.
Deswegen ja mein Appell, dass man jetzt die Kritik genauso in die Praxiswelt überführt. Weg von, da gibt es Defizite, der übersieht das. Und ich will es mal ganz explizit sagen, weil es gibt wirklich ein Beispiel, wo es immer wieder auffällt. Gilda Sahibi hat jetzt ein Podcast mit Arne Samsrott. Wir haben ihre Bücher, das letzte nicht so gut gefunden, aber das davor schon. Und Gilda Sahibi macht genau diesen Fehler. Sie sieht die Regierenden und unterstellt ihnen, etwas nicht zu sehen, was sie aber sieht. Und würden die auch sehen, was sie sieht, nämlich wie Menschen leiden oder so, dann wäre die Welt besser. Und da würde ich sagen, ne, wir haben hier gerade die Gegenaufklärung bekommen. Da findet aufgeklärte, aber eben fern ethische Praxiswelt in der Nahwelt statt. Ja. Und genauso muss man es auch re-ingenieren sozusagen, die Kritik.
Lass mich noch ein weiteres Beispiel bringen, denn ich habe das auch mit ja, mit Freude hier alles gelesen. Denn wir haben ja in Wohlstand für alle über dieses Buch von Mark-Uwe Klingen gesprochen von Känguru-Chroniken. Und da geht es auch laufend um die Faktenfeinde und warum die CDU dies oder das macht und nicht erkennt. Nein, die sind keine Faktenfeinde. Und auch die AfD ist kein Faktenfeind in dem Sinne. Das ist eine Interessenpolitik, die knallhart durchgesetzt wird. Und dieses Kalkül geht sehr oft auf. Und man muss gar nicht da jetzt anfangen mit, ja, warum leugnen die den Klimawandel? Weil es eine Strategie ist, fertig. Es ist ein strategisches Handeln. Strategie und Kalkül, das ist das Entscheidende. Man muss nicht noch mal irgendjemanden wachrutteln oder so. Die übersehen nichts. Die haben das sehr gut. Also wenn das Klingbeil einen Vorschlag macht, wie zum Beispiel, dass da die Familienversicherung abgeschafft wird, dann weiß der ganz genau, der ist der Finanzminister, der weiß ganz genau, was das für einzelne Haushalte bedeutet. Der ist ja nicht aus der Welt gefallen. Deswegen ist es völlig falsch, wenn man sich die ganze Zeit in diese Politikerköpfe hinein denkt und glaubt, dass die eigentlich so sind wie wir. Sie wollen eigentlich das Gute tun, aber sie haben es nur noch nicht erkannt, wie der Weg dorthin ist.
Genau. Und jetzt kommt ja die Anschlussfrage von Leuten, die das vielleicht kritisch hören, was wir gerade sagen. Also angesprochen alle, die jetzt hier angesprochen sind. Warum findet dann trotzdem so viel Irrsinn statt, bei dem es so leicht fällt zu sagen, die sind doch dumm, die haben doch was übersehen. Also wieso fördern die die Kinder nicht, bringt doch 7 Euro pro Kind und so. So und jetzt kommt hier, das ist natürlich alles sehr trickreich, Sloterdijks, aber wir werden es entziffern, die Genesis-Erzählung. Und zwar als Test der Unterwerfung. Das sind also Loyalitätsprüfungen. Wir hatten das schon bei der meritokratischen Falle. Man sagt den Leuten, für 700 Euro mehr machst du jetzt bitte den größten Quatsch der Welt. Und du sagst es auch. Und wenn du gefragt wirst, was du da machst, sagst du, du bist der größte Quatsch der Welt. Und was machen diese Studenten in Stanford und Harvard? Sie machen den größten Quatsch der Welt, sagen das auch und fügen dann aber in pochrascher Manier an. Aber dafür habe ich 700 Euro gekriegt.
Ja.
So, also da, wo es inhaltlich für uns so bescheuert wird, wird es strukturell interessant, dass man es also inhaltlich nur mit Schiffren zu tun. Es ist alles austauschbar. Es geht nur um die Frage, wenn der jetzt sagt, die haben die Wahl gestohlen von mir, was tust du, wenn du vom Senat auf Anhörung bist? Wohl wissend, dass die Wahl natürlich nicht gestohlen wurde, aber was will ich von dir hören? Ja, so und dieser Teil, und da kommt natürlich bei Sloterdijk, aber das macht ihr nicht so explizit, kommt die Gefahr des Religiösen. Denn aus dieser Religiosität kann man über erste, da kommt er hier mit erster Sünde, zweite Sünde und so weiter. Man findet die noble Ausrede, das übermütige, warum nicht und so. Da abgeleitet kommt die Loyalität. Und dann muss man ihm sagen, wieder die Hierarchisierung des Staates. Also eigentlich ist die Hierarchie des Staates zu lange, würde ich jetzt sagen, im Sloterdijkischen Kritikssinne, religiös verseucht worden. Statt einfach zu sagen, sorry Leute, dann mach doch jetzt mal technokratische Praxis. Ein Rat von 500, die wählen jetzt nicht erst mal einen Kanzler, sondern meine Kritik, werde ich dann auch im Buch schreiben zur Kommunalpolitik. Kommunalpolitik ist sehr viel wichtiger als alles andere, denn das, was in Berlin stattfindet, könnte man bei Gremienarbeit belassen. Der Bundestag ist beschlussfähig, er muss nicht erst einen Kanzler wählen. Das ist eigentlich völlig irrsinnig. Und umso mehr ich so etwas wie Sloterdijk lese, frage ich mich, warum braucht der Bundestag jetzt noch mal einen Napoleon? Da sind es doch schon 700 Leute. Glauben die, sie müssten jetzt noch mal den Klügsten wählen? Und das ist dann März und ich sollte es im Fernsehen sehen und denken, wow, geile Demokratie, absolut verteidigungswürdig.
Und du bekommst dann noch mal einen Kommentar, der Kanzler hat Stärke gezeigt.
Genau, der Kanzler hat Stärke gezeigt, er saß im Weißen Haus und hat geschwiegen. Das ist die größte Stärke. Er wurde nicht herausgefordert, sein Schweigen ist seine, was auch immer, er hat es gut, er. Also da kommt die ganze Absurdität von Demokratie mit rein, die uns jetzt immer so als verteidigungswürdig dargeboten wird. Wo ich sage, ne, vielleicht sollten wir wirklich die Begriffe wieder aktualisieren. Autokraten sind Tyrannen und das, was März Kanzler hat, das sind einfach Kaiser. Braucht die Bundesrepublik einen Kaiser? Oder beweisen die 700 Abgeordneten von uns, die direkt gewählt wurden, jetzt Wortlaut Sloterdijk, ein bisschen Größe und schaffen es einfach, ohne Kanzler ein Gesetz zu beschließen. Oder würde ich sagen, lasst es doch mal drauf angucken. Einfach der Kanzler wurde erst beim zweiten Wahlgang gewählt. Warum gibt es einen Wahlgang für den Kanzler? Einfach streichen.
Aber diese Sehnsucht nach Stärke, die ist natürlich in der Bevölkerung nicht gering. Und bei Medienleuten, wir hatten ja hier Clips gespielt, aus der Lage der Nationen, wo sie beim Alles gesagt Postkurs sitzen und sagen, ja dieser Pistorius, wie toll der ist. Und da sieht man auch, dass man doch so eine Führungspersönlichkeit, man will ja nicht Führer sagen, deswegen sagt man immer Führungspersönlichkeit, dass man so etwas auch braucht. Das ist schon eine sehr, sehr ausgeprägte Idee, weil wir alles so personalisiert haben. Also wir sind ja so personenfixiert. Und deswegen ist es ja genau richtig, sich mit diesen großen Männern jetzt mal auseinanderzusetzen, wie Sloterdijk das tut.
Absolut.
Worüber sollen wir noch sprechen? Du hast ja hunderttausend Notizen gemacht. Also ich könnte auch was liefern, aber bitte.
Also hier mit diesen Sünden. Das politische Denken der Neuzeit nach Machiavelli hat es also mit einem Gestaltwandel der Erbsünde zu tun. Besser mit ihrer systemischen Neutralisierung und ihrer staatsjuristischen Bemäntelung. Also wir haben die Erbsünde immer drin und dann werden halt diese Loyalitätsmechanismen aktualisiert. Während die erste Sünde durch grundlosen Gehorsam ein übermütiges Warum-nicht motiviert sein soll wollte, kleidet sich die zweite in die noble Ausrede, wonach alles Machthandeln so defensiv ob offensiv aus dem Gebot der Selbsterhaltung folgt. Also auch hier, das ist wirklich die Einladung, in diesen Text zu gehen und sich das vorpolitisch-theologische Fundament Adam und Eva essen vom Apfel. Warum? Naja, weil sie ihnen keine Ahnung, sie machen es halt und dann stürzen sie da rein in diesen Erklärungs- und dann müssen sie erklären, warum sie da reingebissen haben. Und die einfach nur, es war doch verboten. Also mit dem Apfel war ja nichts. Man könnte ja auch fragen, warum sollten die nicht ein Apfel essen? Also der Arzt sagt jeden Tag ein Apfel. Warum sollte es für Adam und Eva nicht gelten? Ja, weil Gott sagte und sie haben damit ihren Ungehorsam gezeigt. Und damit waren sie in so einer Loyalitätsfalle. Bitte erkläre dich, bekenne dich. Und das Bekenne dich zieht sich ja bis heute. So, Putin hat die Ukraine übergriffen. Was schreibst du in die Überschrift? Schreibst du einfach nur Ukraine-Krieg oder der völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg von Vladimir Putin auf das ukrainische Staatsgebiet im Sinne der Eroberung? So ja, bekenne dich, beiß nicht in den Apfel. Das ist überall immer wieder drin und organisiert Gefolgschaft bis heute, bei der wirklich fraglich ist, warum, warum ein Bundeskanzler, warum Fraktionen reichen nicht offene Fragen im Parlament und am Ende wird durchgezählt, wie ja bei der Präsidentenwahl auch einfach durchgezählt wird. Also das ist alles sehr, sehr, sehr gut begründet, was Sloterdijk hier schreibt, diese religiösen Anleihen und Ableitungen. Einfach ein Spektakel, würde ich sagen. Sehr gute Pointe. Also der Mensch in der Revolution, Camus.
In der Revolte.
In der Revolte 1951, genau die Revolte. Und jetzt sagt Sloterdijk, ja das Gegenbuch dazu wurde nie geschrieben, nämlich der Mensch in der Gefüglichkeit, aber es ist im Grunde jedes Geschichtsbuch, sagt er. Das muss man gar nicht schreiben. Jedes Geschichtsbuch.
Ja, das ist ein super Pointe.
Einfach genial. Also wirklich genial an der Stelle. So.
Das schafft man aber nur, wenn man unsentimental auf alles blicken kann. Das ist, glaube ich, seine große Stärke.
Ja, genau. Absolut.
Seine Stärke ist, da drauf zu schauen, nicht nervös zu werden, nicht emotional zu werden, das als große Struktur zu erkennen und dann die Analogien, die er natürlich hat. Die Belesenheit ist ja beeindruckend, was er alles heranziehen kann an Historie.
Ja, und der nächste Bogenschlag ist hier eben und es ist auch wahnsinnig gut, zu sagen, ja, nach dem Krieg hatte sich die Demokratie gerade dazu eingerichtet, zu sagen, okay, wir vermeiden jetzt mal das Allerschlimmste. Wir schreiben Artikel 1, die Würde des Menschen, was auch immer und so. 70 Jahre später kommt jemand auf die Idee und sagt, ich wünsche mir eigentlich einen charismatischen Führer. Es wäre cool, wenn nach dem müden, also Sleepy Joe Biden und dem Trumpf, nicht Trumpf, sondern wie immer, dass Olaf Scholz guckt, also gelangweilt, keine Ahnung. Der sagt ja gar nicht.
Der Scholzomat.
Genau, der sagt ja gar nichts, hält sich immer nur zurück und so. Ich hätte gern wieder ein rhetorisches Talent.
Ja.
So, dann wird Friedrich Merz als das rhetorische Talent verkauft. Und Sloterdijks macht das alles sehr klug, aber wir müssen es gar nicht im Text. Allein, dass ich das so sage, da weiß schon jeder, ja, warum brauchen wir einen charismatischen Führer? Wer kam auf diese Scheißidee wieder? So, jetzt haben wir in Amerika einen charismatischen Führer. Und? Was haben wir gewonnen? Also, das ist wirklich hervorragend zu lesen.
Auch auf die Tech-Elite, wir kommen ja gleich auf sie, besonders zu sprechen, geht er ein. Was er zu Meta sagt. Man hat einfach so in einem Absatz so einen tollen Diskurs gleich zu Meta. Er schreibt, naiv und raffiniert zugleich, ich erinnerte Zuckerberg daran, dass das Chaos der Zeichenflüsse eine regulierende Hand brauchen könnte. Also Meta war ja die Umbenennung. Facebook wurde in Meta umbenannt. Mit der Wahl des Namens Meta, griechisch für darüber oder danach, bot man sich selber als Provider der fehlenden Überwelt an, ohne aufzuhören, nur einer unter mehreren Verteilern von Dichtung, Wahrheit und Lüge zu sein. An dem polypolemischen Geschehen der Senderkriege vermochte der Impuls, Meta nicht das Geringste zu ändern. Immerhin erinnerte er an die Frage, wie ein Jenseits der Zeichenkriege zu denken wäre. Das Symbol Meta zeigte an, dass Souveränität auf dem Feld der Daten sich nur für den ergebe, der über ihren Fluss frei oder nicht entscheidet. Binnen kurzem wurde klar, wer Datenherrschaft fordert, möchte weniger frei geben als Kontrolle ausüben.
Damit sind wir in einem Rausch der Vertikalität.
Ja, eine Idee, die hier aufgegriffen wird von Karl Schmitt, der ja in seinen ganz späten Jahren dann noch sagt, Souverän ist, wie er über die Wellen des Raumes verfügt. Also eigentlich diese digitalen Ströme damit schon antizipierte.
Ja, der große Rausch der Vertikalität. Der Chef redet vom Jenseitigen, das man jetzt bräuchte, und er liefert es. Ja, so. Und dann hat man selbst in Tech-Konzernen, die nun wirklich sagen, wir brauchen die besten Mathematiker, Theologen nicht so. Ja. Und dann der Chef oben, ich habe so eine Idee, Meta, aus dem Jenseitigen. Wir sind besser.
Du hattest ja irgendwann mal hier einen Clip gespielt, da wurde Zuckerberg befragt, mit wem er sich berät. Und dann hat er ja geantwortet, dass er mehr zu Gott betet. Dass er also eigentlich auch nur noch mit dem Höchsten kommuniziert. Und Peter Thied ist ja noch mal ein eigener Fall. Nun ist ja Trump von einem anderen Kaliber, dieser Gottesbezug, wie du sagst, der kommt man so affektiv zustande heute, morgen, aber dann nicht mehr. Bei Trump ist es ja die Prominenz. Auch das arbeitet Sloterdijk gut heraus. Er schreibt, was an Höhe fehlt, muss durch Reichweite kompensiert werden. Dies liefert einen der Gründe dafür, dass Adel sich in Prominenz verwandelt. Verwilderte Prominenz wiederum ist der Stoff, aus dem die Kandidaten für den oberen Pol der Machtachse gemacht sind. Das zeigt sich an keiner Figur der unmittelbaren Gegenwart so deutlich wie an Donald Trump. Das ist ja auch seine große Unterscheidung, die man machen muss zu Putin, der ja genau nicht mit dieser Prominenz gearbeitet hat, der nicht ein Sozial- und Social-Media-Phänomen sowieso nicht, aber auch nicht ein Fernsehphänomen oder sowas war, sondern der ja so der stille Kagi Beeler ist.
Genau, und da muss man ja eh jetzt auch bei Sloterdijk mal kritisch anmerken, weil er vorhin so diese die neue Sonosphäre, jeder macht irgendwas mit TikTok und so, und damals, jeder hat schön gelesen. Also Reichweite, ja, wir stecken in einer Sehgewohnheit drin, heißt das ja, das Publikum wählt also aus einer Sehgewohnheit heraus. Man muss den Kandidaten schon kennen. Also es ist die große Aufgabe von Frank Stauß, Kampagnen zu machen, um den Leuten zu erklären, wer ist denn jetzt der SPD-Kandidat, der da im Rheinland-Pfalzischen und so weiter antritt. Und da würde ich doch sagen, das ging doch früher sehr viel besser als heute. Also im TikTok-Zeitalter einen Kandidaten bekannt zu machen, dann lieber abends beim Berlin direkt platzieren und erst mal drei Sektflaschen aufmachen. Und da würde ich nämlich auch sagen, diese Idee von, dass Trump heute besonders irre ist, stimmt ja nicht, wenn wir Nixon dagegen stellen. Die Frage ist nur, wie wurde Nixon contained? Und da würde ich sagen, nicht vom Wähler, sondern von der strukturellen, so funktioniert Washington. Da muss halt der Kongress und der macht dann und so weiter und so fort. Und da würde ich sagen, hier läuft auch ein großes Argument von Sloterdijk, also das Taylor Swift Argument, ziemlich in die Leere.
Jaja, weil bei Nixon, er ja am Ende auch an die Sendeanstalten, an die Zeitungen, er war auf die angewiesen. Wie das bei Trump überhaupt nicht der Fall ist. Ganz im Gegenteil, wie wir ja sehen, die Kommunikation jetzt ja auch bei dem ganzen Irankrieg, findet vorwiegend über Truth Social statt.
Genau. Also es ist grundsätzlich anders zu beobachten, auch in Sachen nicht nur Reichweite des Publikums, um den Herrscher zu sehen, sondern auch, was kann der Herrscher anrichten? Im Iran anzugreifen, ist eine große Sache. Aber im Vietnamkrieg, wenn man sich die Opferzahlen anschaut und so, da würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass die Sonosphäre irgendwie zu krasseren Sachen des amerikanischen Präsidentenhandelns führt, als jetzt in vorherigen Zeiten.
Mit einem sehr intellektuellen, belesenen Mann an seiner Seite, der das alles in die Wege geleitet hat, nämlich Henry Kissinger.
Ja, und mehrere noch.
Das ist ja...
Viele Berater aus dieser Zeit sehr berühmt geworden. Es gibt ja dieses Kapitel, ich weiß nicht ob du darüber, zum Thema Marx oder Hegel, die Tragödie und die Fars als Wiederholung. Er sagt, Marx hat Hegel falsch gelesen. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe weder Marx noch...
Lass mich das durchstehen, es ist jetzt wirklich müßig, wenn wir das jetzt wieder alles... Weil Sloterdijks nochmal...
Marx vertrete eine Pointe, steht hier.
Marx was mitgeben will. Ich sehe das nicht so, ich lese das anders. Er will aber so viel über Napoleon und Napoleon III und diese ganze Operettenherrschaft in Frankreich schreiben, ohne viel auf Marx einzugehen, obwohl eigentlich dieser Text, der 18. Premier, der entscheidende Text ist, um diese Operettendiktatur zu verstehen. Jetzt geht aber Sloterdijks so ein Umweg, damit er ja nicht so viel Marx zitieren muss. Ich finde es ein bisschen komisch, ehrlich gesagt. Weil man da auch mal, das hätte nachlesen können, dieser Neuburnapartismus wurde ja auch von Jacobin-Autoren oder so ziemlich gut jetzt herausgearbeitet in Bezug auf Trump. Da würde ich sagen, da wollte er origineller sein und hat sich deshalb der Marx-Lektüre entledigt. Interessanter finde ich, auch bezogen auf unsere Frage der Meritocracy-Trap, wie das eigentlich ist, wenn man da oben ist und wie sich das anfühlt. Es ist ja so, dass man immer wieder so Studien vorfindet, dass man zum Beispiel Leute Monopoly spielen lässt. Und dann gibt man dem einen Spieler gleichen Vorsprung. Der hat einfach doppelt so viel Geld oder sowas. Und trotzdem, wenn er dann mit dem doppelt so viel Geld gewinnt, sieht er sich als verdienter Sieger an. So fragt sich jetzt Sloterdijk auch, ist man eigentlich erwählt, wenn man oben ist. Wie empfinden die sich? Nietzsche notierte hierzu wie nebenbei. Kein Sieger glaubt an den Zufall. Man kann den Satz in eine höhere Potenz erheben. Leute an der Spitze verzichten selten darauf, sich als Erwählte zu verstehen. Wenige haben die Kraft oder die Gelassenheit, ihren Erfolg innerlich zu säkularisieren. In dieser Hinsicht blieb Marc Aurel, der exemplarische Fürster Nüchternheit. Unzählige andere erlangen der Erlagen der Versuchung, dem Beweis des Geistes aus der zeitweilig erwiesenen Kraft zuzustimmen. Bin ich oben, müssen höhere Geister befohlen haben. Ich möge diese Position innehaben. Wer weiß, ob nicht Gott durch mich handelt. Das ist ja etwas, was wir, denke ich, schon bei Trump mehr und mehr gesehen haben. Seit diesem Anschlag, seit dem Attentat auf ihn, sieht er sich noch mal in ganz besonderer Weise erwählt.
Ja, das stimmt. Also die zweite Amtszeit ist auf jeden Fall einzeln zu betrachten. Die zweite Amtszeit, deswegen komme ich noch mal ganz kurz auf dieses Marx-Ding, weil mir diese Pointe unabhängig davon, ich weder Hegel noch Marx, groß Interesse. Aber, dass Marx Hegel unterstellt, er hätte gesagt, naja gut, die Geschichte wiederholt sich, erst als Tragödie, dann als Fass, kontert jetzt Sloterdijk in dem Wesentlichen. Nein, beim zweiten Mal zeigt sich, wie sehr es ernst ist. Da finde ich natürlich zum einen, das finde ich gerade sehr plausibel, weil Trump 2 ist auf jeden Fall ein anderes Problem als Trump 1. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir, vielleicht hat Sloterdijk die jetzt wirklich aus Fernsehgucken abgeleitet und gar nicht so sehr aus Marx und Hegel, denn für die Amtszeit von Trump gilt es. Aber wenn ich mir jetzt anschaue, März ist ja auch zum zweiten Mal da. Und beim ersten Mal, okay, aber der Fraktionsvorsitzende hat immer gesagt, der Kanzler braucht Wachs und Wachs und Wachs, warum versteht das der Schröder nicht und so weiter. Nur jetzt beim zweiten Mal ist es halt wirklich Tragödie. Also März ist gerade nicht auf der Höhe von irgendwas. Er hat null Gestaltungsspielraum und die Umfragewerte sind unter Scholz.
Hier würde ich aber jetzt zur Präzision einwerfen. Es ist genau deshalb nicht Tragödie, sondern Fars. Also wir verwenden diesen Begriff Tragödie ja gerne so, das war ein tragischer Unfall. Meistens sind Unfälle nicht tragisch in dem Sinne, sondern sind wirkliche Unfälle. Sie passieren. Tragisch heißt er wirklich, da hat jemand eine richtige Fallhöhe erleidet, einen Sturz. Das ist ja tatsächlich die erste Märzgeschichte. Jemand, der alles immer für die CDU getan hat, der alles richtig gemacht hat, der das Gesicht der Bundesrepublik ist. Und dann kommt da so eine Frau aus dem Osten und rangiert den einfach aus. Er ist einfach weg. Das ist die tragische Position, von der sich Friedrich März nicht mehr erholen konnte. Und jetzt sind wir eigentlich in der Phase. Das, was du da beschreibst. Ihm sind eigentlich die Hände gebunden. Man ist froh, wenn er neben Trump sitzt und nichts sagt. Macht er eigentlich irgendwas? Wir wissen es gar nicht. Das Ministerium für Wirtschaft weiß auch nicht ein noch aus. Das heißt, hier sehen wir eigentlich so was völlig Freiträgendes. Zwischendurch noch mal so eine Marktplatzansprache, wann immer irgendein Problem sich ergibt. Die Migranten werden schon schuld sein. Also das ist wirklich so ein Agieren in der Phase. Und da würde ich auch zustimmen, das ist ja auch eine Ergänzung, die nicht nur Sloterdijk macht, sondern auch Zizek hat die immer gemacht. Ja, ja, die Phase kann durchaus schlimmer sein als die Tragödie. Vor allem für die Bevölkerung. Auch hier ganz wichtig immer wieder zu sehen, dass wir heute, du hast es eben schon gesagt mit Putin, der ja auch noch Wahlen veranstaltet, dass es immer über diesen Zug der Demokratie geht. Er bringt dann Erdogan. Immerhin hatte Erdogan für einmal nicht gelogen, als er schon 1997 erklärte, die Demokratie sei nur der Zug, in dem man steigt, um ganz anders wohin zu fahren. Man weiß jetzt in die Richtung der islamischen Theokratie. Für Modi hatte er auch ein paar Worte übrig. Er missbraucht die Religion so, wie sie nach dem Sturz in den Staat von Al-Taser unzählige Male missbraucht wurde. Er nutzt sie als Hauptmotiv des sozialen Zusammenhalts in seinem zwischen Mittelalter und hypermoderne schwankenden Reich, Kennwort Hindutva. Er verwendet sie, um den anti-muslimischen Affekt zu einem Argents neohindonistischer Solidarität zu machen. Er braucht den Hass gegen Muslime, um den armen Hindus, die auch unter ihm im Elend bleiben werden, etwas zu geben, worauf sie hinabblicken dürfen, als sollten künftig die Muslime in der Rolle von Asiens Juden zu den Sündenböcken des aufleuchtenden Subkontinents werden. Treffner kann man diese Modi-Herrschaft, glaube ich, nicht beschreiben.
Genau. Das Modi-Kapitel ist ja sehr ausführlich. Ich dachte mir, das ist ja dein Metier. Deswegen habe ich mir gar nicht so viel dazu rausgeschrieben. Aber ich finde es natürlich unter dem Gesichtspunkt, den ich vorhin anmerkte, nämlich dass man das Sakrale eigentlich aussatiert hatte. Die Frage ist nur, welche Traditionen haben die Inder vor Modi gehabt? Also war das schon mal das Sakrale aussatiert und jetzt kommt es wieder rein? Oder steht Modi in so einer Tradition?
Es gab ja schon eine Sekularisierung, die dann wieder zurückgedreht wurde. Natürlich war das immer religiös, aber es gab ja, da sagen wir, eine Spiritualität, die aber nicht in so einen Hindu-Nationalismus direkt kommen musste. Peter Sloterdijk ist, glaube ich, auch deshalb so ausführlich über Indien am Schreiben, weil er ja selbst dort war, früher. Also er ist ja mal, soweit ich das weiß, hat er doch da seine wilden Jahre verbracht. Also er hat doch mal irgendwann im Interview gesagt, dass ich da habe einige Federn lassen müssen. Ja, also das ist noch aus der Selbstfindung quasi der 78er heraus.
Okay, also ich habe mir nur aufgeschrieben, dass Sloterdijk doch sehr beeindruckt davon ist, wie beeindruckt Trump davon ist, was Modi da gelangt, das nämlich sozusagen zu realisieren.
Vielleicht findet man das noch in, ja man wird es finden.
Also wir haben ja mal im Podcast über Modi ausführlich gesprochen und dann habe ich ja auch Clips mitgebracht zu der Social Media Strategie und diesem sehr religiösen, ein bisschen zu den großen Yogatagen und was da alles veranstaltet wird.
Da findet ja wirklich ein neuerinnerndlicher Gesang auch so statt, um das auf so einer methodischen Ebene zu bringen. Ein großer Bogenschlag zu Daub ist hier in dem Buch, nämlich werden es schon häufiger als angesprochen, das apes-apostolische Leben gegen die spendable Gier. Wir werden bei Daub nachher lesen, dass es einen großen Unterschied zwischen dem Caretaker und dem Creep gibt und dass sie sich dichotom gegenüberstehen. Der eine möchte helfen und sich kümmern und der andere steht genau da leben und verachtet das. Und das haben wir hier auch. Wir haben vorhin schon, deswegen müssen wir es gar nicht in Tiefe machen, über die CDU-Unterstellung, dass da so viel Wirtschaftskompetenz. Das wird also hier im Buch nochmal wiederholt mit apostolisch als Begriff und kirgigart als und so weiter. Also hier kann man auch, wenn man sich, ich finde ja diese Frage relativ wichtig fürs politische Tagesgeschäft. Warum der CDU da immer so viel, es ist nicht nur Issue ownership, sondern hier kann man dann sehen, was noch drinsteckt. Aber da kommen wir bei Daub und dann dem Creep, dem Creep zwei Kapitel zurück. Was hier ja noch interessant ist bei Sloterdijk im Kapitel ist, vor dem Start als dort wirst du unterworfen, geht er noch einen Schritt zurück, also in den Bildern, die er gibt, in dieses jägerisch sammlerisch, sammlerische Leben von Adam und Eva und deswegen der Apfel, die der Natur unterworfen sind. Hier würde ich sagen, müsste man mal ein Gespräch mit Sloterdijk darüber führen und mit Ole auch. Es könnte eigentlich ein Streitgespräch oder ein Konsensgespräch von Ole und Sloterdijk sein, wie die ideale Welt jenseits des Staates aussieht, in der also zum einen per se ausgeschlossen ist, dass es überhaupt jemanden gibt, der in der Rolle ist und dann noch ein Befehl geben kann, du musst jetzt hier sterben für uns. Denn aus einer, also das wäre Unterdrückung so, ja. Aber aus der Unterdrückung kommt man nicht raus, man kann sie nur eintauschen gegen eine Unterwerfung, nämlich der Schutzlosigkeit. Die Natur. Was ja in diesem Bibelbilde des Apfels, also die Natur macht ein Angebot, du greifst zu und zack, ist die Falle, der Sünde und so. Du musst dich erklären, bekennen und dein Leben ändern. So drin. Und hier finde ich, fehlt mir auch sozusagen die Alternative zum Sturz in den Staat.
Das Problem bei dieser Idee des Schutzes ist ja, dass es nicht nur Schutz meint, sondern würde ja dann zum Beispiel bedeuten, dass du für das Land kämpfst, also deinen Schutz plötzlich aufgeben musst, also einem Gefecht ausgesetzt bist, dass du wirklich sterben kannst, zum angeblichen Schutz deiner selbst, was ja ein Widerspruch an sich ist.
Genau, da ist also eine Paradoxie, die lässt sich weder auflösen noch ablösen, weil Tod ist Tod. Nur, wenn ich keinen Staat habe, gilt eben mein Schicksal des Todes für alle, die ungeschützt der Natur überlassen werden.
Na, man könnte sich sicherlich auch ohne den Staat vor der Natur schützen.
Ich würde ja sagen, hier haben wir es wieder mit so einem Ding zu tun, wie schon bei der Demokratie selbst. Am Ende funktioniert die Demokratie, weil sie mathematisch einfach durchzählt. Eine profane Einsicht, die ja gar nicht erwähnt, also was Demokratie im Kern ausmacht. Weshalb ich auch sagen würde, na ja, der Staat, wir sind nicht in den Staat gestürzt, sondern wir haben eine, wie soll man sagen, wir begegnen uns halt. Und damit findet automatisch Koordination statt. Und wir können aber der Begegnung nicht entgehen, da die Begegnung im Dorf, in der Stadt, in der Nation immer noch bevorzugt wird gegen der Einsamkeit im Wald.
Ja, aber du bist ja zum Beispiel viel touristischer unterwegs als ich. Da begegnest du den anderen ja nicht als Staatsbürger.
Na ja, doch irgendwie schon, weil wir sind ja alle, wenn auch nicht den gleichen Sitten, deswegen ja das interessante Phänomen des Kulturschocks, dann doch so einer gewissen Moral. Na ja, zumindest verprügeln wir uns nicht, wenn wir uns begegnen, sondern ich frage, kann ich hier ein Getränk kaufen? Und die sagen ja gegen Geld und es ist nun mal überall eine Welt einheitlich.
Ja, aber das hat ja nichts mit dem Staat zu tun. Also das ging ja auch ohne Staat.
Das Geld akzeptiert, weil das Zahlungsmittel geht.
Ohne Staat.
Ohne Staat?
Ja, also das geht auch anders.
Ohne großen Dritten, der daneben steht und wacht.
Ja, wenn man sich da einig ist, also das zeigt ja der Bitcoin.
Ja, wenn man sich da einig ist, aber die Einigkeit ist halt nicht, also das ist jetzt keine chompschische Grammatik in uns. Das ist ja der Punkt.
Nee, das will ich auch nicht damit gesagt haben, nur gibt es ja ganz viele Ordnungen, die stattfinden, die nicht staatlich reglementiert sind, beziehungsweise wo wir die die gar nicht in Anschlag bringen. Also du hast ja im Miteinander mit Menschen ganz viele Regeln, die du befolgst, wenn du jetzt in etwa gleiche Werte teilst. Also du liest ja nicht, wenn du in den Staat gehst, wo du Urlaub machst, erstmal das Sexualstrafrecht durch, um zu sagen, so geht man hier miteinander um, sondern du lässt dich auf irgendwas ein.
Unwissenheit schützt nicht vor Stafeln.
Genau, das ist sicherlich so, aber so begegnest du ja nicht in der Regel Menschen, dass du dich in dieser Weise vorbeizie. Also du würdest jetzt in einem radikal islamischen Staat, würdest du dich vorher mal informieren, was darfst du auf der Straße tun und lassen. Das ist sicherlich so, aber wenn du so dich, also wenn du touristische Begegnungen hast, dann begegnen sich da eigentlich nicht Staatsbürger untereinander. Weil dich auch das gar nicht interessiert. Also du wirst ja nicht, wenn du jetzt einen Chinesen triffst, wirst du ja nicht mit dem erst über Chi reden und dann redet ihr darüber, wo man hier gut was essen gehen kann.
Aber da bin ich ja auch nicht Habermas, der sagt, das muss erst ausdiskutiert werden, sondern ich sage, es gilt natürlich trotzdem, auch wenn man nicht darüber gesprochen hat.
Und jetzt ist ja nur was gilt denn da, wenn du jetzt, wenn der Chinese und der Deutsche, die sich treffen, was gilt denn dann? Also wir sehen ja dann klappt ja komischerweise Kommunikation, vielleicht sogar Beziehung, jedenfalls einen gemeinsamen Abend verbringen. Was weiß ich, das funktioniert ja auch alles ohne den Staat erst mal. Also wenn du jetzt in der in irgendeiner Flughafen Lounge setzt, dann setzt du da mit so vielen unterschiedlichen Nationalitäten zusammen, dass sich nicht die Frage stellt, was ist jetzt gerade hier staatlich angesagt, sondern die Frage ist nur, was sagen die AGBs von Lufthansa dazu? Kriege ich noch ein gratis Getränk oder muss ich dafür zahlen?
Ja, aber die soziale Ruhe, die ich da erwarte, klappt natürlich nur, weil die Rechtfertigungspflichten im Konfliktfall verteilt sind. Deshalb ich versuche, Konflikte möglichst zu vermeiden, also mich konform zu verhalten, weil ich weiß, also wenn ich in China angesprochen wurde, weil ich mich in der Lounge falsch verhalten habe, dann ist es auf jeden Fall meine Aufgabe, mich erstens zu erklären und zweitens Besserung zu geloben und drittens zu verstehen, wie diese Besserung von mir umgesetzt werden kann. Und dass das, ich meine jetzt nicht geschriebene Gesetze, sondern dass das so gilt, dafür brauche ich zwingend einen Staat. Weil ansonsten könnte ich da einfach auftreten und sagen, mir doch alles egal. Und es würde gar keine Lounge geben, weil die Lounge als Bauwerk funktioniert überhaupt nur, weil es diese impliziten Abmachungen, und das ist eben soziologisch doch recht einfach erklärbar, da braucht man jetzt keinen Böckenförde Diktum oder sowas. Nur weil etwas nicht ausgesprochen ist, heißt es nicht, dass ja, vogelfrei und so, sondern es geht um diese Verteiligung von Rechtfertigungspflichten. Und die sind bei aller Unwissenheit. Ich kann die Sprache nicht, ich habe nie einen juristischen Text auf China gelesen und so, ja. Aber dass ich mich rechtfertigen muss, wenn hier Konflikte auftreten, weshalb ich angehalten bin, sie zu vermeiden, hat ganz viel mit Staat zu tun.
Das will ich auch nicht anders sehen. Nur, der Staat ist nicht eine Voraussetzung dafür, dass das funktioniert. Das ist möglicherweise anders zu regeln.
Doch, aber da man es nicht auflösen kann, brechen wir hier an der Stelle dieses Gespräch ab und kommen zu Rousseau und Carl Schmitt. Wir können es kurz machen.
Wir müssen uns ein bisschen eilen.
Ja, wir machen es kurz. Rousseau erfindet dieses Wir neu und sagt irgendwie das Kollektive. Kann man jetzt unendliche Abhandlungen machen, was das bedeutet. Schmitt sagt jedenfalls, operationalisiert bedeutet das, der Wille lässt sich überhaupt nur über Personalisierung finden, um eine und Wille heißt ja Gerichtetheit kollektiv herzustellen, braucht man Anführer. Und wenn der Anführer noch sagt, macht es wie ich und nicht wie der, dann hat man noch die Freund-Feind-Unterscheidung und dann ist sozusagen alles gesetzt. Weshalb er jetzt Schmitt unterstellt. Carl Schmitt wird wohl großer Freund von Donald Trumps sein, alleine weil die Führerfigur so stark ist und weil die Richtung, egal wohin sie führt, so deutlich angezeigt wird.
Das glaube ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also dass Carl Schmitt Hitler unterstützt hat, das ist ja weit hin bekannt. Er zitiert ja nochmal diesen entsprechenden Text, der Führer schützt das Recht. Dass Carl Schmitt mit so einer Figur wie Donald Trump hätte was anfangen können, das wage ich zu bezweifeln. Er konnte mit Lenin ja durchaus was anfangen, aber nicht mit jemandem, der ja eigentlich so eine große Unerfahrenheit an den Tag legt. Sloterdijks sagt ja auch selbst gegen Ende seines Buches, Unerfahrenheit wird zur Pandemie. Damit meint er ja Trump und andere. Das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was jetzt Schmitte auch sehr kritisch beäugt hätte, aber wie dem auch sei.
Also die Gewöhnlichkeit an der Spitze.
Ja, und das ist ja auch ein Thema, das Hans Jünger dann umtreibt, dass so viel Gewöhnlichkeit da ist, aber trotzdem so viel Macht in deren Händen liegt. Ein Zitat, ein bekanntes, das Heiner Müller aufgegriffen hat, das sich auch übrigens bei Jörg Barbarowski im Buch wiederfindet. Was jetzt ja bei Sloterdijk so bemerkenswert ist, dass er eigentlich ja nicht mit großen Männern hadert, sondern ja durchaus eine Faszination für sie zeigt. Er hadert dann eigentlich mit ihnen, wenn sie über das Ziel hinausschießen oder verrückt werden darüber. Er schreibt ja, man möchte sich ernsthaft die Frage stellen, ob es je zuvor so viele große Männer mit großen Ansprüchen gegeben hat, die bereit sind, um der Machtwillen verrückt zu werden. Das ist eigentlich seine Sorge, die ja berechtigt ist, wie wir deutlich sehen können jetzt gerade beim Blick in die Zeitung. Das ist also das, was er ja auch in dem Sinne nur beschreiben kann, denn daraus ist ja erst mal nichts abzuleiten. Also es ist erst mal, beobachten wir dann doch wieder ein Schauspiel. Und die Frage ist dann, wie kommt man aus der Zuschauerperspektive heraus, damit nicht eine solche Verselbständigung stattfinden kann, dass man also diese großen Männer quasi ihrer Macht enthebt, damit sie nicht weiter um der Macht willen verrückt spielen können oder werden können.
Also das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, zeigt ja so die orientierungslose, einsame Spitzenreiterei. Trump, der aus der Rolle des gewöhnlichen Bürgers hineinfällt als gewöhnlicher Mann in diese Spitzenrolle und der jetzt händeringend versucht, für sich selber erst mal Orientierung zu finden. Soll ich ein Kriegsherr sein, soll ich das sein, wie auch immer so erinnern. Merkt er jedes Mal, dass es irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Und jetzt haben wir ja vorhin schon gesagt, die Ableitung der eigenen Herrlichkeit von Gott, von oben, der ist durchschnitten. Man muss Volkstribuen sein. Und das hat ja Trump immer wieder betont, indem er gesagt hat, wen ich unterstütze, derjenige gewinnt sofort seine Vorwahl. Weshalb das die größte Währung überhaupt ist, für diese republikanischen Kandidaten so ein Endorsement von Trump zu kriegen. Und damit die Aufmerksamkeit. Und jetzt kommt aber in der verwilderte Vertikalität. Also Vertikalität, da kommen wir nicht drum herum, aber dass das so verwildern muss. Das ist ja die große Kritik. Deshalb Sloterdijk dieses Buch schreibt. Und kommt dann auf die letzten Tage großer Herrscher zu sprechen, die sich noch mal von ihrem Volk enttäuscht zeigen. Also Hitler, der sagt, das deutsche Volk war meines nicht würdig.
Ja, Rienzo.
Genau, Rienzo, dasselbe. Wie lautet da der Spruch?
Da heißt es bei Rienzo, Moment, ich muss mal schauen.
Das Volk von Rom war meiner nicht wert, sagt er. Genau. Hitler sagt, die Deutschen hätten einen Führer wie ihn nicht verdient.
Und dieser Rienzo ist ja dann das Vorbild für die Wagner-Opera Rienzi, die die Lieblings-Oper von Hitler war.
Siehste, siehste. Und Trump eben jetzt 2025 bei dem auch noch, ich habe es ja schon angemerkt, dass er sich vom iranischen Volk im Stich gelassen fühlt. Ich habe euch doch den Weg frei gebombt, warum macht ihr keine Revolution und so. Und da würde ich sagen, das geht halt wirklich nur, wenn man übergeschnappt, unaufgeklärt ist und auch weiß, das war jetzt das Ende. Es ist nichts mehr zu retten. Ich säge jetzt meine Legitimationsbasis ab, um für mich selber noch mal darzustellen, es lag nicht an mir.
Ja.
Also das ist sozusagen die finale Übergeschnapptheit abgeleitet aus, ja, wir haben eine politische Vertikalität im Staat, die wir einfach nicht gut füllen können. Entweder machen wir diesen Föllefanz mit Napoleon und Co. Oder wir versuchen das aus dem Volk heraus und dann sind es aber gewöhnliche Leute, die keinen Plan haben. Ja. Und da sind diese Pointen nochmal Stiche.
Kommen wir zum Schluss. Was nimmst du mit? Was müssen wir tun? Können wir was tun? Du sagst ja, wir können doch viel tun.
Also.
Ermächtigung des Einzelnen.
Wir müssen, ja, die Ermächtigung des Einzelnen ist natürlich, ich will mal über, wenn du jetzt zum Schluss sagst, zum Schluss, ganz zum Schluss, die Tele Malignität. Tele heißt fern.
Ja.
Und maligen heißt schlecht. Ja. Also Malaria, die schlechte Luft. Und dieses Kapitel, finde ich, hat so einen Bruch zum Text. Denn er versucht ja hier irgendwie so ein bisschen aktuell zu werden. Und sagt so, okay, was sind eigentlich die wirklichen Mittel der Macht? Und dann verirrt er sich so ein bisschen und redet irgendwas über Waffen. Und macht so eine Ableitung aus. Ja, man wollte ja schon immer zaubern, also aus ganz wenig, ganz viel machen. Und zwar ganz woanders, wo man gar nicht ist. Und dann kam irgendwann die Atombombe und die heißt, ich habe hier so einen ganz kleinen Knopf aus Plastik und plötzlich ist die ganze Stadt weg. Also wenn das keine Magie ist, ganz beeindruckt. Nur hier offenbart sich ganz am Ende des Buches für mich so eine sozio-logische Unaufgeklärtheit des Autoren, der sich aber die ganze Zeit in sozio-logische Fragestellungen einmischt. Nämlich wie halten wir es mit dem Staat, wie halten wir es mit der Geschichte, was kann man wissen, wie organisieren wir jetzt Regierungen und Oppositionen, warum wählen wir einen Kanzler und was bedeutet das, wenn er beim zweiten Wahlgang erst gewählt wird und so. Und das entzaubert leider das ganze Buch so ein bisschen, denn er kommt auf Luhmann zu sprechen und ist, wie so häufig in fast jedem seiner Texte, fasziniert davon, dass Niklas Luhmann sagte, das Rechtssystem ist das Immunsystem der Gesellschaft. Und ich würde sagen, ja, da muss man auch mal die anderen Texte lesen, in denen der Unterschied von Gewalt und Drohmacht beschrieben wird. Was, wie ich finde, der Unterschied ist von, auf der einen Seite haben wir so Tyrannen, Despoten, Napoleon, Papst Alexander, er nennt sie ja alle, die römische Kaiser, Hitler, die ganzen afrikanischen, also sehr riesige Liste. Und er kommt ja nicht darauf zu sprechen, dass es ja demokratische Regierungschefs gab, die man durchaus beipflichten kann. Das sind jetzt keine Napoleons gewesen. Barack Obama, Gerhard Schröder, Helmut Kohl, wer auch immer, Sarkozy. Das sind ja keine übergeschnappten Leute, sondern die haben halt einfach mal regiert und dann wurde sie abgewählt, fertig war's. Und das wird nicht gewürdigt in diesem Buch, ist mir dann am Ende aufgefallen, weil er einfach nur fasziniert von der dunklen Seite ist. Das ist ein bisschen wie Till Lindemann schreibt ein Gedichtbuch über Liebe und die Leute stellen fest, wow, das ist ja eine Grausamkeit, kaum zu überbieten. Ich dachte, das sind Liebesgedichte. So, und so ist das hier auch. Und die gute Seite der Demokratie, eine Geschichte, die hier ungewürdigt bleibt, ist eben, Gewalt nicht anzuwenden, sie aber auch nicht ganz auszuschließen, sondern sie als Drohmacht zu benutzen. Also Gewalt zu benutzen, die sich aber gerade nicht verbraucht, die sich also diesem Faszinosum entzieht, dass eine echte Rakete wohin fliegt und dann alles zerstört, sondern es ist sozusagen das Faszinosum der nicht abgeschossenen Rakete oder wie ich sagen würde, der größten weltgeschichtlichen Errungenschaft, dass man nämlich die Bevölkerung der Welt verdreifachte und die Lebenserwartung verdoppelte in einer Zeit, in der mit der Atomwaffe die ständige und sozusagen plötzliche Ausrottung immer im Raum stand. Das fällt ja zusammen.
Und das möchte ich jetzt anhand eines Beispiels einfach kurz demonstrieren. Wir kennen es alle. Donald Trump zerschießt den halben Iran und sagt, ich habe diesen Krieg gewonnen. Noch niemals ist das iranische Regime so unterwürfig gewesen wie jetzt. Und die Wahrheit ist, sie dürfen im Grunde alles weiter. Jetzt sind sie auch noch Türsteher an der Straße von Humus und dürfen da Zölle kassieren. Und Trump hat schon die Idee, da mitzukassieren und so. Also völlig bescheuert. Sie dürfen ihre Waffenprogramme selber machen. Sie dürfen ihr Uran selber weiter anreichern und so weiter und so fort. Die Amerikaner müssen sogar, wenn es bei diesem 10-Punkte- oder 8-Punkte-Plan bleibt, für Reparation sorgen und so weiter. So, das ist mit Gewalt hergestellt worden. Mit Drohmacht, ohne dass eine Rakete geflogen ist, hat Barack Obama damals an derselben Stelle, amerikanischer Präsident, den Iranern einfach das Atomwaffenprogramm weggenommen. Und er hat weltweit die Experten zusammengezogen, die in diesem Land frei reisen durften, in jedes Gebäude gehen durften, um nachzuschauen, dass da gerade keine Atomwaffen hergestellt werden. So, und das zeigt für mich, es gibt, und zwar jetzt nicht abgeleitet aus so einer großen Nachricht, ich habe noch mal tausend Bücher gelesen und so, sondern ich habe einfach Nachrichten geschaut und habe gesehen, es ist ein gigantischer Unterschied zwischen Gewalt und Drohmacht. Also zwischen Tyrannei und eben dem Gegenentwurf der demokratischen Herrschaft. Und es wird in diesem Buch einfach gar nicht gewürdigt, woran man noch anschließen könnte statt an Napoleon.
Dabei endet er.
Und das ist sehr entzaubernd am Ende dieses Kapitels. Das hätte er sich einfach sparen lassen können. Hätte ich das Buch besser gefunden.
Ja, wo er auch noch mal stärker auf Aufrüstung und alles zu sprechen kommt, möchte das dann auch unbedingt, wenn er dann aber schließt, sich noch mal so versucht, die Kurve zu bekommen im allerletzten Absatz. Wem wundert es, wenn heute die Philosophie, die bis vor kurzem noch meinte, die Geschichte im ganzen Denken und machen zu können, kleinlaut geworden ist? Wollte man ihr für eine Sekunde noch einmal das Wort geben, sie könnte sie nutzen, um leise daran zu erinnern, dass die Intelligenz des Menschen bisher nicht ausreichte, um ein scheinbar banales Wort wie Koexistenz so auszuleuchten, dass Kinder es verstehen und Machtmenschen ihm Raum geben. Plötzlich also da so ein Harmonisierungsversuch der Koexistenz, ihr in die Richtung gehend, die du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast und die dir fehlt. Aber warum führt das dann nicht aus? Warum wird es nur im letzten Absatz nochmal drangeklebt? Weil man dachte, gut, ganz so finster will ich nicht ändern. Enden mit Putin, Xi und Trump und der Atombombe. Sehr eigenartig.
Ja, und so muss man leider sagen, dieses Buch läuft auf die Pointe hinaus. Wir sind einfach zu dumm für die Demokratie und nur ein Idiot kann uns retten. Und dem möchte ich mich nicht anschließen.
Findest du, dass darauf hinausläuft? Ich finde, dass das Buch darauf hinausläuft, dass hier Sloterdijk ein bisschen in die Habermas-Fußstapfen tritt und sagt, also diese...
Das ist noch das Schärfeurteil.
Ja, das würde ihn richtig ärgern, dass ich das sage, wenn er es hören würde. Schade, dass wir so viele unerfahrene Typen jetzt da oben an der Macht haben, wie zum Beispiel Donald Trump oder so sinistre KGBler wie Putin, die verrückt werden an ihrer Macht und dabei die Macht immer weiter ausweiten. Eigentlich wäre es doch gut, wir hätten wieder gewisse Technokraten, die irgendetwas regeln oder große Männer, die die Stärke und Nüchternheit eines Marc Aurel oder wem auch sonst immer etwas haben, von dem etwas haben. Und das ist für mich so eine… Ja, natürlich ist das… Also das ist ein Buch, das sagt, ja, schade sind jetzt gerade die falschen Leute auf der Bühne.
Genau.
Wir brauchen ein neues Casting, aber wir können am Ende aber auch kein Casting uns herstellen, weil ja sowieso mit der Demokratie nicht viel zu machen ist und so weiter. Die Leute sind auch eher blöde. Zumindest sind sie nicht so vernünftig. Naja, dann hoffen wir, dass eine europäische Bürokratie und Technokratie vielleicht auch das eine oder andere noch einhegt.
Aber da könnt ihr erwarten dann auf mein Buch für die Kommunalpolitik, in der ich die Frage stelle, warum kannst du?
Ja, es ist ein recht fatalistisches Buch, so könnte man wohl sagen.
Ja.
Der Fürst und seine Erben heißt das neue Buch von Peter Sloterdijk. Er setzt sich darin mit den sogenannten großen Männern auseinander, mit den großen Männern der Geschichte und der Gegenwart. Er analysiert, zeigt Parallelen. Er schlägt vor allem noch einmal bei Machiavelli nach. Was kann uns dieser 500 Jahre alte Text heute verraten, wenn wir Trump, Putin und die anderen einordnen wollen? Dieses Buch gibt viele Antworten. Es zeigt sich aber auch, dass Sloterdijk sehr fatalistisch auf unsere Gegenwart blickt. Wir haben das zum Anlass genommen, sehr über unsere Gegenwart zu diskutieren. Ein Buch, das man also inspirativ zumindest sehr gut lesen kann.
Ja, und da ihr hier in unserem Metier alle auf dem Trip seid, den Staat gerade schlecht zu finden, dafür ein sehr gutes Buch. Aber wer die Demokratie noch mal retten will, und ich finde, das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so schwer, der findet natürlich bei dem Zynikers Sloterdijk jetzt nicht die richtigen Antworten.
Aber sehr viele böse Wahrheiten. So Stefan, wir sprechen jetzt über Adrian Daub. Er hat ein neues Buch geschrieben, was das Valley Herrschen nennt. Dabei ist interessant, dass der Autor erst einmal mit dem Auto unterwegs ist und dort sieht er lauter Billboards, auf denen merkwürdige kryptische Slogans stehen. Zum Beispiel steht auf einem, Ihr KI Agent braucht eine Workflow-Maschine. Und der Autor fragt sich, was kann das bedeuten? Er fährt weiter und weiter, sieht immer mehr Billboards und merkt, die sind gar nicht mehr an mich gerichtet. Sie sind nicht an mich als Konsument gerichtet, der sagt, ich brauche vielleicht mal noch irgendeine Dating-App oder irgendeine Uber-App, irgendetwas Neues, sondern das sind kryptische Botschaften, offenbar kommunizierender Menschen untereinander durch diese Billboards. Aber ich als Konsument, als normaler Bürger, bin gar nicht mehr gemeint. Wer spricht da eigentlich mit wem? Wir sind also hier in einer Phase, in der das Consumer-Internet immer weniger relevant wird und man eigentlich einen Austausch derer hat, die das Silicon Valley beherrschen. Miteinander, sie sprechen mit Risiko, Kapitalgebern, über diese Billboards, aber natürlich auch anders. Es ist so, dass diese Branche, die Silicon Valley-Branche, ungeheuer dominant geworden ist und das zeigt sich vor allem auch an den Börsenwerten. Die Unternehmen aus dem Silicon Valley hatten 2020 noch einen Anteil von 12 Prozent am Aktienindex S&P 500. Inzwischen, 2025, waren es dann 35 Prozent. Das heißt, die sind machtvoll, aber wie herrschen sie eigentlich? Das ist die Frage, die Adrian Daubs sich stellt.
Hast du dich gut abgeholt gefühlt am Anfang, weil er kommt ja auf die Augen des Dr. T. J. Eccelberg zu sprechen.
Ja.
Aus The Great Gatsby, ein Film von 1925.
Nein, nein, der Roman ist von Gatsby und verfilmt wurde es dann in den 70er-Jahren.
Okay.
Und gibt auch eine Verfilmung mit Leonardo DiCaprio.
Ja. Und in dem Film spielen auch diese großen Plakate als...
Und in dem Roman auch, ja.
Ja. Also, ich kann mir das noch nicht... Du hast es jetzt beschrieben und ich finde es auch irgendwie schlüssig, kann es mir noch nicht so ganz vorstellen, denn schon die Erzählung aus New York, die wir da hören, ist ja immer, das ist für die zehn Prozent der Superreichen, das sind dort hundert Prozent, so. Also, wir haben so eine Dreistaffelung aus Amerika, New York und dann Superreiche in New York. Das heißt, in New York wird Werbung gemacht für die zehn Prozent Amerikas. Nur, wenn ich durch Silicon Valley fahre, und er spitzt es ja zu auf, das sind Werbeplakate für Eigner von Unternehmen im Einhorn-Stadium. Es geht also um 99,99999 Prozent der Leute nicht.
Und die fahren auch selbst nicht Auto, sondern sie werden gefahren und sie sitzen hinten drin und schauen wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal auf diese Billboards. Es spielt gar keine Rolle mehr. Diese Billboards sind vielleicht nur noch eine reine Machtdemonstration.
Ja, also das finde ich, es ist ein sehr drastischer Einstieg. Ja, da werden doch Augen geöffnet.
Ja, denn wir sehen hier diese völlige Entkopplung. Das ist ja das, was ja auch bei der KI-Blase so interessant ist. Man sagt immer, ja, wenn die KI-Blase platzt, dann wird das an der Börse aber. Und wir sehen ja auch, dass eben sehr viele mächtige KI-Unternehmen noch gar nicht an der Börse sind und viele auch gar nicht dorthin wollen, sondern es ist erst mal vollkommen entkoppelt. Das heißt, wir können noch nicht mal partizipieren in Anführungszeichen an dem.
Also nicht an der Börse zu sein und man kann nicht partizipieren, ist ja noch mal eine Unterscheidung neuerdings. Zum anderen kommen die ja bald an die Börse. Aber ich finde es wirklich erstaunlich, weil gerade auch, wenn jetzt das Buch 1925 ist, der Film dann 50 Jahre später und jetzt sind wir noch mal 50 Jahre später. Das heißt ja, das sind echte 100 Jahre. Und sowohl in diesem Buch als auch im Film, als auch jetzt in der Wirklichkeit stehen dort Plakate. Und wir wissen aus der Welt der Atome, dass wir sie nicht einfach duplizieren können. Also sie ist ressourcemäßig sehr beschränkt. Was bedeutet, diejenigen, die so viel Reichtum haben, weil sie virtuelle Welten geschaffen haben, also ein Rechenzentrum mehr und Dario Amodai sagt, das ist wie eine Einwanderung von 40 Millionen Arbeitskräften. Das ist ja rein virtuell. Klar, da geht ein bisschen Raum verloren, weil diese Datensender für sich schon sehr groß sind, aber es ist nicht vergleichbar mit der atomaren Welt. Und für mich liest sich das hier, und deswegen finde ich es auch gut als Einstieg, wie eine wirklich Machtdemonstration zu sagen, nicht nur stellen wir hier unsere Plakate hin, sondern wir nehmen euch auch den Raum für eure profanen Businesses weg. Und das finde ich schon, das ist wie dieses, also gegenteilige Bild dazu, überall nur Obdachlose in derselben Region. Das hat Daub, wahrscheinlich ist er hier zu Recht Literaturwissenschaftler, um uns aus dem Fundus der Möglichkeiten genau das richtige Bild zum Anfang zu servieren.
Das Silicon Valley ist, wo uraltes Geld den Anstrich ewiger Jugend verpasst bekommt. Denn keineswegs wird er uns zeigen, ist dieses Geld so ganz neu, dass sich dort immer weiter vermehrt, sondern eine lange Tradition steht da. Er zeigt uns auch, wie Stanford zu verstehen ist. Wir alle sagen, na ja, das ist diese berühmte Universität. Aber wer waren eigentlich die Stanfords? Das beschreibt er ebenso. Wer uns zeigt, wie dominant diese Macht geworden ist, schon deshalb, weil fünf Prozent der kommerziellen Bauaktivitäten in den USA, derzeit auf Rechenzentren zurückgehen. Das heißt, die breiten sich immer stärker aus. Dabei stellt man fest, man liest ja ein Buch über das Silicon Valley, das aber seine Magie verloren hat. Das Valley ist nicht mehr das Valley der Zehner Jahre. Nicht mehr das, was wir vielleicht auch in den entsprechenden Serien oder Filmen über das Valley gesehen haben, sondern es tut sich da sehr viel, weil nicht mehr Linke und Rechte mit dem Valley was anfangen können, weil alle, so war ja auch die Kritik damals von Evgeny Morozov, sich so einem Solutionismus unterworfen haben und eigentlich auch nur froh sind, dass sie irgendeine App bekommen, mit denen was schneller geliefert wird, mit dem man irgendetwas besser jetzt kommunizieren kann. Sondern man sieht jetzt, die Konzerne wollen bzw. müssen sich politisch verorten und sie tun das, indem sie sich also der Trump-Administration andienen. Daubs schreibt, in den letzten fünf Jahren haben die Unternehmen aufgehört, uns die Welt zu versprechen und geben sich stattdessen damit zufrieden, sie zu dominieren. Das Überzeugungsvermögen ist verbraucht, das Vermögen ist geblieben.
Vielleicht kann man den Bogenschlag so, also ich habe ihn so herausgelesen. Am Anfang, deswegen diese Zeit von Yevgeny Morozov, vor zehn Jahren ungefähr. Er hat in der FAZ ja damals auch immer bei uns geschrieben. Und es war im Grunde klar, sie führen uns in die Irre mit Versprechungen, die sie gar nicht halten können. Aber rückblickend heute können wir sagen, es waren einfach Versprechen. Ja. Man musste dann selber überlegen, ob man das jetzt überzeugend findet oder nicht. Aber es war sozusagen ein kognitives Angebot.
Das selbstfahrende Auto in einem Jahr. Zum Beispiel. Sie werden mehr Freunde denn je finden durch Facebook. Genau. Sie werden die große Liebe finden und erfüllten Sex. Hier ist die nächste App.
Und jetzt macht Daub diese interessante Kritik zu sagen, jetzt kommen sie über Bande. Weil die Überzeugung ging nicht auf. Die Versprechen liefen alle ins Leere. Also sie haben uns Flugtaxis versprochen und wir haben 140 Zeichen bekommen und so, dieser berühmte Satz. Und was sie jetzt machen ist, sie mobilisieren das Normative. Also sie werden vorstellig im Weißen Haus und sagen, ab jetzt nur noch unsere Raketen. Wir kommen gar nicht drumherum. Also ob uns Elon Musk jetzt überzeugt oder nicht, das Internet für das Pentagon kommt halt von einem Starlink-Satelliten, durch eine Starlink-Rakete hochgeschossen. Und so selbst dort, wo es eigentlich gar nicht materiell zugeht, bei Mark Zuckerberg, der stellt zwar mittlerweile so eine Brille her und so, aber die Zugkraft und die Marktschließung läuft nicht mehr darüber, dass wir uns bei Instagram oder wo auch immer wohlfühlen, sondern dass es keine Alternative gibt. TikTok wird politisch aus dem Markt geschossen, dann wird die Section 230 abgewürgt, weil man sie jetzt nicht mehr braucht. Dadurch keinen Nachwuchs durch kleinere Apps, die sich das gar nicht erlauben können, diese Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Für die handeln ihre User.
Man entledigt sich der Konkurrenz durch eine Verbindung, die man zum Start eingeht, während man sich vorher staatskritisch gegeben hat. Tut das natürlich als Pose noch immer, aber sagt jetzt, wir arbeiten eng zusammen. Wir sind nicht in der Lage, eine Konkurrenz-App zu TikTok zu entwickeln, sodass TikTok einfach den Gang geht, den man in einer Marktwirtschaft auch gehen kann. Nämlich, man hat nicht mehr genügend Nachfrage und geht dann vielleicht pleite, sondern man sagt, TikTok ist wahnsinnig erfolgreich. Bitte helft uns, dass TikTok nicht mehr bei Dens gehört. Also tut mal irgendetwas dafür. So kann man auch dann auf diesen Plakaten sehen, wie Adrian Daubs das Treffen formuliert. Dass sie abbilden, wie Geld mit Geld verkehrt. Und nicht mehr, dass diese Plakate abbilden, hier ist das Produkt, möchtest du es haben, hier haben wir noch eine Info für dich. Was das Valley Herrschen nennt, können wir nicht verstehen, ohne die einfache Wahrheit mitzudenken, dass seine Granten letztlich kein Interesse daran haben, uns zu regieren. Was Silicon Valley als Regierung bezeichnet, ist bloße Kontrolle, losgelöst von und desinteressiert an der menschlichen Natur und dem normalen Leben, selbst wenn es um das normale Leben mit Technologie und Internet geht. Was das Valley Herrschen nennt, ist fixiert auf Privilegien und Hierarchien und ist bei allem intellektuellen Anspruch verführbar durch Ideologien, die diese Privilegien und Hierarchien stützen. So die Grundthese, die Adrian Daub dann in seinem Buch weiterverfolgt. Was Adrian Daub ja hier tut, ist so bemerkenswert, weil er eigentlich eine fejotonistische Herangehensweise hat. Er hat nicht diese Stringenz vielleicht wie das in dem vorherigen Buch da ist, sondern er pickt sich Dinge heraus, aber verknüpft sie dann mit dem großen Ganzen. Wir sind ja in unserem alltäglichen Nachrichtenfluss eigentlich daran gewöhnt, zu sagen, da hat Elon Musk wieder irgendwas bescheuertes getwittert, jetzt geht es aber wirklich zu weit. Vielleicht sagt man das noch und dann kommt aber schon der nächste Tweet. Hier geht Adrian Daub nochmal zurück zu einem Tweet aus dem Jahr 2018 und verbindet das mit einer ganzen Weltanschauung, die dem Muskschen Regieren bzw. Dominieren zugrunde liegt. Um davon wieder ableiten zu sagen, so funktioniert das Silicon Valley. Es interessiert sich nicht für das normale Leben. Und wer sich für das normale Leben nicht interessiert, wer eine App lange baut, die am Ende so aussieht, dass dabei entweder irgendeine Röhre im Untergrund vorkommt, mit der man sich drei Kilometer bewegen kann zu einer unglaublich langsamen Geschwindigkeit und hat einfach Millionen verbraten, wer eine App entwickelt, die im Prinzip das ist, was man Busverkehr nennt, der ist vielleicht auch sonst am Leben nicht interessiert. Oder wenn er dann das normale Leben bestimmen kann, mit einem Doge Ministerium, wird dies dazu führen, dass das kurz und klein geschlagen wird, was absolute Bedingungen als notwendige Bedingungen gesehen werden kann für ein gelingendes normales Leben. Und das, finde ich, ist die große Stärke dieses Buches, dass er von dem Kleinen immer wieder aufs Große Ganze gehen kann und das nicht nur additiv uns aneinanderreit, wie verrückt alles geworden ist, sondern ja, Wahnsinn ist es, aber es hat doch auch Methode.
Genau, bei der Frage, was hat zum Beispiel Elon Musk uns versprochen? Also ja, Hyperloop und so. Einfach weil er selber zu viel im Stau steckte. Was er geliefert hat, ist ja, also er wird hier selbst als Furie der Zerstörung beschrieben, der über die Macht erringen und die er dann hat, mit dem Wegdoschen von Health Aid für hunderttausende Tote sorgt und so. Also er hat im Grunde er ist superreich geworden, damit er einfach die Welt auseinander baut. Zerstört geradezu. Und ich komme immer wieder auf den Creep, jetzt schon zu sprechen, aber das ist ein creephaftes Verhalten, das gleich schön entfaltet wird. Und damit aber die Kritik in die richtige Richtung läuft, ist Adrian Daub sehr wichtig, gleich zu sagen, es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass Elon Musk uns mehr hätte versprechen sollen oder nicht nur Twitter gekauft hätte, sondern und so. Und er kommt dann gleich auf, Alex Karp zu sprechen und zwar genauso scharf wie wir. Gerade auf die technologische Republik, die er da ausgerufen hat. Die Kritik kennen wir ja, zu viel Schnickschnack für die Konsumenten. Wo sind meine Atomwaffen, mit denen ich selbst Lothardyck ist begeistert davon, oder er fürchtet, auf der anderen Seite der Welt einfach Zerstörung herstellen kann. Durch ein Fingerschnipsen. Wo ist die Magie? Wo ist die Technologie? Und dagegen verwahrt man sich hier, wir ja auch. Es ist sozusagen noch ein unbestelltes Feld, jetzt Elon Musk und Co. mal richtig zu kritisieren. Ja. Und das wird in diesem Buch gemacht.
Ja. Er ist ja Literaturwissenschaftler in Stanford. Das heißt, er kennt diese Situation, in der sich die jungen Leute, die da die Welt aus den Angeln heben wollen, sehr gut. Er fragt sich überhaupt erst mal, was ist denn diese Uni Stanford? Zunächst einmal ist es als ein steuerbefreiter Investmentfonds zu sehen. Stanford ist so, dass das ja gegründet wurde von der Familie Stanford. Die verdiente ihr Geld mit transnationalen Eisenbahnen, die gebaut wurden. Sie hatten einen Sohn, Leland Stanford Junior, der starb mit 17 Jahren. Er ist wohl auch dort auf dem Gelände beerdigt oder hatte eine Kruft. Das ist noch immer da zu sehen. Und lange Zeit aber dümpelte alles so vor sich hin. Dann im Zuge des Zweiten Weltkrieges, als aufgerüstet wurde, war dann dieses Valley auch wichtig. Aber als der Weltkrieg endete, ließen natürlich auch die staatlichen Investitionen nach. Weshalb die Aussicht darauf bestand, dass quasi die Provinzialisierung wieder zunehmen könnte. Dann gibt es einen Unipräsidenten Fred Thurman, der nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg Technologiefirmen dort bewusst ansiedelt. Daubs schreibt, aus Landreichtum wurden Firmenanteile und Mieteinnahmen und aus diesen ein Stiftungskapital von über 30 Milliarden Dollar. Das ist das Fundament, auf dem das alles entsteht. Weiter heißt es, die aus dieser Kaderschmiede hervorgegangenen Unternehmensgenerationen treten gerne als Neureich auf. In manchen Fällen sind sie das biografisch gesehen auch tatsächlich. Aber das Geld, das ihre kühnen und unüberlegten Gedankenplätze auf so mysteriöse Weise findet, es ist alt. Es kommt von saudischen Prinzen und japanischen Banken. Es kommt von Family Offices, die den Immobilienreichtum oder die Aktienpakete amerikanischer Dynastien verwalten. Es kommt aus dem Stiftungskapital der von Amerikas Kleptokraten ins Leben gerufenen Universitäten. Es kommt von den Freunden und Familien, von denen jedes Start-up zuerst Geld einsammelt.
Silicon Valley ist, wo uraltes Geld den Anstrich ewiger Jugend verpasst bekommt. Eine namentliche Pointe müssen wir machen. Diesen Namen erwähnt er. Ich kannte ihn auch nicht. Niemand kennt ihn. Also man läuft über den Campus und da steht natürlich ein imposanter Komplex von Jerry Yang, gesponsert, die Bill & Belinda Gates Stiftung hat dafür bezahlt. Hewlett und Packard. Zwei Gebäude, die sich natürlich gegenüberstehen. Und dann gibt es das Arrilaga Family Sports Center, Outdoor Education und Recreation Center, Center for Sports and Recreation, das Alumni Center, der White Room, das Tennis Center und so weiter. Und super interessant, hier geht es nicht um einen Tech-Gründer, sondern diese Arrilaga-Familie hat einfach, bevor diese Konzerne da angesiedelt wurden, dieses ganze Land besessen. Wir haben es also mit sehr analogen Geld zu tun.
Und die haben Bürogebäude hochgezogen.
Genau, die sind die Landlords des Silicon Valley quasi. Und das ist das zweite Mal, dass wir so eine Brückenschlag-Poante aus der Welt von Bits und Bytes in Atome haben, die reglementiert ist einfach durch Menge und wir hier so eine große Einmischung. Also die Aufmerksamkeit auf der Straße ist Silicon Valley dominiert, aber ganz physisch. Stanford ist ein ganz physischer Ort und Leute sind superreich geworden und haben dort alles bezahlt, weil sie dieses Land verkauft haben. Plus grundsätzlich geht es hier um altes Geld statt Jungbrunnentechnologie, die wie sie auch immer vermarktet wird. Das wissen wir ja alle eben anders funktioniert, als wir immer glauben.
Altes Geld, das aber sagt, wir investieren in diese windigen Unternehmungen. Wir verstehen es selbst nicht so richtig. Und eigentlich sagt Daub, würde man mal die Kriterien von Investoren, Politikern oder so an den Tag legen. Bei diesen jungen Unternehmen würde man sagen, das sind ja alles völlig unprofitable Firmen und sie werden es auch bleiben. Aber dieses alte Geld, das legt diese Kriterien an die Firmen gar nicht an, weil irgendwas anders ist. Deswegen müssen wir sie auch anders behandeln. Und die Politiker haben jahrelang auch gesagt, ja ja, grundsätzlich dürfte das eigentlich ein Unternehmen nicht tun und dürften die nicht recht brechen. Aber die sind so neu, so anders. Deswegen können wir da gar nicht mit unseren Kriterien ran. Also als sei dies zwar ein Unternehmen im Kapitalismus, aber eigentlich ist es ein ganz anderes Unternehmen. Und eigentlich ist der Silicon Valley auch ein ganz anderer Kapitalismus. Irgendwann aber, sagt dann Daub, entpuppten sich diese Unternehmen als Unternehmen. Und deren CEOs als CEOs.
Ja, also Apple feiert jetzt 50-jähriges, Google fast 30-jähriges, Facebook 22-jähriges. Und es ist aber jetzt KI und deswegen ist alles neu. Und man darf auf gar keinen Fall da rein regieren, weil und so weiter.
Ja, jetzt geht es wieder von neuem los. Man hat das gerade wieder so ein bisschen verfestigt. Elizabeth Warren hat sie mal an die Kandare nehmen wollen. Davon haben sie sich eigentlich nie mehr erholt von diesem Schock. Das wird ja auch mehrmals gesagt, wie sehr Elizabeth Warren eigentlich dem Silicon Valley Angst gemacht hat und wie dann diese Rache gelöst zu stark werden. Und damit hat er auch eine sehr gute Charakterisierung vorgenommen für diesen Begriff Disruption. Denn Disruption wirkt immer so, naja, das sind jetzt die Neuerungen, die so über einen rollen. Und wer dann nicht stark genug ist, naja, der muss gehen. Disruption, sagt Adrian Daub, also das ist der Begriff, den ja da alle im Munde führen, ist ein amoralischer und ein hypermoralistischer Begriff. Amoralisch erstmal, weil man sagt, naja, bist du dann nicht stark genug und gibt es da irgendwas besseres, dann ist das so. Zugleich steckt aber was hypermoralistisches darin, nämlich offenbar bist du ja nicht stark genug. Was hast du dann gemacht? Warum bist du so schwach? Das heißt, diese Verbindung sorgt auch dafür, dass die Disruptoren, also die Silicon Valley-Unternehmer, sich als moralisch überlegen dann doch vorkommen, weil sie sagen, naja, ihr seid offenbar schwache Charaktere.
Ja, also wir haben hier auch wieder die Persönlichkeitsstörungen, die wir Rotkar Breschmann immer, also aus der Fragestellung ableiten, die wir gerade bei Sloterdijkschen aufgeklärt haben, mit es gibt eine Fernethik und dann halt eine Moral der nahen Lebenswelt. Ja. Und so ist das hier auch, denn das Amoralische betrifft diese nahe Lebenswelt. Also man begegnet jemanden direkt im Gespräch und sagt ihm dann, äh, sorry, aber du leistest nicht genug. Also wir müssen dich jetzt leider disruptieren. Das ist ein Naturgesetz. Aber es ist ja für das höhere Gut, also Long-Term-Missen, das Hyperreale. Es ist für uns alle irgendwann einmal, er spitzt es ja dann später in der Erörterung des Long-Term-Missen zu mit, warum um die Jetztzeit kümmern, wenn doch die Erde im Jahr 7,5 Milliarden nach Jesus Christus Probleme hat.
Ja, ja. Was mir sehr gut gefallen hat, dass er Phänomene, die ich kenne, aber nie bedacht habe, hier auf den Punkt bringt und lang analysiert. Ich habe mich tatsächlich immer gewundert, aber das nie artikuliert, sondern immer so im stillen Verwunderungen gespürt. Ich habe mich immer gewundert, warum VCs, also Venture Capitalists, Menschen, die sehr viel Geld haben und auch erfolgreich sind, sich jeden Tag bei Twitter herumtreiben, irgendein Shitposting betreiben, sich gegenseitig angreifen, mit irgendwelchen kleinen Usern sich plötzlich abgeben und hakeln. Leute, die kein echtes Profilbild haben, denke ich, warum tut ihr das? Das kennt man doch sonst nur vielleicht aus dem Kindergarten. Was ist da los? Und er beschreibt dann auch, wie die sich dann in absurde Thesen hineinversetzen, also die ganze Drogenkrise. Es kommt alles nur durch China und das ist die große Idee von China, alles zu unterwandern und dann irgendwas. Und das Twittern, die will hin und her. Und jeder bringt noch einen eskalierenderen Tweet. Daubs schreibt, warum bleiben diese VCs nicht einfach weg, also weg von Twitter? Selbst eine Lösung auf Twitter gehörte sozusagen zum Geschäftsmodell, vermittels rechtslastige Hot Takes und eingeschnappte Reaktionen. Wenn die Twitter-Meute über sie herfiel, schafften diese Männer eine Art Gemeinschaft. Das bedeutete, man erhielt und behielt Zugang zu diesem Soziotop vor allem, indem man sich von ganz normalen Userinnen zur Sau machen ließ. Was dann für ihn bedeutet, und da sind wir wieder ganz dicht, weil Sloterdijks also ein neuer Herrscher-Typus. Dadurch, dass er sich dem Spott der Masse aussetzt, wird der nackte VC erst zum Kaiser. Nämlich sie signalisieren, wir machen hier die Hot Takes und ich lasse mich hier von dir beleidigen und so weiter. Aber wir sind die eigentlich Tonangebenden und wir machen hier richtig Dampf. Dadurch werden wir zu Kaisern, dass wir uns in dieser Weise aufführen, obwohl wir das ganze Geld oder gerade weil wir das ganze Geld im Rücken haben. Also ein völlig anderer Typus als das, was man jetzt aus den Herrscherdynastien kennen würde, die sagen, wir sind da zurückhaltend. Vor allem werden wir uns nicht direkt mit dem Volk irgendwie in eine Kommunikation hineinversetzen, wo wir auf Tweets antworten.
Also das Argument, ich habe es auch gelesen, ist immer noch ein bisschen schwierig zu begreifen. Anscheinend scheint es ja da auch so eine, es gibt keine schlechte Aufmerksamkeitssache mit zu schwingen. So dass man eine Resonanz erfährt, allein durch, ah, Edelmars hat auf mich reagiert. Also und dann zündet man da so ein Netzwerk an irgendwie.
Wenn diese Leute ja der Auffassung sind, dass die normalen eh minderwertig sind, dass die einfach nicht gut genug sind und deswegen auch disruptiert gehören und deshalb auch keine Arbeitsrechte haben sollten und so weiter. Dann passt es ja eigentlich zusammen, dass man auf die Plattform derer geht, wo alle, also der Plattform der normalen Leute geht, nämlich Twitter, das war ja noch bevor Elon Musk Kauf stattgefunden hat. Und dann verbündet man sich dort mit den anderen VCs gegen diese, gegen dieses dumme Volk da. Ich schreibe irgendwelche rassistische Scheiße da rein, aber weil wir die Tech-Elite genau so miteinander kommuniziert und weil wir in Wahrheit auch daran glauben, dass das so ist, können uns die anderen mit ihrem Spott gar nichts mehr anhaben. Wir schaffen da, wie dann Daubs schreibt, so ein Soziotop. Das heißt, man stellt eine Verbindung unter VCs dadurch her, dass man sagt, wir können Hot Takes, das was die Masse nicht will, was sie kritisiert, das macht uns erst zu den wahren Fürsten.
Ja, also er hat ja eine explizite die These des Buches Abschnitt, in dem es für mich auch so ein bisschen unklar bleibt, wie er das meint, dass wir eine andere Beziehung zum Silicon Valley haben, was dort wiedergespiegelt wird. Also Beziehung scheint so ein großes Thema zu sein. Ist aber nicht ganz der Blick des Beherrschten auf das Silicon Valley und so.
Hm, naja, was doch deutlich wird, wenn wir jetzt mal auf das Kapitel zu den Vibes kommen, ist ja, dass er sagt, und das leuchtet mir total ein, wenn man sich Elon Musk ansieht, aber auch andere. Die Schöpfer unserer Filterblasen sitzen längst in der Mutter aller Filterblasen. Das heißt, unsere Kritik war ja immer an den Filterblasen, naja, das bringt die Leute dazu, dass sie nur noch ihren eigenen Bubbles folgen und kein anderes Argument mehr gelten lassen. Interessanterweise haben die ja Maschinen produziert, wo sie selbst jetzt zu den allerersten Opfern werden. Jetzt hat der Algorithmus Elon Musk so oft irgendwelche edgy Vogue-Tweets angezeigt, dass er dann irgendwann davon ausgeht, ja, die ganze Welt ist vom Vogue-Mind-Virus befallen. Ich muss jetzt irgendwas dagegen tun. Wie man auch bei Influencern häufig erlebt hat, dass die eigentlich zu den größten Opfern ihrer eigenen Konsumfreude, die sie eigentlich als Job da an den Tag legen mussten, geworden sind. Und eigentlich genauso erbärmlich dann leben mussten, wie die User, die sie laufend verspielen.
Ja, also das verstehe ich wieder. Und da gibt es ja unten auch einen Textabschnitt. Die Währung unserer Gegenwart heißt Aufmerksamkeit. Das ist ja sozusagen, was wir von dem Silicon Valley verdanken, sie zu binden und zu lenken, deswegen wahrscheinlich das einmischen, ist in der Tat eine wichtige Form von Macht. Aber man muss sich klar machen, dass die Reichen und insbesondere die von Silicon Valley, dabei sind sämtliche US-Medien mit größerer Reichweite zu übernehmen und offen zu beeinflussen. Und wir regen uns darüber auf, dass Menschen auf Social Media falsch streiten. Also unter dieser Pointe ist mir das natürlich alles dann sehr schlüssig. Und da finde ich es auch sehr wichtig.
Während die Silicon Valley-Elite im großen Selbstgespräch mit sich ist, Paul Graham schreibt den Essay How to Think Yourself. Da heißt es, wenn man von konventionell denkenden Menschen umgeben ist, schränkt das die Möglichkeit, in einen Ideen auszudrücken. Und gibt man sich jedoch mit unabhängig denkenden Menschen, wird man das Gegenteil erleben. Überraschende Aussagen anderer werden einen dazu ermutigen, sich neue Gedanken zu machen. Klingt erst mal so intuitiv, hat was für sich. Daub fügt an, am Ende des Essays dankt Graham, dem breiten Gremium unabhängiger Denker, mit denen er sich umgeben hat. Sechs der sieben sind Männer zwischen 40 und 45 Jahren. Fünf der sieben arbeiten bei Y Combinator, einem Business-Inkubator in Palo Alto, mitgegründet von keinem geringeren als Paul Graham. Einer ist der CEO des Bezahldienstes Stripe. Der siebte ist Peter Thiel.
Ja, also da schließt sich natürlich der Kreis. Und das ist ja schon mitten im Vibe-Kapitel, das ich sehr gut finde.
Ja.
Also, das Welle verwechselt sich selbst mit der Welt. Das ist eine richtige Diagnose. Die entfaltet werden muss, weil sie ja etwas bedeutet. Grundsätzlich kennen wir das Phänomen aber überall, wo Leute vor Publikum arbeiten, sag ich mal grob. Also in der FAZ hatte man damals, und es ist wahrscheinlich heute immer noch so, dass man irgendeinen großen Aufmacher schreibt, durchaus mit exklusivem Inhalt. Und dann dachte man, man sei selber für die ganzen Nachdreher verantwortlich. Also wenn wir jetzt nicht den dritten Nachdreher auf unseren tollen Text von gestern schreiben, indem wir den Leuten noch mal sagen, dass Wasser nass ist, weiß das niemand in Deutschland. Also müssen wir das da reinschreiben. Und so gestaltet man natürlich eine Redaktionsinformation, die man dann immer gleich verwechselt als, also solange nur auf meinem Computer steht, dass Wasser nass ist und ich noch nicht Publish gedrückt habe, ist Wasser trocken für die Leute. So, und genau in dieser albernen, aber extremen Entgrenztheit gilt das, also überall irgendwie. Und erst recht natürlich, wenn man dann noch 40 Prozent des amerikanischen Aktienmarkts dominiert über die eigene Wertschöpfung, die man da abbildet mit solchen Wahrheiten wie Wasser ist nass. Und das wird hier in diesem Kapitel doch recht driftig. Und ich finde eben notwendig, mal aufgearbeitet. Denn es hat zehn Jahre gedauert, bis Marietas Lombarder mal bei der Republika da saß und so reflektierte. Ja, wir haben immer gedacht, wenn unter so einem Tweet 100 Antworten stehen, ist das der relevanteste Tweet der Welt. Und dann mussten wir feststellen, ach so, im Internet gibt es Diskussionen und dann gibt es die richtige Welt. Und ich finde, das kommt heute schon immer noch nicht so richtig. Also richtig veränderlicht haben sie es nicht, aber im Silicon Valley erst recht nicht. Also das Silicon Valley meint, schreibt er, in der Welt habe sich der Wind gedreht, weil sich in Teilen Silicon Valleys die Stimmung gedreht hat und weil Silicon Valley seit längerem nicht mehr so recht unterscheiden kann zwischen sich selbst und der Welt. Ihm ist, als ob es 1000 Launches gäbe und hinter 1000 Launches keine neue Welt. So, okay, also da muss man dann doch den Vibeshift direkt dazu nehmen, aber wir können es jetzt wieder auf ein mir beliebtes Thema zurückmünzen, nämlich Alterungsphänomene, die er direkt schreibt. Denn der Vibeshift, du hast es ja eben an Paul Graham vorgemacht, wird gedacht von Leuten, die selber schon seit 20 Jahren da drin hängen und glauben, wir sind die Welt, wir bestimmen die Plattform. Du hast beschrieben, wie sich alle dort einmischen. Also mischt man sich ein, hängt dann da in so einem Diskurs fest und sagt, das ist der Vibe, der hier gerade gilt. Aber, und das ist eben, würde ich sagen, in der Kunst und sowieso ein prägendes Phänomen, die Leute machen ihre große Innovation, bevor sie 25 sind. Und dann sind sie irgendwann 50, kriegen immer noch Tantiem. Und irgendwann findet man sich damit ab, dass man immer noch im Bett im Kornfeld singt. Aber hier hat man es ja nicht mit solchen Artefakten zu tun, sondern die sind halt einfach Chefs von Unternehmen, treffen immer noch Entscheidungen. Das ganze Unternehmen ist schon so, der Chef hat wieder gesagt, wir sollen heute blau färben, aber dabei und so. Und dann gibt es hier Diskrepanzen.
Und diese Diskrepanzen sorgen dann dafür, dass so eine Paranoia entsteht, dass sie unbedingt den Vibe verändern müssen, um endlich wieder eine Freiheit herzustellen, die natürlich nur ihre Freiheit meint. Und etwas wird wahrgenommen in der Gesellschaft, was aber gar nicht in der Gesellschaft ist, sondern was sie vor allem von den Plattformen haben, die sie geschaffen haben. Das heißt, was dort als Problem für die Welt erscheint, ist eines, das sie herstellen, dass sie dann innerhalb der Plattformen versuchen, auch wieder zu bekämpfen, indem sie dann jetzt sagen, wir haben ab sofort keine Voken-Inhalte mehr oder so etwas.
Also 2004 haben drei junge Männer eine gute Idee für eine Technologie. Die ist heute 500 Milliarden wert. Die alle sind jetzt so fast 50 und stellen fest, irgendwer behauptet, junge Frauen hätten auch gute Ideen.
Ja.
Und plötzlich sind sie in dieser Midlife-Crisis.
Ja, weil sie das nicht aushalten können. Und dann sagen sie, wir müssen jetzt mal wieder über Exzellenz sprechen. Leistung muss das entscheidende Kriterium sein.
Genau.
Was sie die ganze Zeit suggerieren ist, dass alle, die nicht männlich sind und nicht eigentlich zu ihrer Alterskohorte gehören und alle, die nicht weiß sind, sind aus irgendwelchen linksliberalen Diversity-Programmen dort in diese Positionen geschafft worden. Das gilt es jetzt rückgängig zu machen, weshalb dann auch Mark Zuckerberg bei Joe Rogan sagt, wir brauchen wieder mehr männliche Energie. Und man sagen kann, na ja, aber bis auf Sheryl Sandberg, war ja fast nur männliche Energie überall gewesen.
Und sie hatte auch sehr männliche Energie.
Ja, und da wird jetzt so getan, als sei das also der Punkt, an dem endlich die Leistung wieder zurückkehrt, weil für diese Männer doch nur die Leistung der eigenen Klasse als Leistung anerkannt werden kann. Und das eben diese Tech-Bros. Und ich finde, wenn man es nochmal hier so ganz arg klein dargestellt bekommt mit den Aussagen, die da getroffen werden, von diesen Protagonisten und so, dann muss man sagen, es ist leider auch so dumm, wie es dumm ist. Also das ist ja auch das Erschütternde, was man hier nochmal in dem Buch nachvollziehen kann. Man denkt natürlich so, naja, also diese Art der männlichen Herrschaft, diese Art des Sexismus und des Rassismus, das ist jetzt so simpel, dass man sagen würde, das kann es doch nicht sein. Aber wenn man es dann wirklich nochmal gründlich aufarbeitet, wie Adrian Daub das tut, dann kommt das leider darauf hinaus, und man tut dem Stammtisch unrecht, wenn man sagt, das ist ja wie Stammtisch geschwätzt, zum Silicon Valley. Es ist definitiv schlimmer.
Ja, also dadurch, dass dem Silicon Valley jetzt das herrscht und das Stichwort lautet Doge und andere, so trifftig ist, würde ich sagen, hätte Peter Sloterdijk die politische Sphäre verlassen und die andere Vertikalität gesucht, nämlich jemand baut Plattformen, programmiert Plattformen und programmiert damit auch User. Das ist ja auch eine Vertikalität, für die man sich interessiert. Und wäre dann auf das Diktum, abgeleitet von Hannah Arendt, die Banalität des Großen gekommen, um daraus den Grundbegriff das Absurde abzuleiten, dann wäre das ein Volltreffer gewesen. Vielleicht sollte man das sogar jetzt nochmal machen. Vielleicht baue ich nochmal den Text genau so um die Ecke, dass man Daub und Sloterdijk, dass man die Ableitung des neuen Napoleons, gerade auch weil ja Politiker vor allem über Medien regieren und sei es um eine Vorbereitung auf die Beschlusslage ist, wir kürzen jetzt das Bürgergeld, weil wir dann 30 Milliarden sparen und es stimmt gar nicht, aber die Sehgewohnheit sagt, wir haben das jetzt ein halbes Jahr diskutiert, wir können da nicht zurück, wir müssen das jetzt beschließen. Da sind wir ja eigentlich bei der Absurdität und der Banalität des Großen hier viel näher. Gerade wenn gilt, was Adrian Daubsch schreibt und was, finde ich, immer stimmt, 50-jährige Männer sind immer ganz normale Männer. Bei 25-Jährigen stimmt es nicht, also Harry Styles ist eine Ausnahmefigur, aber der 50-jährige Harry Styles wird ein ganz normaler Bühnenperformer sein, wie es die schon Jahrhunderte gab und noch Jahrhunderte geben wird. So und das kann man hier für die Silicon-Welle-Leute auch einfach sagen.
Ja, sie haben nur mehr Geld.
Das sind CEOs von Banken, die unter sich eine Hierarchie aufspannen, von denen immer wieder gesagt werden muss, ja, man muss das so ganz clever departmentalisieren, damit überhaupt noch jemand mal eine Entscheidung treffen kann und nicht nur Beschlussvorlagen nach oben reicht, die dann drei Monate später von Mark Zuckerberg abgezeichnet wieder zurückgewiesen werden oder runtergereicht werden.
Kommen wir zu dem Kapitel Dominanz. Da heißt es, es ist doch ganz erstaunlich, wie sich die Mächtigen aufführen beziehungsweise wie sie sich verkaufen. Da ist die Rede von Scott Bessent.
Ja, na warte, bevor wir den Datus jetzt so einleitet, die sind seltsam und die Seltsamkeit können wir, ist die Frage, ob es zu tagespolitisch ist, obwohl es schon wieder eine Weile her ist, aber das Corona, der Corona-Anschnitt, also eine Kränkung, in dem man Menschen, die sich schon viel außergewöhnlich halten, noch mal sagt, aber jetzt sitzen wir alle in einem Boot. Das Virus erreicht auch dich. Wir müssen jetzt auch deine Firma schließen. Aber ich habe doch eine Ausnahmefirma.
Ja.
Und bei mir gilt trotzdem die Biologie und die Politik so, ja bei dir auch.
Und Daub, überlegt er sogar, wie wäre es gewesen, wenn Musk seine Firma woanders hätte angesiedelt gehabt, in einem Bundesstaat, wo man vielleicht nicht so strenge Corona-Regeln gehabt hätte, dann wäre möglicherweise diese Art der Radikalisierung gar nicht so schnell fortgeschritten, weil hier jetzt in Kalifornien mussten sie sich so sehr dem Staat unterwerfen, dass das ihre Feindschaft zum Staat noch einmal in ganz erheblichem Maße bescheunigt hat und intensiviert hat. Wie man das ja auch bei Ulf Posch hat im Übrigen sehr gut nachsehen kann, der ja hier auch einmal erwähnt wird in diesem Buch.
Ja?
Oh ja, ich gucke, ob ich das noch finde.
Also wir haben die Gleichmachung durch Corona-Maßnahmen, die als Zumutung und Unrecht angesehen wird. Und natürlich sind die Corona-Maßnahmen dann alle dumm gewesen. Man ist besessen von der Dummheit, möchte darauf reagieren, erzählt dann aber auf, also Elon Musk hat irgendwelche Beatmungsgeräte versprochen. Die haben natürlich nur gegen Schlafabnöhe geholfen. Und damit konnte man jetzt nicht in die Lunge intubieren. Und irgendwelche Leute wollten mit 3D-Druckern, Ventilatoren und Masken, ob es die je gegeben hat, weiß man nicht. Große Ideen kamen auf, wie wenn das noch einen weiteren Monat Lockdown gibt, dann ist der Bitcoin überall. Ging auch nicht so richtig auf. Und man fühlt sich doch sehr gekränkt. Und deswegen jetzt aus Herrschen die Frage, ist das jetzt noch Politik? Nein, es ist einfach Dominanz. Und zwar Dominanz, finde ich, macht es sehr schlüssig, indem man sagt, gerade weil die sich überhaupt nicht für Inhalte interessieren, ist es reines Dominieren.
Ja, und da bringt er dieses Beispiel von Scott Bessent. Der ist bei CNBC. Da geht es um die Federal Reserve. Er gilt ja als der neue Chef der FED.
Nee, Bessent ist der Finanzminister.
Ist der Finanzminister, sorry. Und er sitzt dort und redet über die FED und sagt dann, all die Doktortitel da drüben und ich haben keine Ahnung, was die überhaupt machen. Es ist so eine Art bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen für akademische Ökonomen. Das ist also seine Haltung dazu. Jetzt sagt er, ob Dreierlei ist bezeichnet. Zunächst einmal die Vorstellung, dass Bessent sein Unverständnis zum Fehler dessen umdeutete, was er nicht verstand. Das ist der Kardinalfehler von Masks disruptionsfetisch, nur, dass Bessent eben nicht eine Rakete in die Luft zu sprengen drohte, sondern das weltweite Finanzsystem. Zweitens ist die Tatsache bezeichnet, dass Bessens Aussage weiterhin als Bewerbungsschreiben um den Posten des FED-Chefs angesehen wurde. Seine Aussage, er verstehe die FED nicht, sollte seine Chance erhöhen, zu ihrem Leiter ernannt zu werden. Dies ist die politische Theologie des Zeitalters der Disruption. Ignoranz ist Unbeflecktheit. Fachwissen ist Sünde. Eine fatale Kontamination mit der Materie. Und drittens ist Scott Bessent seit Jahren als Finanzmanager in Währungsfragen tätig. Natürlich weiß er, was die Ökonomen bei der Zentralbank treiben. Er ist kein Idiot, aber er spielt einen für seinen Chef. Für Donald Trump.
Also hier steckt viel drin. Es fällt der Begriff der Necropolitik. Das ist diese Idee von Biopolitik. Also direkt auf den Körper. Jetzt könnte ich sagen, das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt. Das ist das, was mich interessiert, dass man sagt, an Bewusstsein vorbei. Die ganze soziale Ordnung gibt es ja nur um basale und auch banale biologische Bedürfnisse. Jemand hat Hunger, jemand braucht Befriedigung, jemand braucht medizinische Fürsorge, was auch immer. Dann wird es halt sozial einfach mega organisiert. Dann gibt es eine Regierung und dann gibt es einen Gesundheitsminister und jemand, der sich um Wirtschaftspolitik kümmert und so weiter und so fort. Und im Silicon Valley gibt es so diese Idee, das macht er leider nicht so ganz begrifflich deutlich, dass man das einfach alles überspringt. Also Palantir mäßig, naja, die Leute, also wie Peter Thiel sagte, wir können jetzt ewig überzeugen, aber die werden uns ja nie folgen. Also Wahlen werden wir damit nicht gewinnen, deswegen bauen wir uns einfach die Technologie ein oder werden alle überwacht. Dann kommt Larry Ellison und sagt, wenn wir erstmal alle überwachen, können wir auch alle sanktionieren und dann brauchen wir keine allgemeinen Gesetze mehr, weil wir können ja einfach jedes konkrete Fehlverhalten und so ahnden. Und das steckt ja hier ganz, ganz groß drin. Weshalb dieses Dominieren wirklich gar keine politische Dimension mehr ist.
Nein.
Sondern er hat so einen direkten Bezug.
Er bringt ja diesen Bezug zu den Schurken in Filmen oder überhaupt das Identifizieren mit dem Schurkischen. Er wundert sich beispielsweise, warum nennt man so ein Nahrungsmittel tatsächlich Soylent nach Soylent Green? Also das ist ja eine Dystopie. Da wird Menschenfleisch verarbeitet. Warum nennt man ein Unternehmen Palantir? Denn wenn man dabei Tolki nochmal nachliest, dann ist das eigentlich nicht so positiv gemeint. Man identifiziert sich mit der Dystopie. Daubs sagte aber, Schurken dominieren, aber sie regieren nicht. Das ist der große Unterschied, weshalb das, was sie tun, so im höchsten Maße destruktiv ist, was sich daran dann besonders zeigt, wenn Elon Musk wirklich mal regieren soll. Hier ist Doge, mach mal. Dann holt er diese 24-Jährigen, die irgendeinen Unsinn anrichten, aber es ist genau nicht regieren.
Genau. Und er beschreibt hier, und das haben wir verpasst, diese Lektüre, Careless People von Sarah Wynn Williams, die sechs Jahre bei Facebook arbeitete, 2011 bis 17, um darüber zu schreiben. Und da wird es auch beschrieben. In dieser Zeit, als Mark Zuckerberg noch nicht ahnte, wie sehr er die Politik mal braucht, um uns zu dominieren, weil er glaubte, er hätte einfach ein überzeugendes Produkt, war für ihn einfach Staatschefsgräfen an. Und er so, nee, ich hab grad einen Termin mit meinen Programmierern. Oder er wird dann schon eingeladen nach Davos und steht aber nur in der Ecke oben, weil er gar nicht weiß, was er mit denen jetzt reden soll. Warum soll ich mich mit diesem schmierigen Business der Politik da, warum soll ich jetzt mit denen reden und so. Und so geht es halt durch. Und klar, dann kam das große Erwecken. Leute, die Politik nie mochten, sich geradezu davor ekelten, haben sie plötzlich für sich instrumentalisiert und alles Geld der Welt eingesetzt. Also wirklich eine Perversion von, also hier den Sloterdijk noch draufsetzen und dann...
Ja, das Kapitel danach, das können wir vielleicht so ein bisschen überfliegen. Es beschäftigt sich mit der Distinktion. Da geht es nochmal darum, dass diese Tech-Milliardäre einzigartig sein wollen. Wenn man sich aber anschaut, aus welchen Familien sie stammen, mit wem sie sich umgeben, dann sind sie sehr gewöhnlich für diese Klasse, aus der sie stammen. Nur muss man dann, indem man so ein Genie behauptet oder besonders böse ist, doch wieder eine Originalität oder ein Genie herstellen, das eigentlich gar nicht so vorhanden ist. Dazu passt dann auch, dass man immer wieder solche eugenischen Fantasien ausbuchstabiert. Schon der erste Stanford-Präsident hat das getan, hat an Selektion geglaubt, hat auch den Bürgerkrieg so dargestellt, dass jetzt so eine höhere Rasse da mit zerstört worden ist. Es gibt einen IQ-Fetisch bei diesen Leuten, dass also der IQ völlig isoliert von allem gesehen wird. Und allein das als Zahl ist ausschlaggebend und gibt einem das Recht dann entsprechend zu regieren. Dabei merkt man dann auch, dass es eigentlich so eine Simulation ist, der man selbst nur so halb glauben kann. Die Unfähigkeit der Mächtigen, die Natur und Beschaffenheit ihrer Macht, zu verstehen oder zu begreifen, hat profunde Konsequenzen für die Politik dieses historischen Moments, schreibt Daub. Silicon Valley ist ein Motor für die charakteristischen Selbsttäuschungen unserer Gegenwart.
Aber hier, dieses Kapitel ist ja super wichtig, weil man jetzt einbettet unsere Sloterdijk Lektüre. Denn wir kommen bis zum Ende der, also Ludwig XVI wird dann geköpft. Und bis dahin haben wir Sakralkönigtümer, Gottesgnadentum, Ableitung von oben. Dann wird das Volk entdeckt. Und Napoleon macht diesen Geniestreich zu sagen, ich bin quasi euer Anführer, ihr legitimiert mich oder ich legitimiere euch. Also man ist in so einem zirkulären Verhältnis mit dem Volk. So und jetzt steht denen ja beides nicht zur Verfügung. Also das sind Technotypen, die wollen mit ihren Programmieren hantieren und so. Und die brauchen natürlich jetzt irgendwie einen Ausweg. Und die wollen weder das Sakrale, noch sich dem Publikum ihrer Technologie ergeben. Also was machen sie? Sie wählen sich die Biologie.
Ja.
Und sagen, und das ist halt nicht sehr fern von so nem neokalvinistischen, ich hab einen hohen IQ. Ich wurde auserwählt. Es ist mir aber jetzt nicht wichtig zu sagen, ich wurde von Gott ausgewählt, sondern ich bin halt auserwählt. Ich hab einfach einen hohen IQ. Die Biologie hat es mir geschenkt. Ich hinterfrage das bei mir nicht. Ich bin einfach herrlich. Ich hinterfrage euch mit eurem Low IQ, aber auch nicht. Ihr seid dann einfach mein Publikum. Und so, und es ist schon.
Und die muss man dann regieren, die anderen wie Ameisen. Wie das ja auch bei Alex Karp angelegt ist und von Daub auch nochmal unterstützt wird. Was dann auch dazu führt zu dem fünften Kapitel, wo es darum geht, dass Reife etwas ist, was nicht ein Stadium ist, dass diese Leute erlangen. Denn sie müssen natürlich gleichzeitig bei der Optimierung der Biologie dann auch ihre eigene Biologie ignorieren bzw. versuchen, sich zwei Leben zu schaffen. Da geht es um Elon Musk, der ja immer wieder behauptet hat, er sei in Diablo 4 der beste Gamer. Wie sich dann herausstellte, hatte er Leute wohl bezahlt, um in diesem Spiellevel diesen hohen Status dazu zu erspielen. Zwei Aspekte dieser Anekdote sind beinahe anrührend, schreibt Daub. Erstens die absolute Freudlosigkeit, jemanden für etwas zu bezahlen, das eigentlich Spaß machen und entspannend sein soll, nur damit der reichste Mann der Welt ein paar Online-Gamer dazu bringen kann, sich mit ihm anzufreunden. Zweitens die Tatsache, dass Musk hier zwei parallele Leben gesehen zu haben scheint, die reinzeitig nicht zusammenpassen. Das des Gamers, der endlose Stunden damit verplempert, Diablo 4 zu meistern und das des Unternehmers, der dieselbe Zeit damit verbringt, reicher zu werden. Er sah beide leben und schrien, beide gleichzeitig leben zu wollen.
Ja und da sieht man ja, er brauchte einfach irgendein Fundament. Also man sieht ja hier auch diese Haltlosigkeit von so einer Biografie, diese Orientierungslosigkeit.
Ja.
Und dann wählt man sich eben, es gibt Gamer, also muss ich ein Gamer werden.
So. Und so wie er bei Trump auch.
Was kostet es?
Ja. Also auch Trump, der sich dann immer wieder so als, also wenn ich jetzt beim Boxen richtig hart trainiere, könnte ich dich schlagen, oder? Also dass er einfach so einen Boxer fragt, ob er auch sich da einmischen könnte in dieser Art von Biografie.
Oder erinnert dich an dieses absurde letzte Duell zwischen Biden und Trump, wo sie darüber diskutieren, wer das bessere Handicap hat auf dem Golfplatz.
Sowas, genau. Also das ist Haltlosigkeit, das ist Orientierungslosigkeit, da weiß man nicht wohin.
Das ist unreife. Hier noch zu Elon Musk als mittelaltem Mann. Wir wissen ja jetzt durch die Epstein-Files, Elon Musk weiß an Weihnachten nichts anderes als Nachrichten zu schreiben, ob er auch mal auf diese Epstein-Insel kann. Daubs schreibt, insofern ist Musk Begeisterung für KI-Bilder von sich selbst. Auch ein Stück weit einfach der Sieg der Bilder über die triste Realität. Nämlich freut er sich immer sehr, wenn er als römischer Kaiser oder so auf KI-Bilder dargestellt wird und Fans ihm das bei Twitter schicken. Elon Musk ist kein Krieger des galaktischen Imperiums, kein römischer Zenturion, kein Rapper oder Astronaut. Er ist ein mittelalter Mann mit allen Problemen eines mittelalten Mannes minus Geldprobleme. Seine Kinder mögen ihn nicht, seine Untergebenen mögen ihn nicht. Sein Körper kann nur noch mithilfe von Drogen das, was er früher einmal problemlos vermochte.
Das ist alles sehr richtig. Und so wie Sloterdijk wird ja auch kurz über das Publikum gesprochen. Bei Sloterdijk dieses Jahr, es kann durchaus mal ein bisschen Größe zeigen. Statt voraus eilendem Gehorsamen und ich könnte ja auch der nächste König sein. Solche Ideen. Und hier im Dominanzkapitel wird auf diese Proposition 22 eingegangen. Die Kalifornier wurden also gefragt und sie sind ja nun wirklich, also sie wurden als politisches Publikum im Sinne von, sagt uns doch mal, wie wir Mächtige jetzt entscheiden sollen, wie wir über eure ökonomische Rolle denken sollen. Und sie haben sich dagegen entschieden zu sagen, ich bin ein Angestellter, sondern sie wollten die Hoheit über sich selbst haben, was aber bedeutet, sie bleiben weiter einfach eine Ich-AG bei Uber, bei Airbnb und so weiter, statt endlich mal kollektive Arbeitnehmerrechte anzunehmen. Und das hat der Silicon Valley einfach nur 200 Millionen Werbekampagne gekostet. Also Daub macht es natürlich nicht so scharf wie Sloterdijk, aber hier muss man halt ehrlich sagen, das ist jetzt demokratisch legitimiert, dieser Status. Sowohl oben als auch unten. Die Bevölkerung wollte das so. Sie haben sich ihren König hier wirklich gewählt, indem sie sich selber in diese Rolle des nicht Angestellten, sondern mikrorojalen Ich-AGs gebracht haben.
Creeps, dein wichtiges Thema.
Es gibt hier zwei Kapitel über die Creeps, die ich sehr gut finde. Das eine ist, also es wird über Unterscheidungen gearbeitet. Das eine ist die zwischen dem Creep und dem Priester. Der Priester ist jemand, der noch was will in missionarischer Funktion. Also Beispiel JD Vans. Ich verbiete euch die Pille, weil ihr soll Kinder kriegen für das höhere Gut, was auch immer und so. Alle sind in so einer Schicksalsgemeinschaft. Demgegenüber Musk, Zuckerberg und die ganzen Tech-Pros, die als Creeps einfach irgendwas sehen, was sie nicht gefällt, wie auch immer, pornografische Memes werden hier verhandelt. Der ganze Umgang mit Geschlechtern, dass man einfach so für sich Lebensweisheiten rauszieht, wie jemand muss so und so sein, dann muss das für alle gelten.
Der Creep bandt die Frauen in pornografische Memes. Das ist deren Vorgehensweise.
Genau. Der eine will sie missionarisch, religiös in die Küche verbannen und der andere ins Schlafzimmer fesseln, so ungefähr. Ja, ja. Also wir haben es hier mit dieser Unterscheidung zu tun, wo natürlich die Mysogonie einfach tief einprogrammiert ist und auch überwandelt das Entitlement, ich bin ein Mann. Ich verbanne mich nicht ins Schlafzimmer, sondern nur euch, ich bin ja und so weiter, der Hausvorsteher. Und das wird sehr gut durchargumentiert. Und da gibt es einige Verhaltensweisen, die super interessant sind, die hier am Beispiel Kurtis Yavin gezeigt werden. Wir haben häufiger über ihn gesprochen. Wir haben nie was von ihm gelesen. Ich lese also hier eine Überbande und stelle fest, das ist genau so, wie man es erwartet. Texte mit kleinen Behauptungen, die über die Strecke schlagen oder nicht. Und danach ewig lang Erklärungen, wie man antizipiert, wie das Publikum damit umgeht. Und man sich nur daran abarbeitet, sich da schon mal von frei zu machen. Indem man alles für Nonsens erklärt und hier und da. Und das sind ja auch die Dummen. Und das ist diese typische Ulf-Poschert-Pose, dass man im Grunde nur so einen Halbsatz in den Raum wirft und danach eine Stunde lang die Talkshow damit blockiert, dass man sagt, und ihr hasst mich ja einfach nur und hier und da. Und ihr wollt ja nicht. Und ihr wollt mir jetzt, und der Mann, der frei auf der Autobahn und da habt ihr auch wieder was dagegen. Also man ist die ganze Zeit eigentlich nur wie so ein Steinhauer im Zimmern des eigenen Antlitzes. Jenseits aller Inhalte. Die werden eigentlich nur noch Schiffre.
Zitate Poschert. Der Nihilismus der Trolls, der einen Guerilla-Krieg gegen die Aufrichtigkeit führt, der Ironie nutzt, um für nichts von dem, was er sagt, verantwortlich zu sein, der in erster Linie normalos triggern will, ist rein situationsbedingt. Die Empfindlichkeit, mit der prominente Trolle wie Elon Musk, Donald Trump oder Ulf Poschert die selben Pietäten für sich einklagen, die sie sonst als verweichlicht, verweiblicht und vogue verspotten, zeigt bereits, dass dieser Mangel an Fürsorge nicht gleichmäßig verteilt ist. Sie verlachen diese Fürsorge, wenn andere sie übernehmen und klagen sie dann umso lamoyanter für sich selbst ein. Das Prinzip lautet, es muss zwei Arten von Menschen geben.
Genau, das ist, was dann kommt, eine sehr wichtige Unterscheidung, die allerdings schon im Creep-2-Kapitel steht. Ja, das war jetzt auch aus dem Creep-2-Kapitel zitiert, nur weil du jetzt Posch das erwähnt hast, wollte ich es endlich nachliefern. Bei Javin kommt noch so eine zweite Sache zur Geltung, die er beschreibt als die Methode des Pick-up-Artists, der also immer über Bande spielt, immer aus Sicht des Publikums, sich Hoffnung macht und wenn es dann nicht klappt, ist natürlich das Alter-Ego schuld, also das Gegenüber. Aber ich habe doch jetzt die tollsten Sprüche der Welt verwandelt, um dich zum Date auszuführen. Warum klappt es denn nicht? An mir liegt es ja nicht, also liegt es an dir. Und dann wird eine Weltverurteilung, dann wird wirklich pauschalisiert, dann ist auch nicht mehr das Einzelne gegenüber, sondern dann wird einfach der Feminismus ist schuld. Genau.
Oder sowas.
Werbeet reingelangt. Was natürlich super gefährlich ist, wenn man viel Geld und viel Medienmacht hinter sich hat, weil dann kann man einfach einen Vibe bestimmen. Der allerdings, und da kommt wieder diese Verkopplung zur Verwechslung. Nur weil drei Leute sich darauf einigen können, so zu denken, oder der eine nochmal groß publiziert und dann dankt er seinen sieben Buddies, die alle er selber sind und pädatil. Das hat, also das steckt keine Aussage über die Welt drin, sondern das ist zweite Ebene. Und das Problem zum einen ist, die verwechseln die Welt damit. Das zweite Problem, was ja nicht so häufig oder nicht tief genug thematisiert ist, dass auch Leute, die hier reine Zuschauersituationen haben, die Welt verwechseln mit dem, wie Leute die Welt beschreiben. Das fällt sehr leicht zu dekonstruieren, wenn Friedrich Merz einfach sagt, alle sind faul. Weil dann wissen wir, ich kenne niemanden, der faul ist. Das kann nicht stimmen. Das fällt aber sehr viel schwerer, wenn irgendwas zu so Schwammigen und hier wieder Gender und da wieder Feminismus und bla bla bla. Und dann sagt Ulf Posch halt irgendwie die Autofahrer. Und dann denkt man, ich fahre ja auch Auto. Und dann hat man sich so identifiziert. Da hätte ich mir ein bisschen mehr Präsenz im Buch gewünscht.
Ja, dass er das Publikum mal sieht. Also das konsumiert, also den Zuschauer eigentlich. Eine Zuschauerbeschreibung muss stattfinden. Ich finde das Buch da stark, wo es so einzelne Pointen dann machen kann oder wo ja aus einer Anekdote auch was Größeres wird. Er spricht mit einer Domina, die sehr stark frequentiert wird von einer Kundschaft aus dem Silicon Valley. Und die sagt Folgendes. Gefühlt 75 Prozent der Kunden, so Mandy, wollen auf eine ganz bestimmte Art erniedrigt werden. Man soll sie Schwul nennen. Wenn man sie eine Bitch oder einen Kack nennt, dann freut sie das. Aber wenn man sie einen Schwanzlutscher nennt, dann leuchten ihre Augen richtig auf. Das Studio, in dem Mandy arbeitet, liegt direkt beim Castro District. Nirgendwo in den USA wäre es einfacher, ganz normal schwul zu leben. Mandy glaubt daher auch nicht, dass diese Männer eigentlich schwul sind. Sie vermutet, dass ihre Sexualität, selbst wenn sie Frauen involviert, andere Männer im Blick hat. Frauen sind Mittler.
Die Trophy-Wife. Warum hat man eine Trophy-Wife? Um anderen Männern zu zeigen, was man sich leisten kann. Ja.
Und deswegen lässt man sich, wenn erniedrigen, so, dass man sich also gegenüber Männern erniedrigt, nicht gegenüber Frauen. Und das dann auf diese Weise, dass man sagt, bitte, sagt, dass ich schwul bin.
Ja, das ist sehr klug beobachtet. Und jetzt kommt das Highlight dieses Buches, dass wir auch lange mitschleifen müssen in all unseren Gesprächen. Und das ist die Unterscheidung zwischen dem Creep und dem Caretaker. Und zwar nicht einfach nur, weil man das so beobachtet, dass die einen gar nicht mithelfen wollen und die Welt lieber zertrümmern und die anderen eben Sozialdemokraten sind und so, sondern weil die einen die Creeps sich also über Bande definieren als Caretaker mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen. Nur weil es Caretakers gibt und weil sie sich auf bestimmte Weise zeigen, weil sie Identitätsmerkmale haben, finden die überhaupt eine Losung für sich, um als Creep da dagegen zu halten. Also es ist über Bande wie bei den Schwulen, was wir gerade sagten. Also nicht die Schwulen, sondern dass man auf eine perverse, und ich sage mal ein bisschen salopp, sexuell perverse Weise über Bande etwas spielt, dass man selber gar nicht lebt, aber man hat eine Unterstellung, dass andere so denken. Also man hat so ein Menschenbild, dass man, nachdem man selber lebt, dass man sich aber selbst nicht zugesteht, weil man es eigentlich schon zu bescheuert findet. Wie zum Beispiel, es ist voll abhängig, was andere über mich denken. Nee, ich bin ja voll selbst behauptet. Aber dann macht man es doch über Bande und möchte dann als Schwul erniedrigt werden, weil ja schwule Männer sich an schwulen Männern orientieren. Also ist ja eigentlich total verdreht. Und so ist das hier auch. Wir erinnern uns an ein Beispiel dafür. Elon Musk sitzt in Davos und sagt, das erste, was man automatisieren muss, ist, Zitat, Kindererziehung, Altenpflege, Haustierbetreuung. Es sind also genau die drei zentralen, menschlichen Caretaker-Angelegenheiten, sich um die Älteren, die Jüngeren und die Tiere, die man in seinem Leben haben will, kümmert. So, es ist wie, das Computerspielen soll Spaß machen. Jetzt bezahlst du jemanden dafür, dass er für dich Spaß hat. Also, das versteht ja keiner so richtig, ja. Weil er sich halt über Wande beobachtet. Leute finden gute Computerspieler gut, weil die offenbar besonders viel Spaß haben oder was auch immer. Also, will ich einen besonders guten, und dann bezahlt man die. Und er möchte jetzt nicht nur Roboter bezahlen, sondern seine ganze, ich hab so viel IQ, ich investiere das in, ich baue für uns alle Roboter, die uns davon befreit, Menschen zu sein. Caretaker. Und das ist schon sehr drastisch, finde ich.
Und dich das von Leihmüttern optimierte Kinder austragen, um die ich mich nicht kümmere.
Genau, diese Eugene kommt dann noch in die Bandit rein.
Wie Daubs schreibt, Musk genießt es, Frauen und Kinder wie Spielfiguren auf einem Brett hin und her zu bewegen.
Ja, und jetzt ein zweites Beispiel, ganz aktuell, am 2. April 2026 steht Donald Trump im Weißen Haus und sagt, ich brauche 500 Milliarden mehr fürs Militär. Und dann sagt er folgenden Satz, It's not possible for us to take care of daycare, medicaid, medicare, all these individual things, we are fighting wars. Also das ist 100% in dieser Definition creep.
Ja, na klar.
Aber halt in einer politischen Gemeinwohl Position.
Und da kann man sich mal überlegen, wer jetzt gerade solche Oppositionen noch alle aufmacht. Da finden wir auch im deutschen Diskurs viele und nicht nur Politiker.
Also der spanische Ministerpräsident ist ein Caretaker.
Genau, ja.
In vielen Belangen. Der sagt, nein, wir zahlen nicht so viel Geld an die NATO. Wir bürgern jetzt 500 Millionen Nordafrikaner ein, die uns das Gemüse ernten. Ja. So. Und dann steht jemand daneben und sagt, ha ha, so ein Loser, so ein Normie. Ich definiere mich genau darüber, dass ich ihn hasse.
Denn die Gegenwart interessiert mich eh nicht. Wir können, glaube ich, über das Long-Termism-Kapitel sagen. Da haben wir sehr viele auch schon selbst hier herausgearbeitet, als wir über eines dieser Bücher gesprochen haben. Vielleicht noch ein Satz, mit dem es gut auf den Punkt gebracht wird. Verantwortung ist Verantwortung für das Gegebene. Verantwortung für ein Wolkenkuckucksheim ist Narzissmus mit Umweg. Das ist das, was Adrian Daub, diesen Long-Termisten, attestiert. Sie wollen sich gerade nicht verantwortlich gegenüber dem Gegebenen und der Gegenwart zeigen, sondern sagen, aber in einer Million Jahre, da passiert dies und das.
Oder in 7,5 Milliarden nach Christus, wie er das so als Zahl nennt.
Kann ich mich jetzt nicht damit abgeben, dass hier irgendwelche Kinder hungern. Das ist die Haltung, die da genommen wird.
Also ich will es mal auf zwei Sachen noch unterbrechen. Das eine ist, er schreibt, eine Form von Männlichkeit, die unter Dominanz, und deswegen wählt er diesen Brief, nichts anderes verstehen kann als strategische Verweigerung von Fürsorge. Das ist also ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Den müssen wir auch ganz ernst nehmen. Und ich finde, dass es auch hier als politisches Handbuch zu verstehen, wie diese politischen Kräfte zu verstehen sind. Also strategische Verweigerung von Fürsorge ist hier die Handlungsmaxime. Und dann wird das, du hast jetzt über die Zukunft gesprochen, am Ende gekoppelt mit dem Satz, also allerletzter Satz des Buches, die Zukunft mag ihnen gehören, aber das Langfristige, das dürfen wir ihnen keinesfalls überlassen, denn das Langfristige ist das Säurebad aller Herrschenden. Gut, dieser allerletzte Schwenk ist jetzt ein Verweis auf Sloterdijk. Aber diese Unterscheidung aus...
Denke, dass du sterblich bist.
Genau.
Wir haben jetzt gerade Machtwechsel-Podcast, beide haben wir es gehört. Den Abt aus Jerusalem gehört, der auch am Ende gefragt wird, haben sie eine Osterbotschaft? Und da sagt er den Herrschenden, und er meint damit ganz explizit Netanjau und Trump, bedenkt, dass ihr wieder zu Staub vergehen werdet.
Ja, also die Unterscheidung aus Zukunft und das Langfristige. Nun ist so, das Buch wurde auf Deutsch geschrieben, es ist jedenfalls auf Deutsch schneller verfügbar gewesen, als auf Englisch. Deswegen nehme ich mal an, der Adrian Daub hat hier selber das Langfristige. Ich kannte diesen Begriff vorher so nicht. Wir haben natürlich im Long-Term missen, wenn man das jetzt ein bisschen schräg übersetzt, auch so das Langfristige irgendwie drin. Aber das halte ich auch für eine sehr wichtige Markierung. Die Zukunft ist nicht die Gegenwart. Die Verbindung aus Gegenwart und Zukunft ist unklar. Irgendwer kommt und sagt, naja, nächstes Jahr werden wir eine Technologie haben, danach ist alles anders. Und dann kann man sagen, kann sein, keine Ahnung. Also das ist ja so, was die FDP unter, so kümmern wir uns um das Klima oder was auch immer. Das Langfristige allerdings, würde ich sagen, in meiner Lesart ist jetzt davon unterschieden, das Langfristige hat einen direkten Bezug zur Gegenwart. Es ist das Gegenwärtige, aber langfristig. Das heißt, die Zukunft kann man als Grundbegriff hier fast rausstreichen. Das ist auch toll, dass Lanz immer wieder die Daub, wie heißt sie, die Zukunftsforscherin und so? Gaub. Gaub.
Florence Gaub.
Florence Gaub, die hatte er ja ganz oft da. Hier geht es immer um die Zukunft, die Zukunft, die Zukunft. Und vielleicht sollte man diesen ganzen Diskurs ernsthaft vergegenwärtigen im Sinne wie bei so Fitnesstrainingen, dass man am Ende des Tages Bilanz zieht und sagt, wenn ich jetzt jeden Tag so lebe wie heute, wie geht es mir dann in einem Jahr? Und dann gibt es halt Tage, an denen hat man 100 Kilo Übergewicht und dann gibt es Tage, an denen könnte man sofort Marathon laufen. Und diese Verbindung zur Gegenwart muss gegeben sein, würde ich sagen. Ansonsten hat man es mit Creep zu tun, die einfach nur von Zukunft treten. Und wir wissen, daraus ist nichts abzuleiten, vor allem nichts für die vielen, alle, die Menschheit, was auch immer, der Planet. Also in der Ansicht sehr gutes Buch. Manchmal wirklich können wir uns ein bisschen mehr auf den Punkt bringen.
Ja, vielleicht muss man diese beiden Bücher zusammen lesen. Oder mein Appell wäre an Peter Sloterdijks, dass er eigentlich Adrian Daub gründlicher lesen sollte. Ich weiß, dass Peter Sloterdijks sich jetzt nicht zu x usw. begeben will, um das klein zu analysieren. Aber wo er so drüberschwebt, geht Adrian Daub direkt rein und kommt dann fast manchmal zu Ausführungen, die an die Minimarmoralia denken lassen. Ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben, aber es ist manchmal hat es diesen Charakter. Und von daher ein wichtiges Buch.
Wir können es ja wie folgt frech formulieren. Peters Sloterdijks sollte dieses sehr gute Buch über die Neuen Napoleons lesen von Adrian Daub.
Genau. Was das Valley Herrschen nennt, heißt das neue Buch des Literaturwissenschaftlers Adrian Daub. Er lehrt in Stanford. Er kennt sich mit dem Silicon Valley also sehr gut aus. Er geht genau in die Tweets von Elon Musk noch einmal rein. Er schaut sich aber auch die historische Perspektive an. Wie ist das Silicon Valley eigentlich zu einer solchen Macht geworden? Welche Ideologien sind dort vorherrschend? Und er entlarvt diese Tech-Giganten, die sich als Genies feiern, auf eine sehr prägnante und mitunter böse Art und Weise. Es zeigt sich, dieses Silicon Valley ist vor allem ein Ort, wo uraltes Geld sich den Anstrich ewiger Jugend verpasst.
Und wir kriegen neue Grundbegriffe, die bitter nötig sind. Denn dass unsere Politiker weder am Gemeinwohl orientiert sind, noch sich kümmern, ist klar. Die Frage ist nur, wie nennen wir sie jetzt? Adrian Daubs schlägt vor Creeps. Und das halte ich für sehr wichtig. Klingt noch ein bisschen ungewöhnlich. Aber dieser Begriff muss jetzt domestiziert werden.
Der US-amerikanische Autor Ben Lerner ist ein großes Talent. Das hat Alexander Kluge vor Jahren erkannt, hat sich mit Lerner auch mehrmals getroffen. Sie haben auch zusammen gearbeitet, haben ein Buch herausgegeben. Das alles wusste ich aber nicht. Ich hatte nur so mitbekommen, dass es dieses Buch gibt, las den Klappentext und dachte, das ist doch was für mich. Transkription heißt das. Ein Ich-Erzeller ist auf dem Weg zu seinem 90-jährigen Mentor, will ein vielleicht letztes Interview mit ihm führen. Er hat aber ein Problem, als er dieses Interview führen will, kurz vorher, fällt ihm sein Smartphone ins Waschbecken. Das Aufnahmegerät ist damit also auch hin, wie das diesem alten Mann beichten besser gar nicht. Man fährt mal hin, man tut so, als würde man aufnehmen, aber in Wahrheit gibt es keine Aufnahme. Das ist erst einmal diese Grundkonstellation, die mich interessiert hatte. Wenn man es dann liest, ein paar Seiten, noch ein paar Seiten, dann merkt man, dieser 90-Jährige, der Thomas im Roman heißt, der spricht so, dass man fast an Alexander Kluge denken muss. Und dann liest man noch weiter und denkt, ja, natürlich, das ist doch Alexander Kluge. Fällt sich heraus, ja, der wird hier porträtiert, aber auch etwas entfremdet. Alexander Kluge hat das noch mitbekommen, dass dieses Buch erschienen ist, hat sich über diese freundschaftliche Geste gefreut. Dieser Roman beginnt wie folgt. Im Zug schlief ich ein. Ich war unterwegs zu meinem Interview mit Thomas, der gerade 90 geworden war. Ich saß entgegen der Fahrtrichtung, wodurch es mir schwerfiel, sein neuestes Buch zu lesen, das sich in der Hand hielt. Es schlägt mir auf den Magen, wenn ich zu lesen versuche, während ich falsch herum sitze. Oder, wie meine 10-jährige Tochter Eva es auf einer Zugfahrt nach Lublin vergangenen Sommer formulierte, wenn ich in die Vergangenheit gucke. Ich starte durch das schwache Spiegelbild meines maskierten Gesichts im Glas zum Fenster hinaus. Es ist, deswegen ist das Gesicht maskiert, Corona. Es geht also darum, dass sich hier einer auf den Weg macht. Wir merken schon, an der Wahrnehmung ist einiges verschoben. Da blickt man in die Vergangenheit zurück, wenn man rückwärts fährt. Da spiegelt sich merkwürdig, verzerrt das Gesicht. Wie fühlt man sich eigentlich? Fühlt man sich vielleicht manchmal so, wie wenn man auf dem Smartphone etwas antippt und plötzlich alle einzelnen Apps fangen so zu wackeln an, dass man sie löschen kann? Auch das ist ein Bild, das hier aufgerufen wird. Wie ist es, wenn man einem 90-Jährigen begegnet, der dieser Form der Digitalisierung in Form von Smartphone noch entgehen konnte? Wie sind unsere Beziehungen zur Vergangenheit, wenn wir das vergangene Präsent halten können, auch durch das Smartphone? Es sind also viele Fragen, die hier aufgerufen werden. Dabei spielt das Mediale eine große Rolle. So auch in dem Interview, das nicht aufgezeichnet wird, zwischen Thomas und dem Ich-Erzähler. Sie sagten gerade, dass ihre frühesten Erinnerungen mit dem Radio zu tun haben. Die ersten Stimmen, die man erlebt, sind körperlos, ja? Stimmen, die man in Utrecht hört, die der Mutter, die des Vaters, des Postboten, die Schwester, die ein Männlein steht im Walde singt, der Onkel. Sie reden mit einem Hallo da drin, aber man hört auch zufällig hin. Wenn beispielsweise mein Onkel meinem Vater besucht, dann bringt ihn meine Mutter mit mir auf dem Abenden Kaffee. Vielleicht auf diesem Tablett. So, also das Gespräch. Es geht weiter. Brücken, Dämme. Aber was ich sagen wollte, ist, dass das Radio, dass das eine Wiedergewinnung ist, der Stimme ohne den Körper, dass es wie alles Neue auch uralt ist. Das Wahrhaft Neue berührt etwas, das vor dem Bloß Rezenten liegt. Das gefällt mir an Freud. Vieles gefällt mir nicht, dass jede Entdeckung eine Wiederentdeckung ist. Das Kino entdeckt die Höhle wieder. Das ist auch Plato, Anamnesis, weil für uns alle die erste Erfahrung von Sprache in Stimmen besteht, die sich durch den Körper der Mutter fortpflanzen. Einschließlich deren eigener Stimme. Ja, und wir haben den Drang, dies wiederzugewinnen. Aber verstehst du im Radio, war es Hitlers Stimme, die sich immer höher schraubte. Das ist meine erste Lauterfahrung. Vielleicht ist das alles, was wir in deinem Interview über Hitler sagen können. Und so geht dieses Gespräch weiter. Und wir merken schon, das ist tatsächlich der Duktus von Alexander Kluge, den wir hören. Aber es geht keineswegs um eine Parodie, sondern diese Figur verlässt dann auch die kluge Realität. Ich nehme jetzt nichts vorweg, wenn ich sage, auch der Tod wird vorweggenommen. Also dieser Thomas stirbt. Wir bekommen aber in zwei weiteren Kapiteln andere Perspektiven eingenommen, nämlich nach Thomas Tod ist dieser Ich-Erzähler bei einer Konferenz zu Ehren von Thomas und sagt dort, dass dieses Interview, das publiziert wurde, ja kein aufgenommenes ist, sondern dass das nur aus dem Gedächtnis, aus der Erinnerung heraus entstanden ist, wo man ihm gleich vorwirft, er würde da doch Schindluder treiben, Plaggieren oder was auch immer. Alexander Kluge wurde im Radio dazu, also wenige Wochen vor seinem Tod noch befragt und gesagt, ja, das sei eine tolle Idee von Ben Lerner, denn er sagt, die Erinnerung ist präziser, als jedes Aufnahmegerät in diesem Interview. Muss man mal drüber nachdenken, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Die Erinnerung ist präziser. Man würde ja genau andersrum sagen, wir wissen ja, die Erinnerung trügt und all das. Aber was heißt das eigentlich, wenn die Erinnerung präziser ist? Mit solchen Fragestellen muss man auch an diesen Text rangehen, der es einem nicht leicht macht, weil er mit so vielen Versatzstücken arbeitet. Auch mit der Frage, wie halten wir Erinnerung fest oder was können wir uns medial sagen, über das Medium sagen, was wir uns so direkt nicht sagen können. Da gibt es zwischen Vater und Sohn, davon handelt das dritte Kapitel ein Konflikt. Denn dieser Thomas hat doch einen Sohn, Max, zu dem er ein schwieriges Verhältnis hat. Dieser Max sagt, ich habe es immer noch in meiner Anrufliste. Oder ich habe irgendwann einen Screenshot von meiner Anrufliste gemacht und ich habe Folgendes. Eine Eintragung über einen 3 Minuten und 27 Sekunden dauernden Anruf von Laura am 21. April 2020 um 2 Uhr 13, als sie meinem Vater das Telefon ans Ohr hielt und ich die Dinge sagte, die ich nicht mehr sagen konnte. Dinge, an die er keinerlei Erinnerung hatte. Jedenfalls keine bewusste Erinnerung. Als mein Körper im Krankenhaus lag, war mein Geist auf einem fernen Planeten. Ich habe diesen Screenshot in die Cloud hochgeladen. Aber wo ist er dann, wenn er in der Cloud ist? Und mit wem war Thomas eigentlich damals in der Schweiz? Mit seinem Sohn oder dem ich erzähle? Oder waren sie zu dritt da? Was schiebt sich da über die Erinnerung? Und wo wird vielleicht auch die falsche Erinnerung, eigentlich die wahre Erinnerung, ein zugegebener Maßen komplex, aber sehr poetischer Text, ein kurzer Roman, ein kleines Gedenken an Alexander Kluge. Wer sich darauf einlassen will, ich verspreche viel Vergnügen.
Aber der Text funktioniert auch ohne, dass man jetzt immer Alexander Kluge dahinter vermuten muss.
Ja, ja, das geht auch dann davon weg. Also mit diesem Sohn und so, das ist natürlich fiktiv.
Zurück zur Banalität des Großen, zur Absurdität an der Spitze und der Simplicität in Trumps Kopf. Also in der New York Times gab es einen mittellangen Text am 7. April über How Trump Took the US to War with Iran von Jonathan Swan und Maggie Haberman. Also schon selber wieder die Spitze des Hauses, die der Publizist stetig ist. Worum es da geht, ist gerade für uns heute schnell auf den Punkt gebracht. Wir koppeln jetzt einfach zurück ans Sloterdijk, was wir hier vorfinden. Also es gibt am 11. Februar einen Pitch, den Pitch. Es geht um insgesamt drei Termine im Situation Room, wo man also den Irankrieg vorbespricht. Und im 11. Februar ist alles noch eine ziemliche Luftnummer. Aber Netanyahu ist da. Er hat keinen Presse-Termin bei dieser Reise, sondern nur eine Doorstep-Begrüßung. Alle sehen, er ist da. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, was passiert. Und zugeschaltet ist David Barnier, der Mossad-Chef. Wir haben es also hier schon mit einer telemaligen Ität zu tun. Man überbrückt schon den großen, langen Raum bis in die Region, dort, um die es geht. Die Anwesenden sind Susie Wiles, also die Chief of Staff, Marco Rubio, Außenminister, Peek-Hack-Set natürlich, Verteidigung. Dann der Joint Chiefs of Staff, Vorsitzende Dan Cain, der, wir kennen ja seinen Vorgänger, Mark Milley hier dabei ist. Außerdem John Radcliffe von der CIA und Jared Kushner und Steve Witcoff. Wir sehen also schon, bei diesen Treffen, Treffen sind nicht dabei, Wirtschaftsminister, Finanzminister, irgendwelche Leute, die dann mit diesen Folgen von so einem Krieg zu tun haben, sondern das wird alles bewusst, klein und geheim gehalten, auch nicht anwesend. JD Vance, der ist nämlich gerade in Aserbaidschan und schafft es nicht rechtzeitig zurück. Netanyahu stellt einen Vier-Punkte-Plan vor. Irans Raketenprogramm zerstören. Die Straße von Hormuz soll dann nicht abgeriegelt werden können, weil man hat ja das iranische Raketenprogramm zerstört. Gegenschläge seien minimal zu erwarten, weil man hat ja das iranische Raketenprogramm zerstört. Und außerdem gibt es die ein oder anderen Hinweise vom Mossad. Erkenntnisse über Straßenproteste können durchaus eskalieren in Regime Change vom Inneren und so. Also man schmiert Trumps so richtig Honig ums Maul. Weiß aber auch, die Israelis verkaufen das immer ein bisschen drüber. Es gibt also dann ein zweites, einen Tag später, am 12. Februar Treffen im Situation Room, das hier als die Realitätsprüfung bezeichnet wird. Also man sieht, okay, den Ayatollah töten, könne man schaffen. Die iranische Macht und Drohpotenz gegen Nachbarn. Mal gucken, ob man das zerschlagen kann. Volksaufstand, naja, sind alle schon so ein bisschen kritisch. Und also Regimewechsel, auch Rubio, also ob wir das jetzt als Kriegsziel ausformulieren können, ist ein bisschen schwierig. Und hier wird schon beschrieben, die Rolle von dem Cain, also dem neuen Mark Milley, der nämlich keine eigenen Urteile fällt, sondern einfach immer nur berät. Und also ist jetzt ein sehr kleiner Kreis, der da zusammensitzt, aber die...
Woher wissen die das, wenn ich da kurz einhatte?
Das sind Recherchen mit unbenannten Quellen, so. Aber sie beschreiben auf jeden Fall sehr schön, wie der Cain immer so Fragen bekommt von Trump. Und dann heißt es so, naja, wir können jetzt das und das machen, aber wir haben eigentlich unbegrenzte Ressourcen an Waffen, um da zu ballern. Und für Trump ist das immer dasselbe. Also der sieht da nicht, dass da gerade realistische Einschätzungen, was jetzt konkret zu machen ist, und was das eigene Waffenarsenal so angeht. Für ihn ist immer alles, ach so, also wir können da jetzt viel bombardieren. Ja, eigentlich unbegrenzt bombardieren ist dann für ihn die Schlussfolgerung. Also wir haben ja sehr viel mehr Waffen als die Iraner. Also es ist eins plus eins, zwei. Die werden niemals irgendwo angreifen können, weil wir haben denen ja alle Waffen zerschossen, weil wir haben ja mehr. Dass man die da irgendwie hintransportieren muss und so weiter. Das sind alles so Sachen, die an Trump so ein bisschen vorbeigehen. Na ja, Trump jedenfalls stellt da so seine Fragen, sitzt bei dem ersten Treffen auch gar nicht am Kopfende des Tisches, sondern wirklich so mittendrin, als hätte er damit jetzt gar nichts zu tun. Also Netanyahu sendet so in den Raum hinein. Erst danach erkennt Trump, ach so, ich muss ja auch mal dahin, wo man so Entscheidungen trifft. Also ich bin jetzt nicht nur der Empfänger, mein Freund erzählt mir eine Geschichte, sondern jetzt müssen wir ja ins Handeln kommen. Ach so, das hat jetzt Konsequenzen. Also diese ganze...
Ups, ich bin der Präsident.
Genau, ups, ich bin der, es ist genau richtig, ups, ich bin ja der Präsident. Er ist wirklich reingestürzt, reingefallen in diese Rolle, in diesen Moment. Also wird wirklich sehr gut beschrieben.
Was Daub hier auch beschreibt, in seinem Buch wiederum, dass die dann Macht haben, aber dann doch so tun wollen, als hätten sie gar keine Macht. Also wenn sie nämlich Macht und Verantwortung miteinander verbinden müssen, dann entziehen sie sich einfach wieder so und sagen, höh, ich, was habe ich damit zu tun?
Genau, und dann, die gehen hier so ein bisschen drauf ein, dass Trump 32 Jahre alt war, als das im Iran da losging, er da irgendwie noch so eigene, ah ja, sollten wir eigentlich schon immer machen. Wenn ich das jetzt mache, wäre ich ja der größte Präsident von allen, weil die vorher sich ja nicht getraut haben und lauter solche Sachen. So, und dann, in dem zweiten Gespräch ist aber Vance schon dabei und geriert sich als skeptik, wie hier steht. Ich habe ja schon einige Podcasts gehört, in dem es heißt, ja, jetzt hat Trump sich über Leaks, also bei der Frage, wie kommt der Text zustande, schon in die Rolle gebracht, er war ja immer skeptisch. Wir können aber jetzt mit Sloterdijk folgendes hier herausarbeiten. Vance sagt, also, das ist ein Desaster, wenn wir den Iran angreifen. Dann ist aber die Stimmung im Raum anders. Man möchte es dann doch irgendwie machen. Und dann sagt er, ja, wenn schon Intervention, dann wenigstens so begrenzt. Also wir machen ein nachvollziehbares, vielleicht sogar legitimes Kriegsziel. Wir gehen jetzt nur auf die Atomwaffen oder so. Dann kriegen wir auch den deutschen Kanzler mit rein, ja, so ungefähr. So, und dann merkt er aber, es geht auch nicht. Und dann ist seine dritte. Ja, also wenn schon Großkampagne, dann wenigstens mit überwältigender Wucht. Also aus dieser Losung heraus, ich muss dir auf jeden Fall erstmal Loyalität zeigen. Inhalte second, Loyalität first. Steigert er sich rein in ein, nee, nicht. Aber wenn du willst, unterstütze ich dich dabei. Na, damit es schnell geht, wenigstens mit überwältigender Wucht. Und das ist wirklich eins zu eins, wie Sloterdijk das beschreibt. Die Blöden sitzen im Raum zusammen, denken sich was aus. Loyalität jetzt im Moment ist sehr viel wichtiger, als dass das ja echte Konsequenzen hat. Dass in einem halben Jahr Wahlen sind und man mit Konsequenzen zu leben hat.
Dann lass uns lieber darüber verrückt werden gemeinsam, nur dass wir in der Macht uns halten können.
Die Weils ist ganz stolz darauf, dass sie gar keine Meinung hat. Sie erteilt immer nur das Wort. Rubio ist vor allem durch seine Doppelfunktionen Sicherheitsberater und Außenministerin eine ganz wichtige Stimme. Er teilt über ihm einfach das Wort, hält sich selbst auch zurück. Vens ist schon überzeugt und sagt ja wenn dann wenigstens richtig. Und dann kommt es zu diesem dritten am 26. Februar. Dritte Runde, wieder sind Besset und so weiter nicht dabei. Tulsi Gepper, der Direktorin der nationalen Geheimdienste, auch nicht dabei. Also man ist wirklich im ganz kleinen Kreise. Und dann wird also der Angriffsbefehl ist dann einfach ein von Donald Trump. Also Vens sagt nochmal du weißt ich halte es für eine schlechte Idee, aber wenn du willst, unterstütze ich ihn natürlich. Und am Ende geschieht das einfach nur, weil Donald Trump sagt, ich glaube wir müssen es tun. Ja, I think we need to do it. Und das ist quasi der Angriffsbefehl. Die Militärs sagen ihm dann ja dann bereiten wir das jetzt vor. Also morgen 16 Uhr wäre Deadline für uns. Trump so macht seinen Alltag weiter, sitzt im Flugzeug und 22 Minuten vor der Deadline sagt er dann Operation Epic Fury ist bewilligt, keine Abbrüche, viel Glück. So und damit hat sich das einfach ergeben. Und dieser ganze Hofstaat dort wird hier schön durchgegangen. Also die Wild Chief of Staff. Wenn es für die nationale Sicherheit nötig ist, dann sollten wir es tun. So der Red Clip von der CIA hat keine Meinung, aber er hat Geheimdienstmaterial, das zeigt ja den Aja Toller. Der hält sich jetzt auch mal oberirdisch auf, den wird man kriegen. So das ist so sein Beitrag. Marine-Abgesondte, die hier vom, also die im Weißen Haus council-mäßig die Marinesachen vertreten, sagt, ja das ist eigentlich rechtlich zulässig, dass wir das jetzt hier machen. Also wir fahren einfach mit allen Schiffen da drüber und dann bombardieren wir halt. Die Levitt so, ja, ihr entscheidet hier und ich manage das dann mit dem Presse-Team. Und so geht einfach die Liste durch. Also alle sind einfach so, Kane, sag noch mal, nüchtern, also der Joint Chief of Staff, ja es gibt da schon so ein paar riesigen, aber wir haben im Grunde jetzt erstmal keine Munitionserschöpfung zu erwarten. Was für Trumps so bedeutet, ja dann, also spricht ja nichts dagegen. Und man muss halt echt sagen, Mark Milley ist bekannt dafür, wirklich beratend zu haben. Also im Sinne von, ich habe das jetzt alles nicht zum Spaß gelesen, was in diesen Büchern steht. Und ich habe auch Lenin gelesen. Ich wollte ja wissen, was der Feind denkt. Und meine Schlussfolgerung ist, und nichts davon weit und breit zu sehen hier. Das ist einfach nur Loyalitätsscheiße. Alle fühlen sich geil darin, Präsidenten zu unterstützen. Militärs fanden quasi nicht statt. Also außer, dass halt hier der Marine-Typ und der Oberbefehlshaber da mit dabei ist und so ein paar informative Hinweise gibt. Und dann ist einfach passiert. Das ist die Banalität des Großen.
Ja, besser kann man es sich auf den Punkt bringen.
Das ist wirklich absurd, so wie Sloterdijks das geschrieben hat.
Ich habe ein Buch gelesen von Jörg Barbarowski, Am Volk vorbei zur Krise der liberalen Demokratie. Dieses ist eines, das uns provozieren soll. Ich halte es für ein gutes Buch. Ich weiß, dass Jörg Barbarowski kein linker Autor ist. Ich brauche auch keine E-Mails, in denen mir noch mal irgendwelche Aussagen von Barbarowski jetzt vorgelegt werden. Ist mir alles klar.
Muss man den kennen? Bin ich der Einzige, der ihn nicht kennt?
Er ist ein wichtiger Historiker, Osteuropa-Experte.
Putin-Versteher.
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Das ist auf keinen Fall. Worum es ihm geht, ist zu sagen, es stimmt doch irgendwas nicht. Wenn alle die ganze Zeit die liberale Demokratie retten wollen, ist das überhaupt das, was wir tun sollten, beziehungsweise ist die liberale Demokratie gleichzusetzen mit Demokratie? Nein, sagt er, in Bezug dann auch nehmend, Bezug nehmend auf Philip Manow, aber auch viele andere. Das Volk soll souverän sein, aber es kann sich Gesetze nicht selbst geben und sich nicht selbst regieren. Deshalb muss es repräsentiert werden. Dieser Gedanke aber widerspricht der Vorstellung, das Volk, was immer es auch sein und woraus es sich zusammensetzen mag, könne Herr sein seiner selbst. Aus diesem Widerspruch erwächst der immerwährende Streit. Aha, also wir haben es ja jetzt gerade mit sehr vielen zu tun, die sagen, wir müssen Deutschland vor der AfD retten und deswegen müssen wir alle staatstragend agieren. Er sagt, nö, grundsätzlich ist ja ein demokratischer Impetus gegen den Staat gerichtet, weil auch in einer Demokratie nicht das Volk direkt regiert, sondern das Volk wird repräsentiert. Und da passiert es dann natürlich, dass der Staat zur Beute wird. Da passiert es, dass ja, man eigentlich bei der liberalen Demokratie es mit einer Spielart der Demokratie zu tun hat, bei der durch die Institutionen, durch Verfassungen und so weiter, die Spielräume für den Souverän, nämlich das Volk, doch eingeschränkt werden. Er zeigt hier anhand von vielen, vielen Zitaten von Marx, über Rancière und Nietzsche, inwieweit es tatsächlich auch in Demokratien Unterwerfungsverhältnisse gibt. Er sagt, die Beschwörung einer friedlichen Verständigung ist nichts als Gewaltvergessenheit. Die Leute, die kommen, ja, aber es gibt doch hier unseren Gesellschaftsvertrag, sagt er, das ist Augenwischerei. Nur der Marxismus wiederum, der wollte den Staat bemächtigen, um den Staat dann abzuschaffen. Oder wollte sich des Staates bemächtigen, um ihn abzuschaffen. Das ist dann nochmal ein Weg, den er nicht mitgeht. Deshalb kann man auch sagen, das ist jetzt ganz klar keine marxistische Staatskritik, die so weit geht, dass man eben diesem marxistischen Schritt mitgeht. Allerdings in dieser Opposition zwischen Volk und Regierung, beziehungsweise Volk und Staat, die hier gemacht wird, ist er natürlich auch in den Fußstapfen von Marx, aber natürlich auch in den Fußstapfen von Nietzsche, den er hier zitiert. Staat heißt das Kälteste aller Ungeheuer, kalt lügt es auch. Und diese Lüge kriecht aus seinem Munde, ich der Staat bin das Volk. So ist die Lüge, nämlich der Staat ist eigentlich nicht das Volk. Das uns in so einer Klarheit darzubringen, sich auf Max Weber zu beziehen, die Geschichte der Staatlichkeit eigentlich als eine demokratische Herausforderung zu begreifen, nämlich die Demokratie wird eingeschränkt. Dass er das tut, ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut und auch interessant, dass sich dieser, wie gesagt, eher nicht Linke, auf französische Linke Denker bezieht. Er sagt, der Begriff der demokratischen Gesellschaft sei nur eine Fantasiemalerei, so der französische Philosoph Jacques Rancière, die bementeln soll, dass auch in ihr die Herrschaft der wenigen gerechtfertigt werden muss. Rancière, die Gesellschaften werden heute nicht anders als früher durch das Spiel der Oligarchen organisiert und ebenso wenig gibt es eine demokratische Regierung im eigentlichen Sinn. Barbarowski fügt an, davon ist aber in der politischen Öffentlichkeit nirgendwo die Rede, weil die Fiktion der Volksherrschaft gegen alle Evidenz aufrechterhalten werden muss. Das führt ihn also dann zu der Auseinandersetzung mit Populismus, die sich so gestaltet, dass er sagt, na ja, wenn jetzt da Leute, auch wenn uns die einzelnen Forderungen da so nicht gefallen mögen, auf die Straße gehen und sehr wütend sind und all das, dann ist das nicht eine antidemokratische Haltung, sondern es ist sehr wohl eine Haltung gegen die liberalen Institutionen und die liberale Demokratie, aber nicht gegen die Demokratie an sich. Die Souveränität nämlich, die geht ja dem Recht voraus. Er bezieht sich hier da auf Schmitt ganz deutlich, immer wieder Bezug nehmt auf Schmitt und Philipp Mahno, der ja auch schmittianisch argumentiert. Dabei versucht man sich dann in der Lehre der Souveränität immer häufiger vom Pöbel abzugrenzen. Aber der kann eben auch zurückschlagen, nämlich die, die nicht dazugehören, können auch wütend werden und können sich rebellisch zeigen. Wer den Gehorsam aufkündigt, die Obrigkeit beschimpft und möglicherweise sogar die Systemfrage stellt, wurde auch schon in der Vergangenheit mit dem Vorwurf konfrontiert, gar nicht Teil jener Gemeinschaft mündiger und vernunftbegabter Bürger zu sein, die ein Anrecht darauf hätten, angehört zu werden. Die Rede vom Pöbel, vom weißen Abfall, der in der Flyover-Zones dieser Erde lebt, ist keine Erfindung des 21. Jahrhunderts. Dieser Diskurs ist sehr lang, ideengeschichtig wird er nachverfolgt. Nicht das Volk konstituiert sich, sondern die Verfassung, die konstituiert sich das Volk. Das müssen man verstehen. Marks Ausführungen zu Pariser Kommunen werden rezipiert. Er sagt, wir haben es eigentlich jetzt gerade nicht mit einer Angst vor dem Ende der Demokratie zu tun, sondern bei den Eliten gibt es eher die Sorge, dass es eine revolutionäre Bedrohung gibt. Ob die jetzt von rechts oder links kommt, spielt da dem Sinn erstmal keine Rolle. Es ist eine Bedrohung des Status quo. Nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg, da hatte man so eine Epoche der Langeweile, wie er es nennt und auch ein Liberalismus, der Furcht hat sich breit gemacht, nämlich dass man sagte, wir brauchen ganz viele Institutionen, ganz viel Verfassung, damit wir die Bürger vor sich selbst schützen aus der historischen Erfahrung, vielleicht nachvollziehbar. Zugleich sagt er aber auch, naja, Hitler wurde zwar gewählt, aber was dann parlamentarisch stattfand, was also die Eliten unter sich ausgemacht haben, hat letztendlich zu dieser Allmacht Hitlers geführt. Und es war nicht einfach nur die demokratische Wahl. Jedenfalls ist für ihn klar, dass diese Idee einer offenen Gesellschaft eigentlich eine ist, die von Augenwischerei geprägt ist. Der Individualismus ist etwas, was generell schon in einer gewissen Opposition zum Staat steht. Individualismus bringt den Einzelnen hervor, der aber zugleich dann in dem neoliberalen Zeitalter immer abhängiger wird von den Institutionen. Das heißt, wir sind als Individuum unglaublich darauf angewiesen, dass wir von den Institutionen die entsprechende Anerkennung erfahren. Wenn nicht, dann können wir nicht mehr reisen, können wir dies und das nicht mehr tun. Deswegen muss man eigentlich sehen, ist also diese Stärkung des Individuums bei gleichzeitiger Neoliberalisierung auch erst mal eine Schwächung des Souveränz, nämlich des Volkes, wenn dann irgendwann das so geregelt ist, dass an Schiedsgerichten entschieden wird. Wenn Konzerne das unter sich ausmachen oder mit Regierungen oder irgendwelche Anhörungen sind unter Ausschuss der Öffentlichkeit, dann ist das tatsächlich etwas, wo man sagen muss, naja, da wurde entdemokratisiert. Und diese Entdemokratisierung kann sehr wohl dann auf die Straße berechtigten Protest, auf der Straße berechtigten Protest verursachen. Man könnte es kurz sagen, dieses Buch ist das Gegenbuch zudem von Mark Schieritz, das wir hier im Salon besprochen haben, zu dumm für die Demokratie. Denn da geht es ja eigentlich darum, die liberalen Institutionen wetterfest zu machen gegen den Populismus, der da kommen könnte. Barbarowski schreibt über den Gerichtssaal. Bin gespannt, was du jetzt dazu sagst. Dann mache ich mal eine kurze Pause hier in meinem Referat. Was immer man auch denken mag, wenn brisante Kontroversen von der politischen Arena in die Gerichte verlagert werden, dann ist die Demokratie in Gefahr. Denn Richter, die Machtverhältnisse ignorieren, gefährden sich auf Dauer selbst, weil sie genau wissen, dass ihre Urteile im politischen Raum ein Echo erzeugen, dessen Wirkung sie nicht unter Kontrolle haben. In der offenen Konfrontation ist die Justiz im Vorteil, weil sie niemanden außer sich selbst gegenüber rechenschaftspflichtig ist und weil kein Richter aus dem Amt entlassen werden kann. Gewöhnlich macht die Justiz von ihrer Machtfülle keinen eigennützigen Gebrauch. Doch wird man nicht bestreiten können, dass Verfassungsrichter stets in Versuchungen sind, das Lied derer zu singen, die sie einst ins Amt gebracht haben. Die Politisierung der Justiz aber erweist der Demokratie einen schlechten Dienst. Denn Richter, die vollziehen, was die Legislative und Exekutive versagen, werden unweigerlich in den Streit der Parteien hineingezogen, aus dem sie sich doch eigentlich heraushalten sollen. Weiter, die Politisierung der Justiz wächst mit ihrer Allzuständigkeit. Deshalb kommt es für die politischen Parteien mehr denn je darauf an, Einfluss auf die Besetzung der Verfassungsgerichte zu nehmen. Es ist paradox. Legislative und Exekutive unterwerfen sich der Aufsicht und Kontrolle von Institutionen, die von ihr unabhängig und selbst nicht rechenschaftspflichtig sind und die sich jederzeit über den Willen des Souveränz hinwegsetzen können. Rechtsstaatlichkeit ist eine wichtige Säule der meisten Demokratien, so Wendy Brown. Bei der Staatslenkung durch die Gerichte haben wir es jedoch mit der Subversion der Demokratie zu tun. Eine solche Art der Führung stellt die Unterordnung der Rechtsprechung unter die Gesetzgebung auf den Kopf, auf der die Volkssouveränität entscheidend beruht. Dabei wird eine nicht repräsentative Institution offen ermächtigt und politisiert. Ich hatte ja hier einen Text schon gehabt, wo gesagt wird, müsste man nicht Karlsruhe mal anders sehen. Sind die Verfassungsgerichte nicht auch uns im Wege für eine progressive Politik? Die Politisierung der Fett in den USA ist ja etwas, was jetzt sehr kritisch gesehen wird. Aber jemand wie Adam Truss geht ja so weit zu sagen, das ist ja eigentlich das, was die Linken hätten immer mal machen sollen, sich nie getraut haben.
Bulldozern. Na ja, klar, wir kommen natürlich aus diesen Paradoxiden nicht heraus. Es muss entschieden werden. Politiker machen das auf ihre Weise, Richter auf die andere. Wir können aber schon sehen, in Amerika sind zumindest viele Staatsanwaltschaften Wahlämter. Auf der Gegenseite die Sheriffs, die Polizei.
Da ja, aber hier ist das ja nun sehr entkoppelt voneinander. Und die haben eine enorme Macht oder eine Institution wie die EU und alles, was da dranhängt. Der kommt kurz auf die Griechenland-Krise zu sprechen. Es war für Griechenland und für die Griechen am Ende völlig egal, welche Partei sie wählen. Sie kamen aus diesem Zangengriff nicht raus. Das ist also eine Entmachtung. Wir leben, schreibt Barbarowski, in einer Demokratie, deren Sachwalter den Souverän entmachten wollen. Weshalb er auf eine, ja, elektorale Demokratie eher zusteuern würde, wo Mehrheiten entscheidend sind. Für mich ist da, wie auch bei Philipp Manow natürlich immer die Frage, wie ist aber dann ein Minderheitenschutz zu garantieren? Eine Frage, die bei Manow nicht hinreichend meines Erachtens beantwortet wird und auf die Barbarowsky auch gar nicht eingeht. Das wäre meine Kritik, aber ich würde sagen, von links muss das weiter gedacht werden, weil man wirklich diese autoritäre Seite der Institutionen ja sehen muss. Man muss nicht den Schritt von Barbarowsky mitgehen und sagen, wir müssen jetzt erst mal wieder das Staatsvolk in den Vordergrund stellen, weil er natürlich sagt, ja, mit der Migration ist das Problem, dann haben wir Gerechtigkeitsdebatten, Leute, die nicht zum Staatsvolk gehören, aber trotzdem hier irgendwelche Transfers erhalten und all das. Ich halte das für nicht besonders stichhaltig. Man kann das Staatsvolk auch anders definieren und kann vor allem auch diese Gerechtigkeitsdebatte verhindern, weil wir wissen, man könnte mehr Geld mobilisieren durch MMT, alles, was da uns vorgeschlagen wird, wie durch Umverteilung. Aber, glaube ich, ganz wichtig ist hier zu erkennen, dass man sich versucht, jetzt mal ehrlich mit der Demokratie als Konstrukt auseinanderzusetzen und dabei auch versteht, dass es hier nicht um wahr oder falsch geht, wie Chantal Muff zitiert wird, Demokratie ist keine Wahrheitstheorie, sondern dass es hier um Machtverhältnisse geht. Sodass ja auch hier ein Denker ist, der sehr viel sich auf linke Theoretiker bezieht, um zu sagen, naja, also hier ist doch alles auch schon mal an die Hand gegeben. Man muss jetzt nicht nur angstvoll da den Status quo verteidigen und sagen, ist aber doch eigentlich alles so gut. Und dann brauchen wir nur noch vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft. Sondern man muss eigentlich hier erkennen, wird eine Kritik geliefert, die uns dann dazu führt, zu sagen, trauen wir uns mehr Demokratie zu? Er bezieht sich hier durchaus auch auf Willi Brandt. Oder sagen wir, wir haben Angst vor der Demokratie. Dann muss man es aber vielleicht auch wirklich so artikulieren. Und dann hat man eine ganz andere Debatte. Aber das gerade sehr scheinheitlich geführte Argument, die liberalen Institutionen sind, die Demokratie, wird hier doch, wie ich finde, sehr polemisch, aber stichhaltig und gut lesbar entlarvt.
Sehr gut. Ich möchte trotzdem anmerken auf das vorgelesene Zitat. Die deutschen Verfassungsrichter fallen jetzt nicht dadurch auf, dass sie unbedingt immer mitspielen wollen, sondern die große Ausnahme dieser Regel ist natürlich das Urteil zur Verschuldung da gegen das Sondervermögen. Ansonsten kriege ich vom Bundesverfassungsgericht immer nur mit, wie sie ein ums andere Mal fernab jeder Inhalte einfach nur sagen, welche Organe hier zuständig sind, welche unberechtigt dabei sind, Entscheidungen getroffen haben, wem das jetzt nochmal vorzulegen ist, statt selber erinnertlich einzugreifen, was ja zum Beispiel in Amerika ganz anders ist.
Ja, anders stammt.
Da pickt sich ja das Supreme Court wirklich gerade raus, was er so als Vorlage und dann wird einfach über alles Mögliche, was eigentlich Verfassungsrang hatte, entschieden. Einen Text, den wir lesen, weil er viele Leser hat. Wir spielen also hier das Hegemon-Argument über Bande. Er heißt der nächste Coup-Versuch, The Next Coup Attempt and How to Stop It. Also Timothy Snyder schreibt drei Tage bevor die New York Times ihren Text schreibt, wie man einen Coup verhindert. Und er macht das in fünf Schritten, die ich nicht alle so richtig nachvollziehbar finde. Aber sei es drum, bekannt ist er dadurch, 2017 schon mal On Tyranny geschrieben zu haben, mit der großen Logik Do not obey in advance. Also bitte nicht im Vorfeld schon flach auf den Boden legen und sagen, bitte Trump trampel auf mir rum, sondern, also wie wir es gerade bei den New York Times gelesen haben, sondern man kann durchaus mal Staatsbürger Größe beweisen, die königliche Kundenrolle annehmen. Also das Setup ist ja hier. Es gab schon mal einen Putschversuch von Trump, nämlich nachdem er nicht anerkannte, dass Joe Biden gewählt wurde. Wir sehen also, wenn wir es hier drauf zukommen lassen, dass es einen zweiten Putschversuch gibt, eine Wiederholungstat. Die erste war nur einfach nicht erfolgreich. Da würde ich sagen, das ist vom Setting her erstmal sehr gut. Und er möchte jetzt auch, das finde ich sehr witzig, dass er hier immer vom Ballsaal und Bunker. Also was ist Trumps Thema und was ist Trumps Thema? Und das ist ja so krass, dass wir jetzt gleichzeitig Ballsaal und Bunker gerade thematisieren, weil ja unter dem Ballsaal offenbar ein Bunker geplant wurde und lauter solche Sachen. Also unter deren Sicht finde ich das sehr gut zu sagen, ne, wir müssen immer zweigleisig denken. So, das erste der fünf Szenarien ist The Steady Hand. Das kennen wir, amerikanische Präsidenten. Oh, es ist ein Krieg, jetzt kein Führungswechsel. Jetzt die Steady Hand. Die Frage ist dann, kriegt man das vermittelt, dass vielleicht JD Vans übernimmt oder sowas? Nein, also hier in dem Text noch nicht. Es geht darum, dass Trump einfach an der Macht bleibt. Die ruhige Hand. Und er widerspricht und sagt, die einzig ruhige Hand ist die der Justiz. Und ich würde ja sagen, lieber in Friedenszeiten dran gewöhnen, dass man gar keinen Kanzler und Präsidenten hat, sondern einfach ein großes Gremium, das halt entscheidungsfähig ist.
Timothy Snyder, um das herauszustellen, ist also der gegen Barbarowski. Ich glaube, so kann man es auf den Punkt bringen. Also er ist, ja ja, ganz klar. Ich glaube, Barbarowski und Timothy Snyder würden mir beide zustimmen, mit dieser Diagnose. Dass sie in Oppositionen zueinander stehen, ja. Also ich glaube, Timothy Snyder ist nicht derjenige, der sagt, ich will elektorale Demokratie, sondern der sagt, wir müssen die liberalen Institutionen als zum Beispiel das Recht stärken. Und Jörg Barbarowski sagt, ja das Recht, das ist ja nachgelagert, erst kommt der Souverän.
Wahrscheinlich ist du recht.
Ich will das nur, es ist ein schöner Kontrast jetzt gerade, dass hier in Bezug auf Amerika gesagt wird, wir brauchen da dringend die Institution, bevor der noch weiter freitret. Was auch noch mal der Unterschied ja ist, wir haben es ja bei den US-Präsidenten mit Leuten, mit einer ganz anderen Machtfülle zu tun, als das hier in Deutschland der Fall sein kann.
Genau, schon allein dadurch, dass sie eigene Wahlämter sind, wie das Französische. Und dann heißt es immer, das Parlament ist nicht auf seiner Seite. Und dann denkt man sich so, ja warum habt ihr das denn so gebaut? Ist doch bescheuert. Also zu deinem Punkt möchte ich sagen, wahrscheinlich wären sie nicht einer, vor allem der Timothy Snyder hat hier gerade keine Polemik geschrieben, sondern hier geht es ans Eingemachte. Und von daher würde ich sagen, eine Polemik zu schreiben ist sowieso schon mal contrarian gerade in dieser Großwetterlage. Das zweite hier ist Bonapartism. Wenn ihr die Demokratie zu Hause so geil findet, dann lasst sie uns doch in die Welt tragen. Wir machen jetzt Kriege. Also man nutzt den Iran-Krieg so richtig, jetzt wo er einmal da ist, man kriegt ihn ja nicht weg, dass man ihn einfach komplett überhöht. In so einer pseudosakralen inhaltlichen Begründung, wir als Volk, ich als euer Führer, wir können das doch jetzt machen. Den Iranern einfach Demokratie bringen. Das Volk da wäre nicht von alleine. Also pushen wir noch ein bisschen mehr. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man das noch mal hingebogen bekommen mit diesem Iran-Krieg, alleine wegen Spritpreise und so.
Wenn man noch so eine Wolfowitz-Administration von vor 20 Jahren hätte, aber so nicht.
Was im großen Widerspruch zu Sloterdijk ist, also in der Sonosphäre kriegt man das nicht mehr hin. Dafür bräuchte man jetzt Tagesthemen und New York Times und so. Kann man ja mal so sagen. Dann die drittens Bismarck Unification. Also ich meine, Bismarck hat ja das Land wirklich geeint. Keine Ahnung, wie weit man hier noch Einigkeitsgedanken noch mal reinkriegt.
Aber das müsste ja dann über eine sozialstaatliche Innovation laufen. Also da müsste ja eine neue Sozialgesetzgebung oder so was her, dass man damit eine Einheit herstellt.
Genau. Und man würde halt den Austausch machen und zu sagen Zuckerbrot und Peitsche. Also das mit der Demokratie geht nicht. Einheit ist jetzt wichtig.
Jaja.
So auf diesem Wege.
Da denke ich mir, weiß nicht, also die, ich weiß gar nicht, was da mobilisiert werden müsste, um dort eine Sozialstaatlichkeit herzustellen, dass ein solches Empfinden sich einstellt.
Vor allem nicht bei diesem Approval Rating, dass er dann schon entscheidend ist. Und na klar, die Staaten sind halt auch über ihre Wahlämter zum Teil, haben wir aus Kalifornien gehört von extra klein, jedes Wahlamt demokratisch besetzt. Also da gibt es ja auch einen strukturellen Nicht, sozusagen eher sind die Separatisten, als dass von Washington aus das Land geeint wird.
Bismarck wäre Healthcare for All. Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass das jetzt gerade die Trump-Administration groß macht?
Nein, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Das faschistische Opfer, kennt man ja, Putin in der Ukraine, Hitlers Invasion der Sowjetunion, also Führer und Volk vereint und ausgerichtet, sind zum Opfer bereit. Ich weiß nicht genau, was er uns damit sagen will. Hitler hatte schnelle Siege in Polen und Frankreich gewonnen. Trump jetzt, also in Kuba das köchelt so sinnlos einher. Man sieht Fernsehbilder und denkt sich, das geht ja irgendwie nicht. Jetzt wird immer häufiger, während Venezuela, das war ja so ein großer Erfolg. Keine Ahnung, ob das als Blitzkrieg, kann man wiederholen, taugt. Vor allem jetzt, wo man es drei Monate später schon im Iran sieht, dass es nicht taugt. Na ja, also er schreibt, Hitler hatte schnelle Siege in Polen und Frankreich gewonnen, was bei vorher zweifelnden Militärbefehlshabern und Zivilisten den Eindruck schuf, er wisse, was er tue, was dann den Weg für eine zweite ideologische Phase des Krieges öffnete. Also, das potentielle ich nicht. Die amerikanischen Befehlshaber sind Trump gegenüber vermutlich skeptisch. Jedenfalls werden sie von Hexeth, das ist natürlich ein strukturelles Argument, in einem außergewöhnlichen Tempo gefeuert. Ähm, das stimmt so weit, aber das Militär ist auch sehr groß, also man weiß, aber da haben wir wenig Plan. Und dann Exploitation of Terror. Vorbild hier ist nicht der 11. September, sondern die von Putin angeleierten Wohnungsbombenanschläge 1999, die der eigene Geheimdienst ausführte. Und dann brauchte man halt den großen Führer, der dann sagt, hier, wir kämpfen jetzt gegen Terroristen, das Land steht zur Seite und man kämpft jetzt gemeinsam gegen den Terrorismus. Jetzt, 20 Jahre später wissen wir, wie es eigentlich ablief. Hier wird jetzt aber eine sehr interessante, aktuelle Konnotation reingebracht, denn Trump könnte ja behaupten, der Iran mache Anschläge in Amerika. Nur, dem Iran ist das gerade gar nicht abzulesen. Nicht, weil sie nicht könnten, sondern weil sie, schreibt er explizit, mehr Gewinnerin sehen, Hexeth zu verhöhnen und so Tweets zu schreiben wie Regime Change in Full Swing und dann aber Amerika zu meinen. Wieder immer mehr ayatoller-artige, vulgär-salkrale Leute einfach die Macht übernehmen. Und da muss man nicht sagen, das ist auch witzig irgendwie. Also auf so einer inhaltlichen Ebene, weil es stimmt. Naja, er kommt dann zurück auf sein Ebay in advance, das natürlich eine, wie wir bei Sloterdijks gehört haben, immerwährende Geltung besitzt. Und Wissen verändert Zukunft. Na gut, das können alle behaupten. In deren Sicht, ich weiß nicht genau, wahrscheinlich ist es dem Autor geschuldet, dass man diesen Text jetzt so intensiv liest. Oder häufig zumindest. Ich sehe gerade gar keinen Weg für erfolgreicher. Wir müssen hier Wahlen canceln. Und ich habe danach Handhabe gegen einen wieder demokratisch regierten oder dominierten Repräsentantenhaus. Das sehe ich irgendwie, also keine Ahnung.
Ich sehe es auch nicht. Aber ich erinnere mich jetzt ad hoc an einige Irrtümer von Timothy Snyder. Insofern kann das natürlich sein.
Ja, aber das haben wir zumindest gelesen.
Der Autor Roman Wider hat sich mit Russland und der Ukraine viel beschäftigt. Russisch studiert, mehrere Reisen, Aufenthalt in Russland, in der Ukraine. Er hat in Sibirien gelebt. Er kennt sich mit russischer Literatur und Sprache sehr gut aus. Er hat sich aber davon abwenden müssen, als nämlich die Krim von Putin überfallen wurde. Also lange vor der volle Invasion dann. Er wollte auch dann nicht mehr daran beteiligt sein, mit seinem Promotionsprojekt da irgendwie. Ja, dem als Übersetzer für ein putinisches Russland zu dienen. Das heißt, er ist also jemand, der sich ganz klar pro-ukrainisch positioniert hat, der jetzt einen Text im Merkur veröffentlicht hat, der einen aufhorchen lässt. Dieser Text ist überschrieben mit den Worten, war mir nicht so bewusst. Von wem können diese Worte sein? So beginnt der Text. Eine Äußerung aus einem dieser Podcasts geht mir nicht aus dem Kopf. Paul Ronzheimer hatte am 29. November 2025 Carlo Massalla und Claudia Major eingeladen und der Titel war durchaus vorsichtig formuliert. Waren wir zu optimistisch? Es wäre nicht eher abschneidend gewesen, wenn die Gäste sich zu einem vorsichtigen Ja durchgerungen hätten. Immerhin hatten die beiden, wie viele andere Experten, die Rückeroberung verlorener Territorium womöglich gar der Krim in Aussicht gestellt, sei es auch nur partiell, um so in eine bessere Verhandlungsposition zu kommen und natürlich nur unter der Voraussetzung viel umfassender Waffentieferung. Aber nein, sie würden alles wieder so machen. Weil Ronzheimer nachhakt, meint Masalla allerdings, zum Rückzug aus Bachmut hätte er im Frühjahr 2023 früher raten sollen. Dann lässt Ronzheimer am Anfang selbst Frontreporter die beiden wissen, dass sie in der ukrainischen Debatte einen großen Einfluss haben, weil, Zitat, das was ihr zum Beispiel sagt oder wir schreiben, sehr eins zu eins in der Ukraine zitiert wird. Daraufhin Masalla, okay, gut, war mir nicht so bewusst. Das gibt jetzt Roman wieder zu denken. Er sagt, kann es sein, dass weite Teile der deutschen Öffentlichkeit über Jahre hinweg Personen zugehört haben, die keinerlei Innenansicht der ukrainischen und der russischen Gesellschaft besitzen? Was bedeutet im Bereich von Militär- und Sicherheitspolitik überhaupt der Expertise? Man stelle sich vor, Christian Trosten hätte sein Virus nur aus dem Internet gekannt, als Meme vielleicht.
Das ist ein sehr gutes Bild.
Diese Frage, die er uns hier stellt, ist die entscheidende Frage. Vier Jahre Kriegsdiskurs. Und wir hören die Experten, die am meisten vorkamen und die wissen nicht mal, dass sie in der Ukraine zitiert werden oder irgendwas. War mir nicht bewusst. Oh ja, da habe ich mich wohl einmal bei Bachmuth bisschen geirrt. Das war's. Er schreibt nichts gegen Gespräche mit ukrainischen Soldaten. Aber welchen Wert hat es, wenn in einem Interview über die Front das ukrainische Heer als Familie beschworen, der Gegner als das Böse schlechthin bezeichnet wird? Wie das medial geschieht dann. Und man wird auch ärgert, dass diese Experten dann immer aber so tun, als würden sie ja gar keine Handlungsanweisungen geben, gar keine Forderungen ausstellen, sondern nur neutral beschreiben. Sagt er, das stimmt doch nicht. Er sagt, wenn Masalla meint, man müsse sich darauf einstellen, dass der Krieg noch ein paar Jahre weitergeführt wird, dann ist das keine Prognose. Es ist unwillentlich auch eine Anweisung. Bitte weiter kämpfen. Ihn ärgert sehr, dass es eine europäische Projektion von der Ukraine gibt, die so aussieht, dass man sagt, geschlossen und wehrhaft stehen sie da, so gemeinsam da. Das sei nicht der Fall. Er beschreibt, wie die Ukraine vor dem Krieg von Europa und vor allem vom IWF immer weiter in die Privatisierung gedrängt wurde und damit die Korruption gesteigert wurde. Er beschreibt auch den Klassenkonflikt in der Ukraine. Sehr interessant. Er sagt da, diejenigen, die an vorderster Front kämpfen, wie die Angehörigen des Rechtsradikalen, gar nicht so europa-affinen Asow-Regiments, haben eine pessimistischere Einschätzung der Wirklichkeit und plädieren für einen Waffenstillstand. Die nach Europa orientierten liberalen Kreise hingegen, die in der Regel Englisch sprechen, positionieren sich mehrheitlich gegen jeden Kompromiss, obwohl sie selbst gar nicht kämpfen. Sie wiederum sind die Quelle der westlichen Journalisten, die über die Ukraine berichten. Das heißt, diese Dopplung, die wir hier schon sehen, also man sagt hier, es muss weitergekämpft werden, jetzt nicht den Mut verlieren, da haben wir immer hier gesagt, ja das sind so unsere Sessel-General. Offenbar gibt es das aber in der Ukraine dann auch nochmal diese Aufteilung. Er sagt, ja, was waren das eigentlich immer für Sätze, die man so gesagt hat? Putin darf mit seinem Plan nicht durchkommen. Was bedeutet das? Er fragt, was Scholz da eigentlich gesehen hat. Er sagt auch, naja, was ist eigentlich jetzt das Ziel? Also geht es wirklich um die Ukraine? Weil die meiste Zeit dann ein Anstieg gebracht wird, wenn wir jetzt da Putin in der Ukraine nicht stoppen, dann wird er sich Moldau und Litauen holen. Aber dann sagt er, was bedeutet das denn im Umkehrschluss? Die 100.000 Soldaten, die jetzt gefallen sind, also er spricht von hunderttausende Soldaten, also plural, die da gefallen sind, scheint deren Zukunft nur deshalb beendet worden zu sein, wegen Moldau und Litauen schon. Also gibt es einfach so, Ukraine ist schon nur so ein Übergangsding, aber für was Höheres, also das Höheres noch nicht mal mehr, das eigene Land, sondern das. Also er beschreibt es wirklich wahnsinnig gut, diese Widersprüche. Er fragt sich auch, was ist eigentlich mit dieser Aufrüstung für wen? Weil Russland sich angeblich darauf vorbereitet, ab 2029 die EU anzugreifen, ist allerdings ohnehin längst beschlossen, dass die europäischen Rüstungsbudgets in völlig neue Dimensionen steigen müssen. Die horrenden Ausgaben werden jedoch das Atombombenarsenal Russlands nicht wegzaubern können, sondern nur die eigene Gesellschaft Schritt für Schritt von innen zerstören und am Ende jene Leute an die Macht bringen, die mit diesen Waffen auf jeden Fall etwas anfangen können, wenn gleich dann vermutlich Hand in Hand mit Russland. Das ist ja auch meine Sache immer von den Leuten, die die ganze Zeit sagen, es ist fünf vor zwölf mit der AfD und zugleich diese Aufrüstung, die man der AfD in die Hand gibt. Er hat auch eine Passage, wo er sagt, hätte man vielleicht als Deutschland und Russland kurz vor Ausbruch des Krieges ein Manöver in der Ukraine, ein Probe-Manöver machen müssen, um damit Putin zu verstehen zu geben, mache es nicht. Also hätte man da kalkulieren sollen, ich kann das überhaupt nicht beurteilen, es ist jedenfalls ein Aspekt, der hier drinsteckt. Er sagt über die NATO, warum wird sie im russischen Wording die Grundursache des Konflikts nicht genau jetzt zur Verhandlungsmasse erklärt und zwar nicht durch den naiven vorschnellen Verzicht der Ukraine auf einen NATO-Beitritt, sondern im Gegenteil hinsichtlich einer perspektivischen Integration Russlands in ein solches Sicherheitsbündnis. Man hat es schon vergessen und damals auch nicht glauben wollen. Am Anfang des Krieges stand schon einmal eine Forderung nach Sicherheitsgarantien, und zwar für Russland, worauf die USA abstärkig reagiert haben, mit Verweis auf den NATO-Russlandrat. Heute wäre für die NATO ein guter, vermutlich der letzte Moment, ihr Bedrohungskapital in Frieden umzumünzen. Ihr Abschreckungspotenzial als Sicherheitsbündnis steht durch die aktuelle Politik der US-Regierung ohnehin nur noch auf tönernen Füßen. Auch das, finde ich, ist eine ganz erstaunliche Überlegung, dass man wirklich eine europäische Sicherheitsarchitektur hat, bei der Russland auf Dauer mit eingeschlossen werden muss. Er sagt auch, das sei ja am Ende auch etwas, was schon Christopher Clark und der eben hier besprochene Jörg Barbarowski ins Spiel gebracht haben. Das aber, müsse man auch sich klar machen, ginge nur ohne Putin. Und das wäre vielleicht eine Möglichkeit, Druckmittel auszuüben, nämlich ins Innere, dass die russischen Eliten, um Teil des Sicherheitsbündnisses zu werden, sich Putin und seiner Schergen entziehen. Realistisch jedenfalls nennt sich die Politik der antagonistischen Aufrüstung zu Unrecht, schreibt er. Sie ist vielmehr die Konsequenz der Verleugnung der realen Existenz des Gegenübers. Und sie hemmt gerade dadurch auch den fantasievollen und gestaltenden, also politischen Umgang mit den wirklichen Verhältnissen. Finde ich, 17 Seiten ist der Text lang. Ich empfehle ihnen Gänse zu lesen, weil er auch sehr viel über die Historie der Ukraine der letzten 20 Jahre, 30 Jahre erzählt. Ja.
Sehr gut. Dieses Bild würde Drosten einfach aufgrund chinesischer Nachrichtenlagen hier einen Podcast über ein Virus machen, ist natürlich genial.
Ja.
Weil Drosten das so oft und eigentlich immer hat mitlaufen lassen, worüber man gerade nichts sagen kann. Ja. Und das bei Masalla einfach nie ein Thema ist. So ein letzter Text von mir. Anna Holms schreibt in The Atlantic über ihre Popkultur-Aversion. Je mehr Leute mir die Serie The Pit in dem Fall empfehlen, desto unwahrscheinlicher ist es, dass ich sie mir anschaue. Eine Vermeidung jener Popkulturprodukte, von denen scheinbar alle behaupten, dass sie mir gefallen würden, nennt sie eine Hyper-Aversion, die sie bei sich beobachtet. Das Phänomen kennen wir alle. Wie man kommt, ganz enthusiastisch herbeigestürmt und sagt, musst du gucken, musst du gucken. Man denkt sich so, nee, also jetzt erst mal recht, erst recht nicht so. Ich muss mich ein bisschen selbst behaupten. Ich entscheide, was gut für mich ist. Sie fragt sich dann, sie prüft sich. Bin ich ein Idiot? Bin ich ein Contrarian? Nee. Non-confirmist? Auch nicht. Dissenter? Bin ich einfach immer dagegen? Nein. Hab ich keinen Urteil? Nein, ich merke schon. Reaktanz ist es schon. Also es hat schon was damit zu tun, wie es mir empfohlen wird. Bei Harry Potter, Taylor Swift und so, geht man mit dem großen Flow oder behauptet man von sich, kenn ich nicht, ich hab besseres zu tun irgendwie so. Jedenfalls, sie diskutiert so ein bisschen durch. Fomo Lomo, also dass man auch eine Love of Missing Out hat. Und so gibt es auch. Und sie macht am Ende folgenden Punkt, den ich jetzt mal herausarbeiten möchte. Es ist die Wende, die sie bei sich dann feststellt. Und zwar läuft das so ein bisschen über dieses Identitätsmanagement. Also sie lehnt nicht die Kultur ab, aber dieses Moment der Identifikation oder Überidentifikation, sowohl bei anderen als auch missionarisch über andere bei sich selber. Und es kommt dann ein bisschen mit Selbstschutz und Pipapo. Und dann macht sie am Ende eine ganz interessante Beobachtung. Fakt vielleicht ein bisschen auch damit zu tun, dass ich die Woche dieses Fußballspiel Bayern München gegen Real Madrid sah.
Kommt es dazu?
Ich habe einen Neunjährigen. Ach so. Seine Schwestern sind gerade auf und davon. Es sind Ferien, sie sind im Ausland. Er musste mit mir Vorlieb nehmen und ich wollte ihm eine Freude machen und sagte, FC Bayern München gegen Real Madrid spielt. Und damit bin ich natürlich Volltreffer. Kann man natürlich gucken, vor allem, weil es dann heißt, bis 23 Uhr aufbleiben.
Aber ihr wart nicht im Stadion?
Nein, im Fernsehen.
Ich wusste nicht, wo es stattfindet.
Ach so, ja, nein, nein. Nein, nein, wir waren zu Hause im Fernsehen. Also, es gibt das Phänomen, dass wir alle bedauern, dass es nicht mehr da ist, dass Thomas Gottschalk für uns Deutsche, also der Singular im Plural, den Abend eröffnet und sagt, jetzt ist wetten das. Was es aber gibt, ist, jeder für sich guckt einfach seine Lieblingsserie. Das sind also zwei ganz krass unterschiedliche Phänomene. Und daraus leitet sie jetzt ab, ich reformuliere auch mal ein bisschen, sie möchte nicht erkannt werden als jemand, der asynchron nach eigenem Rhythmus so eine, kann ich heute, kann ich morgen gucken, eigentlich auch egal, Streaming Rezeption macht. Wenn es aber das gemeinschaftliche Abend, hast du gestern Dings geguckt, wäre sie sofort dabei. Weil da eben jenseits, also wir sind hier ganz nah am Medium ist der Message, weil es jenseits des medialen Inhalts eben ein Gemeinschaftsstiftendes, ja klar hab ich es gestern geguckt, weil ich kam ja nicht drum herum, weil es wurde nun mal gestern 20.15 gesendet. Also habe ich natürlich organisiert, ich das nicht alleine gucke. Ich habe mir Freunde eingeladen, wir haben Happening draus gemacht. Und jetzt ist einfach, hast du The Pit geguckt? Du musst unbedingt The Pit gucken. Und sie so, nee, sorry. Ich bin kein einsamer Zuhausesitzer, der The Pit guckt und das ganz geil findet und dann noch binge-watched oder so und acht Stunden nichts anderes macht. Ja, also dieses Bild des vereinzeltem Empfängers will sie einfach nicht akzeptieren. Vielleicht habe ich es jetzt auch zu deutlich rausgelesen. Ja, aber es wird sehr deutlich am Ende, dass sie das so markiert als...
Ja, weil es sonst ein Gemeinschaftserlebnis ist und man freut sich auf die nächste Folge in der nächsten Woche. Aber wenn jemand quasi mit dem Wissenvorsprung kommt, ich habe die ganze Serie ja schon gesehen und du noch nicht, du Schuldiger.
Genau. Wenn es um The Pit geht, dass ich an jedem Tag zu jeder Zeit alleine anklicken kann, dann ist das, wogegen ich mich vielleicht wehre, wenn ich mich gegen die Menge entscheide, nicht der Hype, sondern die Einsamkeit.
Ja, sehr klug. Ich kann es gut nachvollziehen, wenngleich ich ein Freund der Allverfügbarkeit bin. Denn ich leide darunter, dass ich jetzt zum Beispiel sofort ins Kino hechten muss nachher.
Weil der Film nur noch drei Wochen kommt.
Um mir einen Film anzusehen, der um 16 Uhr zu sehen ist. Und dann kann ich das nicht ändern. Sonst müsste ich den morgen gucken. Morgen bin ich aber woanders und dann geht es nicht.
Genau. Aber du bist halt eine Orchidee, die sowieso die Filme alleine guckt.
Ich gucke viel allein, ja.
So. Und das ist genau das, wogegen sie sich wehrt. Wenn jemand sagt, ja, ja, ich habe The Pit schon geguckt, dann ist das das, wow, was für ein einsames Leben. Du hattest schon Zeit zu Hause acht Stunden The Pit zu gucken. Ja, also fand ich sehr gut, sehr mutig.
Fanny Pigeot schreibt in Le Monde Diplomatie über den Mineralienabbau im Kongo. Es geht darum, dass ja, Kongo reichhaltige Vorräte im Boden hat und China sich dort sehr ausgebreitet hat, während die USA das lange Zeit haben schleifen lassen, sich um den Kongo noch weiter zu kümmern. Das ändert sich jetzt aber gerade. Plötzlich ist auch der Kongo wieder im Blick von US-Politik und ja, es gibt entsprechende Ambitionen. Die Chinesen jedenfalls blicken da relativ gelassen drauf. Die werden immer weiter ihre Präsenz ausbauen. Und wenn die Amerikaner jetzt auch doch ein bisschen was abhaben wollen, bitteschön, sie haben sich eigentlich schon den Löwenanteil durch Verträge gesichert. Seit durch die Energiewende heißt es, der industrielle Bedarf weltweit gestiegen ist, nimmt sich die Republik Kongo wie Alibabas Schatzkammer aus. Hier liegen nicht nur 70 Prozent der globalen Kobaltvorkommen, sondern auch Gold, Diamanten, Zink, Mangan, Nickel, Zinn, Wolfram, Tantal und Lithium. In 2000ern haben sich die USA erst mal zurückgezogen. Man hätte ein paar Millionen investieren können, um weiter dort ausbauen zu können. Hat aber gesagt, nö, ist nicht nötig. Da werden hier Experten zitiert, das könnte handelspolitisch der gravierendste Fehler gewesen sein, den die USA je in Afrika begangen haben. 80 Prozent der produktionkritischen Mineralien ist im Besitz von chinesischen Unternehmen oder werden von ihnen betrieben. Die USA versuchen zurückzukommen, aber China ist da im Vorteil, weil man sich schon sehr gut mit den einheimischen Eliten verständigt hat. Man hat einen großen finanziellen Spielraum. Man hat diese Deals angeboten, nämlich dass man Infrastruktur ausbaut für den Kongo, dafür aber dann entsprechende Extraktionsrechte erhält. Es heißt hier, dass von Seiten der Amerikaner auch private Initiativen laufen, weil man doch sieht, Lithium ist uns wichtig. Das unter anderem von Jeff Bezos und Bill Gates finanzierte Start-up Cobalt Metals erhielt die Abbaurechte für Lithium in Manono im Südosten Kongos. Man hat aber auch das Problem natürlich, dass diese ganze Ausbeutung der Bodenschätze große Klimaschäden verursacht, dass man es mit Schmutz und Trinkwasser zu tun haben. Und was man ja auch nicht vergessen darf, es gibt einen Krieg. Da heißt es der Krieg gegen die von Rwanda unterstützte M23 Miliz in Kongos Osten hat sich seit der Unterzeichnung des Washingtoner Abkommens weiter intensiviert. Die Zahl der Vertriebenen, die zuletzt stark gesunken war, steigt wieder an. Zudem wurde die Lage in der nordöstlichen Provinz Ituri gar nicht in den Blick genommen. Hier haben die mit der Terrororganisation IS-verbündeten Elliott Democratic Forces eine Schreckensherrschaft errichtet. Wenn man das so liest, wenn man sieht, wie dort Millionen in Beschlag genommen werden durch diesen Terror und die Weltmächte das versuchen, unter sich aufzuteilen, denkt man immer, es ist so unglaublich nochmal, wie sehr Afrika zerrüttet wird von von so vielen verschiedenen Kräften und wie wir da auch noch unseren Anteil dran haben, aber nicht alleine, sondern das ist ja eine eine so verquervermachtete Konstellation da, dass man das immer so staunend lies, aber so gar nicht ein noch ausweis, wenn man das rezipiert.
Tja, da brauchen wir eine neue Theorie der neuen Bonapartes, aber als Wirtschaft.
Also auch das, ja.
Wenn ich da schon höre, Jeff Bezos hat eine Firma, die da einfach sich die Rechte sich und so.
Bill Gates zusammen. Das ist auch wieder eine Konstellation. Nun zum Schluss Musik, sehr gute Musik von dem Pianisten Alexander Malofeev. Er hat ein Album herausgebracht, das heißt Forgotten Melodies. Es ist ein Album, das vier Künstler, vier russische Komponisten, die im Exil lebten, miteinander verbindet. Es ist ein Doppelalbum, also zwei CDs, wenn man es physisch kauft.
Für sie wirklich Forgotten. Hast du sie zum ersten Mal gehört, als du das gehört hast?
Nein. Also nicht alles kannte ich. Aber diese Komponisten sind nicht vergessen, sondern einzelne Stücke hier, die hervorgeholt werden, die sind Forgotten. Und es liegt aber auch daran, dass man hier einen Titel wählte, der mit dem Werk identisch ist von Nikolaj Mettner, einer der Komponisten. Das heißt nämlich Forgotten Melodies Op.38, das gespielt wird. Alexander Malofeev ist ein sehr begabter Pianist, der jetzt auch die großen Säle füllt. Er spielt auf diesem Album Glinka, Metna, Achmaninov und Glasonov. Ich bin hingerissen von diesen Interpretationen. Es sind Tänze darunter, Romanzen, Preludes, Sonaten. Es ist eine Musik, die man jetzt nicht so rubrizieren kann, weil wir es ja mit vier unterschiedlichen Komponisten zu tun haben, die aber durchaus in einer Traditionslinie stehen. In diesen Musiken jedenfalls können wir eine Sehnsucht nach der Heimat hören, aber auch eine Verzweiflung darüber, dass diese Heimat nicht mehr da ist. Es ist toll, wie präzise Malofeev die einzelnen Töne uns zum Teil hinstellt, aber dann auch ihre Fragilität zeigt, wie auch wenn er laut wird am Klavier, diese Verzweiflung sichtbar ist. Jeder Ton hat da seine Berechtigung, seine eigene Interpretation bekommt er. Das ist wahnsinnig feinsinnig. Es ist wunderschöne Musik, die mitreißend sein kann, die melancholisch wütend ist. Es sind tatsächlich Komponisten, die ich jetzt auf dem Klavier zu selten höre, muss ich dann sagen. Ich bin froh, dass Malofeev uns diese Komponisten wieder ins Ohr spielt. Ich empfehle diese Musik sehr.
Gut, dann hören wir das alles für eine bessere Welt und hören uns dann Ende des Monats wieder, wenn mal wieder eine Deadline abgelaufen ist von Donald Trump.
Wir sind gespannt. Bis dahin.